Hello, hello I know it's been a while I just said I was
going to I was going to say I was like Oh, I'm going to take
a couple of days off Because my social battery was really
low And then I ended up disappearing for like half the week
So I have a perfectly good explanation for this For those
who don't follow me on Twitter And we're like, what the fuck
happened to her?
And also don't look at my community posts But basically I
don't know what I did But in the beginning of the week I
fucked up my tooth I don't and it's like And it's like the
back molars too.
So it's not painful.
Like, it's not really painful, painful.
Well, like, okay, if I like put pressure on it, it is.
But like, it's very rare that I would put pressure on it.
I could eat very fine.
Like, if I switch cold water, like, I don't feel any pain
from switching cold water on it.
So, I don't know what I did.
But I think I like, I think I it i think because when i was
like getting my tongue to feel around it there is a oh god
oh god i just touched it i i can't help it i touched it um
it is movable which is concerning one of the pieces is
movable so i and it feels it feels so weird so one of the
pieces I think, because like, when I first didn't I crack,
when I got my tongue, um, like when I used my tongue to feel
it, um, it like, it like, I could feel like a lie, you know?
Like, I was like, this is, I was like, this is one tooth.
Why do I feel a line across that tooth?
So I got really worried because I was like, this is not
normal.
So, yeah.
I called and made an appointment, but the earliest
appointment I could get was on Tuesday.
So I gotta wait till Tuesday to, like, have that looked at.
So I'm tanking it right now.
Don't worry.
Like I said, it's not painful.
I am, like, very paranoid right now, because I am, like,
rubbing my tongue around my teeth, not just, like, the,
like, I'm trying to avoid the, I'm trying to avoid the,
like, the affected tooth, but I am, like, super paranoid and
anxious now because I read remember I told you guys I read
this thing where like if you rub your tongue against your
teeth it's actually bad for your teeth because you'll end up
eroding it and uh eroding it and also like pushing your
teeth too much but I can't help ever since I read that and
then what happened to my tooth I keep rubbing my tongue
against my yeah I I keep rubbing it I'm trying not to I was
like no don't you stop doing that I was just like and I'll
like but what if i do i was like give me a sec uh sorry i
have to answer this message real quick
uh sorry i had to i have to answer this work message real
quick sorry okay here you go here you go all right back i'm
back to my story um anyway anyway so it the feeling it's
such a weird feeling because it's like I said it's not
painful it's like it's like it's like something's wrong I
could feel something's wrong on that too and like it's like
throbbing but not a pain throb like sometimes it'll throb
but it's not pain throb it's like I'm here you know it's
like i'm here look remember it's like i'm here remember me
pay attention to me like that type of throbbing it's not
like pain throb it's just like remember me throb yeah yeah
it's not painful yeah yeah it's like irritating it's like i
guess it's like it is it's like i think my gums on that area
might be swollen i don't know i can't tell i can't i can't
tell at all uh simple it thank you for the super chat yeah
it's so fucking needy right now um thank you it was super
chat thank you thank you hi doggy just want to let you know
you were my most watched channel the year on youtube take
this money and go get your toothpicks thank you thank you
thank you thank you yeah okay so i don't have dental
insurance so so um yippie so i'm gonna find out how much
it's gonna cost me because if you guys didn't know dentists
are like the top five most well-paid jobs out there so whoa
can't wait to see the bill no i should get insurance soon i
really should i thank you thank you thank you stop touching
it you will break it i learned the hard way thank you super
chat thank you thank you the thing is okay it's really up
but my parents never got me health insurance they just they
kept i need you guys to know this my never got me health
insurance since I was little they so I just I've just been
like it's just been a gotcha whether or not I'll get sick
guys I didn't even have a fam like I've never I haven't had
a family doctor since I was 10 because like because like
that's when we started moving around So they're like you
don't need a family doctor We'll just go to a doctor
whenever you're sick and like you'll never get sick So No,
no one's even more messed up You know Canadians technically
have free health care My mom never renewed my health care
card since I was seven That
up the hard way Cause like um Cause like you know I had to
go to the hospital I'm glad to go to the hospital for some
stuff.
And, oh yeah, for a checkup.
Yeah, because you guys remember I had that cough thing for a
very long time.
So, like, I wanted to go to the hospital to get medication
for it for my seasonal asthma.
And then I think this was, like, last year.
And then, like, I gave them my care card.
Because all Canadians technically have a care card.
And then they looked at my care card.
And they're like, man, this card.
like has like this card is very expiring and i was just like
huh and they're like yeah um we your card like is very old
and like we don't use this card anymore for those who don't
know so the old there's a new care card system in canada now
where it's like um you can i don't remember what it is but
it's like it has a photo on it so my care card is a very old
version expired for more than a decade so like I have the
really old care card where it just has the number the your
insurance like the health number and um and the new care
card is the one where it has a photo of you so I don't have
that because my care card um is so old that like I have
apparently um it expired when I was like seven or eight
years old
Try to renew it.
I try to renew it at the, at the, what's it called?
The, the, oh my gosh.
What is it called?
The driver's license place.
Oh my God, driver license.
Oh, what's that word called?
The, the driver license place in Canada.
The, uh, no, no.
It's America.
America is called DMV, but we have our own name.
own name for it what is it called my canadian brothers and
sisters what is it we don't call it the dmv we call it icbc
yeah oh wait yeah because it uh because like um i'm on west
coast so we call it the i'm on west coast yeah so we call it
the uh you'll be like oh my god docs guys there's like
barely any i think like everyone knows like i'm on the west
coast like i was like what other provinces are in the west
coast in canada like what's the um uh so we call it uh she's
in canada oh my god okay so um we call it the icbc so i was
just like oh Oh, like, you can get your care card renewed at
the Canadian DMV.
I can't believe Turkey is Canadian.
I know, right?
No, you can.
For those who don't know, you can technically, you can get
your care card renewed at the Canadian DMV.
So they're like, oh, yeah, we can, because they were like,
when I was renewing my drive, license they were like um we
need to see your care card for like uh for like reference so
like like for like identifying people um because they and
then I gave them because they're like the care card was one
of the uh the documents that you have to give them to renew
your driver's license um like one of the like evidence that
you can use that it's that says it's you so I gave them my
care card and they're like bro this is fucking oh okay they
didn't say that but they're like card I gave them and
they're like we don't use this anymore they're like bro we
don't use like why do you still have this card like we need
like they're like okay we can renew your care card because
we don't use this card anymore because apparently it looks
different now i don't really know what the care cards
oh um it's like an ancient relic okay it's yeah it's like a
fucking ancient relic um so they're like yeah we can um we
can renew this for you because we're not you're not you're
not supposed to use this anymore so so because so I was just
like oh okay and then I gave them you know I gave them like
um um I gave them information and they're like yeah we're
gonna um we're gonna go send your card to get renewed and
then by the way I didn't get it renewed because I got I
don't remember exactly the what the mail message was but
they like they're like sorry miss we couldn't renew your
card because It was like something where like this card is
so old that you'll have to reapply to be in the care card
system.
Because they're like, you have not renewed your card in so
long.
We need you to reapply to be back into the system.
And I'm like, oh, no.
So I have to do that one day.
They're like, we couldn't give you, we had so like, don't
even have the free healthcare.
I had to have, like, since I was eight years old, I have not
renewed my card.
are you even a citizen at this point like you don't even
exist in the system that's crazy I have to I have to redo my
card I have to reapply to be part of the system to be part
of the Canadian healthcare system uh it's so old um anyway
so that was a two to three months ago I should really um hun
george thank you for the super chat thank you thank you time
to crowdfund a new new teeth thank you the super chat thank
you thank you the holy canadian without healthcare dango
thank you the super chat thank you thank you um it's cost 11
billion dollars us dollars thank you the super chat thank
you thank you delta thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i gotta help my number one most watched youtuber
youtube created pay for dental work thank you for the think
this is the worst part about being like self-employed i
can't give myself free dental technically you guys fund my
dental i can't give myself a 401k and like dental free
dental privileges i have to pay for my own from it on my own
pocket um next to you thank you super chat thank you thank
you well i'm sure you can i mean you could get dental
insurance i could uh I just gotta figure out how to do all
that because like I said, I'm like a little baby chucked
into the adult world Zonderman, thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
I feel like I'm slacking you, Sierra, but I'm still in the
top 0.1 watch percent somehow.
Go now, by the way, for Dental.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like I said, um, um, sorry, my chief was being weird, so I
couldn't help but like chomp down.
Like, I don't know.
Like, I should stop doing that.
Like, I just want to like chomp down because my like when
like two feels weird i just want to be like i know i
shouldn't touch it it's like it's like when you have a scab
wound and you want to pick it like you're like you know you
know it's bad you know it's so bad but you just want to pick
it because you're like what if it just gets better like like
maybe if i destroy the scab the skin will just heal itself
you know like that's how i that's how i still am i'm like
what if i just pick it or like when you're like supposed to
squeeze a pimple and you're like oh but what if you know
you're not supposed to squeeze or scratch this pimple
because it'll uh first off uh it's really bad because like
it might spread to somewhere else because it's like you know
the reason why it's a pimple is because all the bacteria um
all the bacteria grows in that one spot so you're not
supposed to push on it or scratch it because then it could
lead to uh we can lead somewhere else on your face um but
then you're like thinking okay but when if i pop it though
oh and also it'll scar it to that's how you get scars um so
so like i can't help it it's like i just wanted oh i just
wanted to go um uh bourbon thank you thank you thank you
okay but what if yeah but what if i'll just wash my hands
after right that's how it works um angriest thank you with a
super chat thank you thank you i see a lump on your gum line
you need to go get a check please that's probably a push
build up thank you thank you thank you i don't know it's
like all the way in the back too so it's like you know at
the it's like literally the furthest tooth at the very back
of my left jaw the top left jaw so i can't if it was like a
bottom jaw it's very easy to see it but it's like the it's
the molar it's the molar at the very back at the top so i
don't i can't even see it no i got my wisdom teeth removed
um so like i don't know what's going on But yeah, if it's a
root canal, I'm, I, oh my gosh, I'm just going to expect the
worst because I feel like today, this year has been a very
unlucky year for me.
Because of course, I was like, oh, what's the worst that can
happen at the last month of the year?
Like, oh, my, the bad year is almost over.
And then, of course, I fuck up my tooth on the last, on the
last month.
I fuck up my tooth.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Of course I jinxed.
I was like, oh, the year's almost over.
Surely nothing else bad is going to happen to me.
Then I had to crack my tooth somehow.
I don't know how, but it just happened.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, right on the last month.
Thank God it wasn't during the holidays.
Because I had to wait for the dentist to come back for
Christmas or the New Year's or some shit.
Oh, yeah, I got one more in me the new the year.
Yeah, so that's why I've been missing for half the week
because, like, I was just, like, it was just bothering me so
much.
And I was like, oh, I think, and I've got the appointment.
And I was like, and then appointment is like next week.
So I was just like, oh, fuck, I can tank this.
Because it's not painful yet.
That's just like, it's just annoying when I'm talking.
Like, sometimes I could feel like the presence of that, too.
But sometimes I don't, like right now, I don't feel it.
Right now, it feels normal.
But, like, it would just randomly, like, show itself.
It'd be like, oh, you're not paying attention to me.
And it starts, like, like, I guess, like, it just starts
throbbing.
But not painful throb.
Just be, like, pay attention to me, throb.
Yeah, and I should get a new card, too.
I should really get a new care card.
I should be back in the system.
Because they're like, oh, there's always, whenever I go do
some, like, health stuff, they'll be like do you have your
care card with you and i was like yeah i was like no because
like um you know they're like oh so and then they assume you
just want it off the record because obviously if you have
your care card thing like medication and prescriptions are a
lot cheaper so they'll just they're like oh you want it off
like off your receipt you don't want it in your records i
was like yeah i don't want it in my yeah yeah definitely i
just i just don't want it in It's not like I don't exist in
the records.
I just don't want it in my records.
Riki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Actually, I prefer my crown to my realty, but wishful
thinking, maybe they can just fuse it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They don't know that I might not have a record, so they just
think I want it off the record.
James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, it comes naturally with getting all the things
no big timbers never get all of them i am forever thank you
i'm going to your funeral think of a super chat thank you
thank you like whoa whoa uh that's all right thank you a
super chat thank you thank you all right anyway let's let's
go play some haiti's uh yeah we're timeless what
Um, anyway, guys, Hades time!
Um, so, I did spoil myself a little bit, because apparently
a lot of people, I saw the reviews, and apparently a lot of
people are very disappointed in the ending.
Like, everyone likes, like, the gameplay and everything, but
apparently the ending is very...
Oh, is it loud?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, guys.
Ha-ha.
All right.
I don't know, Sound Guy.
Sound Guy, are you alive?
Um, did it fix it?
Oh, they changed it already.
is better okay that's good never mind jk when did they fix
it when did they oh they fixed it oh oh my god i thought the
game was fully released was it recently oh they reconned it
nice okay that's good see that's one that see guys see it's
good to like wait not play it on release especially for
katies i knew like um oh a month ago okay that's good i knew
like okay for games like okay i'm gonna tab out for games
like haiti's the reason why i didn't play out like didn't
play while they were updating it because like you know um
they had early access and everything and i didn't even play
when the game fully released is that i knew they were gonna
keep patching it like i felt like haiti's was the type of
game that they were gonna keep patching it keep changing
things over and over again so like that's why i didn't
bother to play it for a while um so that's why like i waited
until then because they always fixed a lot of things they
always like kept patching and everything and i just want to
experience it um as the game that they want me to experience
it versus like them recording everything because i feel like
i don't want to come back to it you know i i didn't want to
like come back they're like like forced me to come back to
it because i'm like when i finish the game it's finished
like it's like how maybe I'll finally play Tarkov because
you can finally escape from Tarkov.
Did you guys know that the game has finally released like
this month last month or some shit and they they finally put
a mission in there where you can escape from Tarkov.
Yeah it ends there's actually an end game like yeah I saw
like yeah it actually has an end game and after after five
plus years You can finally escape from Tarkov.
No way.
Title drop.
Yeah.
They finally added that in.
So last month and people were like making it a big deal
because it definitely takes, it took this guy two weeks.
It took like this like pro escape from Tarkov streamer.
Two weeks of nonstop playing to complete the mission.
to escape from Tarkov and I was just like bro what do you
mean it takes two weeks of like five like I don't know ten
plus hours of gaming to escape from fucking Tarkov like yeah
so I'm like oh my god we're just yeah just that fucking
mission of and he got the bad ending dude that's like you
can see that's so fucking long and there's one out of four
and just walk out five have you has he ever considered just
flying out you know has ever considered just walking out
there's clearly Tarkov can't be that big guys what if he
just walks out yeah it took two weeks of non-stop playing
just to get the worst ending possible while escaping anyway
Anyway, let's play Hades too.
I hope Sound Guy is here.
Oh my god.
Wait, where, which one is?
I would assume it's the 11th?
Okay, why do I have two saves?
Wait a minute.
Okay, okay.
10th May, I assume it's May 10th.
What is, what, what does this mean?
What does the staff mean?
I'm confused.
Okay, I'm at night, I assume it's night six, right?
No, we're going back in.
I'm not restarting this.
What do you mean I played early access?
What do you mean?
I played early access.
Guys, it's literally on my channel.
I played the first early access.
Okay.
We'll do this one because it's 10.
What's like night six?
Is that like how many?
It's only six.
Restart, please.
Do you even remember?
Guys, do I really?
Okay.
But guys, I have all my stuff in there.
But the Lord.
Okay, fine.
I'll restart.
Fine.
But all my stuff.
What's the point?
I got all my stuff, though.
I...
A few tales of whose reign as grim lord of the dead came
to...
All right, here you go.
once his past caught up with him i don't think it did
because everything's at a hundred history repeats see guys
pure pressure and bullying works guys
deaf to kronos
okay oh yeah because his his like dad like his entire family
got kidnapped or something what's this i restored it all
right proceed
oh nice money oh this is so easy
okay space is jump okay that's good all right oh my god it's
like this is a tutorial level or some shit oh my god okay
he's still fucking tanky though okay it runs right click I
feel like this weapon was not in the early access.
This weapon is too good.
It was?
Okay, maybe I definitely forgot everything.
The thing I love about this game the most is that I don't
have the voice act.
Alright.
What do I get?
Your attack deals more damage in larger areas.
faster whatever you cast expires restore it I feel like more
damage more damage is always good but more damage is always
nice all right yeah money I feel like I have not I did
definitely did not use this as my main weapon I'm like I
don't remember I don't remember this There you go.
Oh, what did I get?
What is this?
Mostly used to unlock.
Oh, yeah, that's why.
Alright.
Back up.
We go.
Are the enemies new?
I'm just like, wait, are you new?
Guys, I literally don't remember.
You're like, you look new.
And then they're like, they've always been in this game,
Doki.
Are you new?
No.
Oh, hey, golden coin.
Money.
Yippee.
Our new stuff is mostly later.
Okay.
Okay, I remember these guys.
These guys I remember.
Okay, there's a lot of things on my screen right now.
No, not.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
I still have a lot of HP.
God, I hate the clutter.
Clutter is the fucking worst.
Okay, nice.
More ashes.
Wait, what's this?
Okay, this is...
Oh, this is the heart... Okay, this is money.
Shop?
Okay, let's get an upgrade.
I can charge my cat.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Well, wasted that.
Oh, it's a screen off-center?
No, it is.
Oh, wait, it is.
Oops.
Wait, is it?
Oh, shit.
Oopsie.
That means Rivals was off-center, too.
Is it better now?
That means I streamed Rivals last, like, on Tuesday.
It was also...
Wait, actually, was it?
Okay, I gotta check this out.
How bad was it?
How off-centered was Rivals when I streamed it for seven
hours?
I don't think...
I like how nobody noticed it, too, for Rivals.
That's the best part.
part.
Oh, it wasn't that.
Wait, yeah, it wasn't that noticeable.
Oh, wait, it is.
It is the top part.
Wait, is it?
Oh, yeah, no.
You can tell because, like, nobody noticed it, too.
That's the best part.
It's just slightly weird.
You guys are just so distracted by Venom.
No one noticed that Rivas was also offset.
I like how everyone noticed in the 80s.
Oh, shit.
Okay, this...
Oh, what the?
What the fuck?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I don't know how to kill.
Okay, that was unlucky.
Oh, okay.
I just got it.
Wee!
Okay.
This is actually bad.
I think I might be.
No, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh my god, this is so bad for me.
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Everything is fine.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
I did just skip her.
Oh, yeah, the reason why...
Oh.
I shall freeze hell in its entirety if that is what it takes
to get her back.
I'm so healthy.
Okay, so...
The reason why the rival's bot got, like, copyright muted is
because apparently this...
The Rivals song that they sing in Times Square is, um, is,
uh, what's it called?
It's DMCA-able.
So, so, which is crazy because it's, it's like, because like
Rivals at Twitch have such a close relationship.
So I didn't, like, it's fucking crazy that the songs, the
main Rivals Day song is like copyrightable.
Grandmother.
Your murder damage.
and repeatedly deals damage to foes in the binding circle
use sprint forms a gust of wait how long how how many how
how many times have i like okay what game did i play oh it's
because of sonic it's because of shadow the hedgehog okay it
was just because of my last game uh that i streamed on
youtube that was like that sorry i had to like check all
right which one is arctic ring the best Your cast and flicks
freeze repealing deal.
Oh, yeah, that's good.
We'll get that.
Okay, so I'm not feeling very healthy.
I am not feeling healthy at all.
Okay, as long as, like, he doesn't touch me, we should be
fine.
Wee!
Okay.
That is fine.
As long as they don't get near me.
No touchy.
Oh, oh, hey, I said no touchy!
You fucking spawn did you guys see that you fucking spawn in
front of me That's fucking illegal, bro Catch it catch this
All right, nice money All right.
Oh, hey.
Oh heels.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Uh, I don't remember what this is.
So I'm gonna go get heels That's here.
No, wait.
That's Aphrodite, right?
Is that Aphrodite or is that is that here?
that's Aphrodite the naked oh neither is he was yeah I knew
that was that's like it's either Aphrodite or he is which is
better the boon or I know I know you guys are gonna fucking
say Aphrodite because she's half naked okay maybe not half
naked is like me being generous she's fully naked uh up is I
feel like no you guys are biased you guys are fucking biased
like what no
Yes, and I'm winning you And that's how I like it That's
right That's why I'm giving you what you want
That's right Not that easy You gotta work for it If you want
Aphrodite You guys were the ones that wanted me to start if
I couldn't play on my own save I ain't giving you Aphrodite
that's what you get oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
that's fine oh my god no it was so fast okay it's fine I
wanted to die
That's what you get.
No Aphrodite, no life.
At the end, it didn't matter.
Just ignore everyone, continue your last name with all your
stuff.
Okay, thank you.
It was a super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I've committed.
I remember her.
You know what?
You're right.
I died.
I'm going back.
Did they add anything?
Okay, but first off, before I go back, did they add anything
new in the beginning?
Cal would it do it.
You guys want to know what happens in the beginning?
You guys wanted to know you can watch the first five.
I think they, I feel like they don't, Oh no, why don't you
find up?
Please stay.
Who dares to stir my eternal rest?
Also, everything was a hundred during the last save.
So like, I turned it up by a bit though.
So like...
Alright, so this was the options for audio.
It's literally all a hundred.
Alright, they added more trees.
Are you really gonna make me replay this?
us for more trees all right do you really want me pre-play
the first chapter just because it has more trees yes yes we
love trees oh i remember her to slay our enemy last night on
a new moon no less look at the new trees to hokey i lack
such forgiveness for my failure had mistress hegity the
titan yet lives and olympus yet burns while i'm back where i
started yes recovered bodily if not in spirit and grown
wiser for it you've not failed merely begun this is all part
of the task death death to chronos death to chronos yeah
death to chronos tell me you killed the bastard drove your
staff into his wretched skulls with a dagger in his gut oh
god thank you for the We're at a good stream.
Kronos, the titan of time, is vanquished, Odysseus.
I have his head right here.
At least.
I wish I did.
Well, you'll get him next time, I reckon.
It's okay, we'll get closer.
Oh, there he is, sleeping.
There's Hypnos.
Oh, wait, I don't remember this.
I mean, I remember him, but I don't remember this part.
This asset.
That's new.
Oh, yeah, and then I can have a guard.
and later.
Alright.
This one.
Don't remember what this is.
Okay, you...
Oh, this is the roguelike part.
Okay.
You deal 20.
Okay, I like damage.
I don't need to be.
You're after you... Oh, restart.
Wait.
We need HP.
And then...
Okay.
And then what else do I have?
Do I have more?
Okay, I don't have more.
That'll do.
Can you stay there for a little longer?
Look at the trees they added.
Yo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, my gosh.
I mean, it does look a lot prettier.
Now that it's, like, out of early access.
The arms of night are now at my disposal.
Okay, so...
I don't have money for this.
Guys, remember when I had all these weapons, guys?
I remember.
Oh, there he is.
you have many battles yet to come the only question is are
you prepared to win hell yeah i am so let's see you give me
12.
20 that's a lot you're certain it's acceptable for me to
strike you 20 times in front of all your students dead
certain now hit me with everything you got as you will sir
all right there's that and then they're special and then oh
wait oh my god okay that ensnars okay so q is my q is my
special uh my special move and then there's that hold q what
does holding q do hold q to ensnare and destroy oh what's q
hold q why does it work oh i don't have enough magic that's
why okay give me my magic hello i am low in magic how do you
restore magic hello sir oh that's not magic okay that's the
exit death to chronos i'll see to that no one is more
prepared beyond the mists of arabus there should be a way
down i was like how do i get more magic leaves
it's time all right all right oh yeah no oh restart there we
go magic back okay
oh i could do that i don't i think i i definitely forgot
like 80 of the game all right i was like oh my god over i
talked over all these controls All right, let's go.
I guess we leave now.
We leave.
Go out.
880%?
That's maybe 99%.
Oh, hey, Poseidon.
You're one of my father's brothers, aren't you?
Then help him.
In the name of Hades, Olympus, I accept this message.
Oh, okay, wait.
Sound guy wants me to adjust my shit real quick.
All right.
Last time.
Music to 60%.
Oh my god, that's hearing me.
60.
Ambulance 80.
Uh, sound effects to 65.
Okay, that should be good.
And then we'll raise overall.
Uh, all right, let me know if it's better.
Yeah, the only thing I remember was Aphrodite.
We thought you met the same fate as your father.
for poor old Hades and his kin.
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry, Uncle.
I'll do that.
Your cast also meaning you hit foes with powerful splash and
like fourth.
Your special hit foes with a splash and knock out your
attack hit foes.
I feel like I should do an attack, right?
I'm gonna do attack.
Alright.
Nice, triple kill.
Boom.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I used to blow up my magic.
that's that's not what I wanted to do oh wait is this new I
feel like this is new I remember restoring my mana and shit
and then you're like dokey it's been there since early
access dokey it was always there dokey said thank you super
chat thank you thank you first time catching one of your
streams and it's my favorite game no less when you see you
so good you might get addicted I got addicted to...
I get addicted to all roguelikes.
I'm not...
I won't be surprised.
I love roguelikes in general.
So I don't know how long I'll be playing this for today.
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I wanted.
I just wanted to send that out.
Oop.
Alright.
Nice.
Uh, Poseidon.
What was this?
What was this one again?
Oh.
Also, Zora, thank you for the gifted chip.
Thank you, thank you.
Max mana?
I don't think I need that.
I'll go get Poseidon.
I'll talk to my uncle.
I need to stop using my...
I need to stop using my mana.
Because my mana...
Because if I hold it, it takes out my mana, right?
I feel like that's such a waste.
Alright.
Nice.
uncle give me free stuff oh they refill every room okay you
cast also melee hits foes with a powerful flash your splash
effects from all oh which one do i get your special what's
my special is my special the right click or q your splash
effects from beside and also okay is um oh hey boon i'll get
the
Okay, special is right click.
Caskets.
Alright, I just wanted to be sure.
Oh.
No, no, no.
No touchy.
No touchy because I don't regen.
Or do I?
I think I do, actually.
Okay, nice.
Alright, refreshes every rune so I can be more...
more relaxing with my magic.
Boon time!
Wave strikes, your attack hits first.
I'm gonna do a water strike.
What's this?
Is that Apollo?
Do Apollo.
Boom.
Actually...
Okay.
Might as well.
I haven't used Q yet.
Alright.
Boom!
Okay.
These guys are slow, so it'd be easy to kill.
See?
Look at him.
Just standing there.
Fucking idiot.
Apollo!
Do bind your time, sunshine.
The Titan thinks he has us pinned, but we have the situation
here under control.
Just locked in a bit of a stalemate is all.
Yeah, it'll be okay.
That's why we're depending it all on this bastard child.
A blinding rush.
Your sprint is faster and flicked days on surrounding foes.
Whenever your cast expires, restores magic.
Your cast expands in size until they expire.
Do we want to recover?
Two, right?
For the recovery?
She's explicitly not a bastard.
Oh my god, fucking course.
It gives me Aphrodite.
Well, yeah, I say that.
Sorry, sorry.
My dad was the bastard child.
Sorry.
It was my father.
Shit, I need free forgetting about it.
God damn it.
Are you fucking okay?
It's fine.
Okay, we still do.
Nice.
In the name of Hades.
Olympus, I accept this message.
Alright, nice.
Alright, you get your...
Whoa.
See, that's why we all remember Aphrodite.
Alright.
Your special deals more damage to you.
nearby foes your cast inflicts weak and damaged foes while
dragging them towards the center rushing damages i feel like
rapturing right inflict weak because it's an epic i wasn't
done admiring right we should get that one too i have much
to learn from her i think oh another flower nice yoink boon
info oh it's just like what upgrades I got for my stuff.
Wait, what did I get for this?
Your cast?
That's my cue, right?
Yeah, I need to use my cue more.
Bam!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I'm... Okay, maybe I should use my cue less.
Okay.
Like, the cue actually almost fucked me up there.
Uh, that's heals, right?
Oh, What's this one again?
It immediately fumbles.
What is this one?
Oh, give some more upies.
Okay, no problem.
All right, I brought it up a bit more.
HP?
I feel like more max HP.
I have enough money for items, I'm pretty sure.
Right?
Shop tab.
Oh, wait, you must have art now.
Oh, he has art.
Remember him?
He used to be, like, question mark.
I'm in your debt, Lord Karan.
Yeah, he has.
He has art now.
Can I borrow some money?
Please, I'm so poor.
Plus 12.
I mean...
Oh my god, he actually has...
Wait, what's this?
Wait, that's new.
What is that?
He looks so cool.
Yeah, I'm broke.
I'm broke right now.
I only have $81.
I mean, I might as well just buy the food.
I don't have money anyway.
Yeah, I'm princess of hell is poor right now.
Brokey bird.
Yeah, he was a play solo during the first early access.
What's this?
I've never seen this one before.
Ash?
This is ash, right?
But what is this, though?
They're just upgrade stuff?
I'll just get ash.
Then.
Yeah, because we're still in early.
Anyway.
Like, there's no way I'm gonna get it.
get through this run.
Toki, you just gotta believe in your- No, no, this is my
second run.
There's no way.
I- Oh, shit.
I have trouble believing that we're gonna make it through
the second run.
We're gonna get to the end.
What was this?
Wait, what's this?
Yeah, I believe.
Are more upies?
All right, I updated a little bit more.
Is this money?
All right, let's go to Aphrodite.
Where are you freaks out there?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I'm not hitting him.
I'm like, why am I not doing damage?
I don't understand.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have to hold it for so long.
Goodness.
Alright.
Get out of here.
all right passion oh she doesn't talk to me anymore she's
just she doesn't want to talk to us anymore she's like oh
now that i know why you're here you got earned my he got
earned my png rushing damage surrounding flows inflix
against you deal more damage while you have at least 80
percent help the bonus is you deal more damage you're
attacking power but you prime what the fuck is prime 20 you
made her what do you mean i made her upset what is Prime 20.
Actually, how much you had...
Jesus Christ.
Why is there like 20 fucking notes on this?
I am an anti now for Aphrodite.
Oh!
Okay, that's cool.
It costs less.
Ash, right?
Yeah, Ash.
Oh, hey.
Yoink.
I'm gonna steal your plants.
There you go.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I don't have a lot of magic.
I just realized that.
But I'm stronger, right?
It's worth it, right?
I'm stronger.
But it means I'm stronger.
Okay.
Makes mad unusual for this run.
Wait, then what's the fuck is that point?
Yeah, but I should be stronger with it.
Okay, heart, chop.
I have not... I don't think I can afford anything.
I only have $90.
I'm just gonna grab... I'll grab Max Health.
Yeah.
I'll grab Health just because I don't have...
Um... I don't even have like... Oh shit, we're at there.
Okay, we're gonna get absolutely destroyed.
God's mistress.
Hello.
There she is.
Oh, it's a test before she sends me out to the real world.
Dang it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I like the art in this game, but I always bother me how
everyone looks like they have some mutant form of super and
Juanese.
What's super Juanese?
I could not have reached this point without your guidance.
And in turn, you shall not pass this point without a
demonstration on the game.
Please, Hecatee, I don't have insurance.
My capability.
You'd have us face each other here, even though my task has
already begun.
Training shall never be complete and I would know if you
stand any chance at all against our enemy Yeah Don't
remember it.
Oh shit.
I forgot.
Oh, I forgot a fighter Oh
Oh shit Look now upon the moon.
Oh my god.
I don't remember it Please I don't remember how to fight you
please Oh my god, I don't remember these witches.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Oh my god, how did she know?
Oh god, oh god, no, not Toho.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't do well with Toho, please.
Oh god.
Oh!
That's fine.
it's fine
it's so fine oh shit what the fuck is that what the fuck is
that what the fuck no I'm a sheep no no oh shit oh shit no
no please I'm just a little guy
okay this is not fair this is not fair it's not how you
treat your fucking Could apprentice!
Okay.
Oh,
God.
Okay, it's fine Where is she?
Oh god, oh god
Oh god Oh god Please don't get Oh,
I did it!
Oh, that was one hit!
Oh,
one hit!
And with ferocity Oh, it's so slow Beyond this threshold Oh,
okay, sounds how is the volume okay now i look forward to it
head mistress i fucking hate toho can you not join me no i
dare not stray too far from our abode bro i think about 20
get the chance they can thank you oh we did it thank you
head mistress i was living on the thread there oh my god we
did it we passed the test now i'm worthy thank god think the
Fucking gods, I'm worthy now.
Where do I go?
Restore, please.
Oh, just 11 HP.
That's fine.
That's all I need.
See, present Doki is a better gamer than past Doki.
See, I leveled up.
Oh, I remember.
I hated this.
This is the bad area, too.
I remember I hated this boss.
Good music, though.
The underworld plunges deeper than the deepest sea.
Yet there are such places where the edge of one and the
other meet.
I just remember the band was really hard.
I also...
Oh, yeah.
No, I'm so fucking weak.
Yeah.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
I'm so weak in this area.
I'm not supposed to be here, guys.
I barely do any damage.
Holy shit.
Like, why are you here?
You're not supposed to be here yet.
Like, I'm dull.
I know I'm not.
Please forgive me.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, they take fucking forever to kill.
Okay, nice.
I think not.
Oh my god, I stood in front of the trap.
I forgot that they do that.
I was like, how did I?
How am I getting damage?
Yeah, I stepped in the fucking...
I forgot this was a trap there.
This was mana, right?
We don't need magic.
I might as well get the boon.
Oh, God.
What?
Oh, shit!
I was like, why can't I go anywhere?
But it's just...
It's just water.
It's just all water.
Okay.
Let's use this to get...
Out of here.
Okay, that's fine.
Can't touch me.
That's right.
I'm so far away.
Boon time.
Your cast inflicts...
Okay, I should get that to level 2.
The cast was really helpful.
Uh, I have enough for the shop.
Let's just go for the shop.
Hello.
Aphrodite.
Want to talk?
Oh, nope, he doesn't want to talk.
I mean, we might as well grab this.
Oh, now you want to talk to me.
Come on, we all have fantasies, gorgeous.
All right.
Oh, fantasies.
All right, your specialty is more damage to nearby.
That's my right click.
Gushing damages surrounding flows and fleets weak.
And again, once you stop, you deal more damage while you
have at least...
One or two or three, chat.
carefully.
Whoa, fantasies.
Rushing damages surrounding foes and flicks.
What's rushing damages?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, it's my dash.
Might as well grab everything.
Waves strike.
Should we level up our two or...
Or is two or three?
I don't know.
We should get...
Or attack.
Two?
Alright.
Make our attack stronger.
Poseidon or...
Who's that?
Is that...
That's not Apollo.
That's...
Who's that?
I don't know who that is.
I'm gonna go to Poseidon.
Is that Apollo still?
Or is that...
That's Apollo?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Uh, we'll do a Poseidon.
I don't want to fight a boss.
Oh, shit!
Where did they all come from?
It's fine.
Yeah, we're not going into the Elite Room.
I'm really weak right now.
Oh, hit surrounding foe with a powerful splash as they start
to strike, but you prime 30.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Do I really need magic?
Just, yeah, okay, is this a no magic?
Let's do it.
Okay, no magic run.
Let's go.
We don't need magic.
Oh, wait.
Who's that?
Who's the fire?
No, man.
Who the fuck needs magic, guys?
Oh, this one is not a boss room.
Yeah, the no magic run.
Magic's for, oh, shit!
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, magic's for nerds.
Okay, I forgot that's what they do.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
The fire goddess never got involved.
In the name of Hades.
Oh, shit.
The fire goddess is here.
Yeah, that is for nerds.
The magic isn't real, right?
That's new.
The art is new, right?
I don't remember her having a hat.
It's all blasted place to the ground myself.
Now, here's a little warm-up for you.
oh oh game upies okay i'll be more all right let me know if
it's that's better your special inflicts scorch don't
already have a special hose cast aim and fireball that okay
we don't have magic to do that uh you deal more damage that
to foes are nowhere near other foes um guys we can't do two
because we don't have magic we don't do it we can't hold
castle we don't even have magic what what magic
guys stop two doesn't need we don't need magic for two we
don't press q for binding spell that ensures pose and but it
says hold
we are you still oh okay we still oh thank god you don't
need then?
2.
That's projectile cast.
No magic.
Okay.
Don't get one guy.
By who?
The one guy that's telling me that there's no magic or the
one guy that's telling me that it is magic.
There's several one guys here.
3 also nice for bosses.
I think we'll do bosses then.
I'd rather commit to the... Wait, what's this?
Unseal?
Wait, what's this?
Guys, what is this?
I don't want to...
I'm not going to randomly go into the fucking hole.
I have to know that if this was a horror film, I will walk
away.
If I don't know what it is.
Guys, what is this?
Let's find.
It's fun, Joki.
It's really fun.
It's the fun hole.
All right, let's go into the fun hole, I guess.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, it's Ash.
Which is better?
Ash or honey?
Because that's...
Oh, that's for, like, making friends, right?
So we should go with Ash, right?
Don't call it that.
The happy little skull door.
Honey or ash?
Or nectar?
Okay, next day.
What the fuck does these guys do?
It doesn't look like they do anything.
Yeah, I'm gonna make sure these guys get out of here.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, the stupid goddamn vets.
God damn it.
Stupid fucking vets.
Someone fix the fucking ventilation system here.
Oh my god, keep forgetting.
I don't want magic.
They're like, where are you casting for?
This is your goddamn no magic run.
You wanted this, Doki.
Jesus.
Okay, that's fine.
I got the nectar.
Oh, hey, Hammer!
Hammer time!
Hammer's always good.
Okay.
I don't remember what it does, but I remember hammer was
good.
Hammer time.
Okay, I'm stuck in...
Oh, shit!
I don't like this area.
I think I'm, like, stuck in this area.
Oh, you fucking!
Alright.
Oh, stop.
Hammer time.
Her attacks hit two, but uses five.
Well, like, I don't...
Your attacks have...
Okay, I think we gotta do 30 plus.
You can channel 30 magic in here special to deal...
Okay, guys, I think we can only do three.
I think...
Maybe shop because maybe there's HP?
Maybe I'll have HP in the shop.
Nice, okay.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Okay, I think we need the HP.
the health no i need the health yeah it doesn't matter i
thought i had enough ever-present song compels oh yeah we're
not making no i don't i don't know i've tried warriors abyss
yet it's basically haiti subway warriors characters probably
like it i heard of yeah i know a lot of people were
recommending it to me but it doesn't really want to try out
in the future uh kagashi thank you for super chat thank you
thank you okay guys we could I can maybe he has some spare
money just lying around you know come on come on Hades don't
be such a cheapskate come on don't you have oh I have a gift
for you nah I'm not giving the nectar to you come on are
there any spare what's everybody queuing for any spare spare
money I'm the princess of hell any any money six zero out of
zero mana
I'm gonna show up the up the volume more
I'm cheering for the side things guys Mr. Ruffel for kids
think of a super chat thank you thank you Sirens I should
have known you are the source of all that singing Slink down
into the underworld have you It's the perfect pressure down
here Okay up the volume more all right Don't drown your
so-called fans to death Have you even got any left Yeah, but
then there'll be ghosts and there'll be eternal fans.
They can't leave.
They're here forever if they're dead.
You think about it.
Oh my god.
How the fallback?
Okay.
Okay, this is not fair.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is...
is this is not looking so good for it for dokey right now oh
my okay it's okay i'll just kill her bad if her oh god oh
god i hate back dokey i got to halfway
unfinished painting.
Don't look away.
Don't forget all that the Titan took from you.
That's me.
Oh, shit.
I forgot I'm the daughter.
Oh my gosh, I'm the that's my brother.
I forgot.
I thought I was the daughter of the bastard child.
I'm actually the daughter of Hades.
Because that's why it's Hades too.
Because I'm the second Hades.
I'm Hades' second child.
The cauldron's for me now oh hey ruined my concert shake my
head mr mcfluffigan thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you get it that's why it's called haiti's too because
he has two kids now my dad is haiti's too all right let's
see reveal gang twas miss haiti's too persuade a retro
broker to appear Do we want the... Which one do we want?
I guess we can get both.
Yeah, I mean we can we can afford both
Yeah Summon the broker.
Oh, nice.
Okay, we got the broker now.
Welcome to the crossroads All right, we can get The molly
great night reveal now your works within our silver pool
Yay!
Now we can garden!
At least our cauldrons finally purify.
Raise the fates!
Speaking of which, are you as yet considering an invocation
to them?
I have my doubts that they would listen even now.
If there's any chance the three fates shall aid us, I'll
take it.
Thank you for preparing things for me.
Though I'm well short of freshly picked reagents still.
Hmm.
and offer such reagents if i could but as you venture past
this blade look carefully along your path and you shall find
them or can't they help me like why do i need to pay them to
help me i'm literally the princess yes head mistress um they
should help me regardless i should not have to bribe them
hail broker okay so i should buy the ad what's psyche uh
what what's the psyche for like to be mentally stable like
is she a Is this okay?
Not only thank you, but super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry about giving money to a princess.
We'll be paying for taxes.
So rightfully, your fees.
Masha, thank you, this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Going to Oceania sounds like some kind of dirty business.
Thank you, this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, more.
Oh, the cards.
Okay, I'll get the cards.
There you are.
Oh, it's not one time.
Okay.
That's why.
As life have laid down at the bottom of the sea.
nastiness lurking there that the reports make clear i wager
you'd win that wager handily the worst of them has to be
this sea monstrous called skiller and a siren friends they
have this ridiculous act whoa she's a hater whoa just
because they have more fans than you bro still is still
around the sirens no less it's a wonder you made it back
damn she's so she's so
She's so jealous.
Meld the anti-confirmed.
Let's see.
I feel that.
Uh, I mean, I can't afford it.
We have your attack is special.
You have 20.
Oh yeah, let's get that.
That's a lot better.
I don't have enough ash for any of this, so we'll keep.
Yeah, we'll keep all of these four cards.
oh can i afford this something new here oh nice this grabs
the pickaxe reveal to me the bounties of the earth yeah i
can start mining yeah mining time i guess she is again at
last i had to do this again oh wait i can oh i can gift them
who should i
craft okay i have one nectar that i can use to give people
who do we want who do who has the best upgrades skelly okay
we'll give you the nectar then all right commander though it
falls to us to keep the old traditions alive may you partake
of this nectar unburdened by the weight of its significance
oh yes deftifiers wait that's good of both the offering and
of the sentiment I summarily shall do my part.
Behold, the luckiest of my possessions is in your possession
now.
That's right.
I don't give this for free.
It's for, it's exchange.
Oh, wait.
Luckier twos?
Wait, that's not Deft of Fives.
The crossroads training grounds are watched over by fearless
seafarer Skelemius, famed in death as he was famed in life.
I know equipped it.
You cannot fail with such a genius on our side.
Nope.
nope I heard that how do I equip it go to the other case and
equip it where's the fucking case left of the pool left of
the pool oh there it is there's the box how do I equip it
the tooth you're at 20 five with this to rank up wait excuse
me is it is it in my pocket uh is it do i i don't know is it
equipped oh it is okay there you go wait what does it do
after okay nice okay that is death defiance but as a tooth i
don't know how that works but i'll take it go up please wait
what's there why is there a thing here is this me looking up
again
through all that gloom somehow.
Enough talk we go in.
What?
Seal with words?
Oh, I have to go out.
All right, here we go.
Oh, there it is!
Come on, Neng.
Of course.
Of course the first encounter is Aphrodite.
God, she's so obsessed with me.
This family isn't so good at letting go, is it?
After eons of prosperity, She's so obsessed with me, guys.
Yeah, that's my crack tooth.
Wishing damage surrounds.
Do I get Passion Rush?
Do I think that's good?
Or should I save it?
Or do I, like...
I mean, like, I do a lot of dodge.
I'm gonna grab two.
Yeah, guys, she wants me.
It's so bad.
Alright, nice.
Looks like a new path out.
Grab Restore Mana.
Grab the Ash.
Alright, let's get him out of here.
I need to hold more.
Like, I need to use to hold key more.
I feel like it'd be much more useful if I do it more.
I don't know, I'm just so impatient.
I'm way too impatient for it.
That's the worst part.
Why hold when I can damage now?
Nice to go.
Let's get...
You know what?
Oh, what's your name?
Athena.
God, it takes so long, too!
That's the worst part!
I have such... I have a good APM.
I don't want to fucking hold.
Or is the meter?
Oh, it's the meter!
Because I was Athena.
roads got you out of there did she yeah she did that and now
she's gonna beat me up again i don't get it i passed your
test why does she still need a fucking hit me is ice strike
better because i know like the other gods give other stuff
she's so old hey hey the older they are the more experience
they have
Is one?
Nice.
Alright, we definitely want the hammer.
Think about it!
Yeah.
Nobody smack-talk my grandma like that!
Your attack has more range and deal- Okay, yeah, we want
that.
Gains of power.
Your special fires.
Okay, I'd rather have this.
I'm grateful Daedalus.
Yeah, my style is definitely one.
Let's get more ash.
Yeah, I like the range.
Range is nice.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Chill!
Alright, nice.
Five feet!
I'm a bodyguard what the fuck I can't see shit where do I go
do I go in oh okay I got a little confused I was like am I
am I do I go in to the black hole oh my god don't go in the
back
This is new though.
This guy's new.
He's new.
I haven't seen this guy before What did I just say?
There we go Nice.
Oh, there's more All right The side is you God kill the
darkness like Kingdom Hearts So then they had a girl the
Titan must have struck your father's house right after you
oh that's sad i didn't mean my didn't have a proper
relationship okay your cast also immediately hits foes with
a powerful splash your moves makes you briefly restore any
blank you what's okay press and hold attack special or cute
and view them with magic uh three is good for farm when we
claim rewards other than boom we're a copy made oh that's
good i like copies Yeah, another one!
That's right.
Maybe I can farm a lot more of this.
That's good.
Another one!
The hunt is on?
Wait, what?
Oh, is she gonna help me?
Yeah!
Oh, shit!
My aunt's helping me!
That's right, nepotism!
Let's go!
That's right!
I love nepotism!
him wait all right yeah okay let her kill him for free wait
what to do it whoops all right uh yay animus or my cousin
that's right don't make me get my cousin involved my cousin
can beat up your cousin i don't really want to upgrade c
star I guess double reward chance.
Yeah, increase the chance.
Felt that for sure.
Let's get the flower real quick.
Hello, cousin!
It's like when you get your big brother to beat up your
bullies.
Not in your circumstances, but you've finally begun.
Know that the family has your back.
Oh, I didn't get to see her artwork before, I'm pretty sure.
Her art's new.
No shortage lately of surprises on Olympus or below.
It's good to see you, Artemis.
But I must be off.
times against us and all that wait no why can't i just have
bring her along she helped me in one fight can't she help me
another an old fool too busy besieging the mountain yeah
she's like to sense the threat headed his way go get him all
right we should get death ward right right that looks good
how are you busy all the gods are at war how are you busy
you help me in this war my blessing is yours yay i got
blessed i don't think i have enough money for this i might
as well just get nectar yeah crit damage sound is always op
what the yeah like how are you busy like we're we're in the
same mission like you might as well help your cousin
Like, shouldn't you be helping me, bro?
Cousin?
There we go.
Nectar, yeah.
What?
Oh, double cut!
Yeah, I was like, did I not get it?
I mean, we could get more power.
I don't think we need magic.
I don't use it that much.
In general, so I might as well.
Hello?
Where's everyone?
Oh, they're over here.
Alright, that is great.
That's right, you dare.
Nice.
Any more?
That's right, cast!
They gotta make sure they don't start screaming at me.
God, the range thing is so OP.
Grandmother.
Hello, grandma.
Your cast inflict freeze and repeal your damage to foe and a
binding circle after remaining active for oh wait this is
good right okay two or two or one or three I guess three
more three okay cold I like how they're like three and I'm
like three cold the reason is just cold Alright, alright,
fine.
Cold.
Oh, yeah, no, that freeze is good.
Yeah, you're right.
Cold is it.
Cold was good.
Cold was a good reasoning, guys.
You're right.
Cold was good.
Alright.
Otherwise, you can just stand here.
Pack steal more damage and inflict freeze.
I should get that as level 2.
Or strike it.
The double.
Yeah, if they can't hit you, you can't die.
Never tell this Doki.
Do I get two or one?
One?
Is it 75%?
Guys, if we keep doubling this, we'll never get the actual
stuff.
Two of you won the gap.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Two for Doki, but the Gamba though.
But we guys, if we keep increasing it, We'll never actually
get items!
Yeah.
Can't increase it forever!
Alright, nice.
Ascent to a heart.
Yay!
We should be able to afford the shop now.
Maybe we can have double the shop items.
Is that possible?
It's Keron.
Hello.
Good talk.
carod yes my lord i met apollo grandmother uncle poseidon
i've known artemis and hermes for so long i'm impressed they
kept my secret double it and give it to the next person yeah
i met so many people carod okay we should get aphrodite he
can afford that you and your perennie demeter you must have
so much catching up to do perhaps you even have the power to
unfreeze that disapproving scowl i oft fear is permanently
set so I mean, she's happy when she sees me.
Maybe she likes me more than you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got the double.
I got a duo.
Yeah.
You deal more damage with your weapon, the more...
Oh, wait, you should get that.
Right?
That's the duo.
Do it this early?
The first time?
You guys watch my older Hades streams.
I think the very first time I played it, I got a legendary.
I can't look at the people who are so bad.
What?
First time, guys?
Our luck is bullshit.
Why do we have another test?
Just let me through.
You surpassed me before, yet I...
I wonder.
This streamer ass luck.
Or did the fates themselves perhaps provide a little nudge?
Come head mistress.
If I could be provoked that easily, I'd stand just like our
creators.
Good fortune seldom comes to those in no position to- Yeah,
my luck balances.
You're right, my luck balance.
I have shitty real life luck, but good streamer luck.
My health is fucked, but that's okay, guys.
Look at this cool-ass build I got.
Look at this cool thing I got in game, though.
Shit.
Sorry, I got too cocky.
Oh, my God.
This is bad.
I'm not doing so well.
It's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
I like to cope.
Coping is fine.
Oh, no, not.
Bro, not fucking Toho, bro.
Bro, come on, come on!
Toho's not cool!
Mistress, please!
Oh god.
Oh fuck, I hate this one!
Alright, sister!
Ah!
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
It's not fair!
Oh god.
Oh god
Okay, it's five It's five It's five I killed them all
Okay Okay, not her Her nice Come on, she's so close Whoa,
whoa Whoa, whoa nice I got it oh thank God for freeze no no
it's fine you could maybe just let me through you know
because you're the one boss that technically like I don't
technically I don't have to fight I passed the test yeah you
know like technically we don't have to fight.
Ruki has to hug every part of her life's stomach.
Gotcha.
True.
Oh, shit.
It's the clock guy.
It's Kronos.
What compelled you to wander in and out of Herobus?
I'm not your girl, old man.
That's right.
That's creepy.
So it seems you appear to be quite pressed for time.
Forgive this old man his transgressions jokies build low
strength low endurance low dexterity low faith low
intelligence max out luck only in games thank you for the
super chat mr broken thank you thank you yay we're here now
is it i'm pretty sure he is the villain all right oh within
the sopping blackest pits of oceanus Oh, yeah.
Sound guys.
Sound been good now.
Poets could not possibly describe.
I'll find a way.
All right.
Down we go.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
That's a lot.
How did that guy hit?
Who the fuck hit me?
Oh, my God.
It's these guys.
I hate these guys so much.
I think the exploding guy is the worst one.
Yeah.
I guess we'll get out.
Oh My god a fucking course.
Oh my god.
Oh my It's not good.
I'm not okay.
We're not doing okay right now.
There's too many too many fires
Oh god Okay The freeze is going over time for me right now
ashes.
What's this?
Oh my, okay.
Okay, thank God.
Thank God I walked away.
Wait, what?
What's this?
Lore?
Is Lore worth it?
Is Savory Mooncake exist?
Because if not, I'm going to invent him.
Also, the sheep can punch enemies.
Thanks for continuing to be amazing.
Oh, it can.
Hands are good.
Free stuff.
Oh, I like free stuff.
Skull, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, I won't be surprised.
Hey, flower.
Are you okay?
Oh my god, it's so painful to be so this beautiful, isn't
it?
I fucking do it!
Far and wide, just to gaze upon me.
Not that I blame you.
And get totally rejected.
I fucking knew it the way he was posed.
God!
It's so painful to be this handsome, I know.
Oh my god.
His name is Narcissus?
Oh, that's good.
I don't even know who you are.
I'm a narcissist, dummy.
The narcissist.
And if your note would be sooner, then why don't you relieve
me of one of these innumerable gifts the others offered in
vain?
It's Nicholas Kane.
Received a gift and...
Oh, wait.
Oh, he gives me free stuff.
I know.
My God.
I know what a horrible life you have to live to be just so
beautiful.
It truly is So terrible Why not Three?
Oh wait Oh this is just heals Oh this max health Okay I just
noticed the max health I know right Wow Turkey is in game
Thanks Thank you narcissist
That's yeah I just noticed it was healing I know it's so
painful lived that life.
Okay, nice.
I saw him just in time before he did anything.
Did anything dumb!
Jesus Christ, that was a lot of fish.
One left.
Fine, I can freeze him.
I feel like I didn't get a lot of doubles yet.
Uh, one, two, or three, chat.
His name is literally where the word narcissist comes from.
Why, though?
I don't understand.
I mean, it was so reasonable, though.
Again, are we still, we're still...
Oh, shit, let's go!
It worked, guys!
It was, guys!
The gamble was worth it!
But what if we gamble even more?
Number go up!
Chat, number go up.
Guys, eventually we have to...
Guys, we have to eventually get other stuff.
stuff guys we can't keep getting doubles we have to
diversify eventually
all right get Poseidon in here please no we don't but what
if
and I'll let it ride all in all right I don't know which
one's good for you Poseidon gel cell that's quitter's top if
you mute especially the bgm side before going to scale us
something fun happens kid thank you the super chat thank you
thank you three hits riding yeah i guess so just because i
don't use magic anyway a wave of power all right aphrodite
um let's just go with poseidon i don't want to risk it i
don't want to risk it because i think i like my build anyway
i think my build is like really strong in general like it
doesn't really matter to me yeah there you go i'll just
vaporize them too nice
your moves also launch wave ahead that knocks blows away but
uses a star of each encounter yours oh should we get
hydraulic might your moves i feel like three right Yeah.
Three seems good.
We'll get nectar.
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck!
I'm fucking, of course, I hit all of them.
I thought I really, I hate the, I hate the sea serpent.
They're so annoying.
Jesus.
Okay.
That's fine.
Sea serpent's the most annoying one.
Honestly, if we're here.
sure all right let's put this in just in case in case they
they decide to rush me all at once oh god there's so many
okay but i'll get the sea serpent out oh not the vapors all
right oh oh got out just in time okay this room was not fun
That was not a fun room I have 81 Okay Actually Grab this
We'll grab the boon Because I don't think I have enough I
don't think I have money For like anything good So I might
as well just get the boon Yeah Guys we're not Guys No we
have Guys I swear to God We have to Guys I swear to God We
have to I'm doing it We can't keep gambling We can't keep
We're at the boss level We can't keep Wait, do I turn it the
volume BGM here?
Down here?
Okay, it's at 60.
All right.
Excuse me?
I knew it.
She's come back.
You ready for another show, lady?
We've been rehearsing our material.
Oh, it's too late.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to be a star.
But that voice?
Girl, no talent agent's going to pick you up, girl.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a fucking caterer.
That's right.
Oh, it's too late.
Oh That's right.
I'm an anti.
I'm a siren anti Damn dorky.
I saw the reviews Girl,
I saw the reviews.
Nobody's gonna pick you up, girl.
Oh my god
Shit shit okay it's five more crap I'm gonna take her band
member out are you serious
that's five oh shit so you can hit her hit her drummer
that's right what you gotta do when your drummer's dead girl
oh Oh, not this.
I hate that move.
Okay, that's fine.
Laugh!
Oh, it's because of her clam shit.
Alright.
Grit Roxy first.
That's fine.
Oh, it's fine.
Got out.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's okay.
thank God for Roxy she's just there thank God it's very
helpful that she's just chilling okay what that hits me okay
that's bullshit that's actually bullshit oh my god are you
that's right got your where's your rhythm now You lost your
rhythm!
How'd you gotta fucking figure out the tempo without Roxy?
That's right now you don't have a basis!
Oh shit, I'm...
But I feel so weak though.
What's going on?
Oh!
I was like, whoa, oh no.
That's a lot of fish.
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah!
You can't keep time.
That's right.
You're a little bit pitchy there.
That's so cute.
Let's go.
Got a pearl, too.
Yoink, my pearl now.
Let's go down.
You ruined the side, Stokey.
The anti's won.
Okay, we gotta heal.
Go ahead, go here.
No.
Okay, that looked like a door, okay?
Within a green-tinged chamber that the shrewd...
What a hater.
He passes to Mr. Narcissus.
The pain of being so beautiful must be such a burden to him.
But...
Nice.
Oh, it's like a little behind the scenes.
Damn.
What the fuck?
This is...
Oh, this is...
like bro the other mirror's so tiny for her for backups
where am i now i can't believe she graduated
that's right the band broke up and i did it i broke up the
band and i'm proud of it what no hello what's this you're a
long way from the crossroads so this is where the real
action is huh Easeless.
Practicing for what?
It just took a turn, Aris.
You know how it goes.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I have some urgent business to
attend to.
Always in such a rush.
I'd really hate to slow you down.
Though, let's hang out some time, okay?
Yeah, she has a gun.
What the fuck?
I have guns back then?
Bro, is she from the future?
What?
Oh, I got blessed.
Yeah, what did she do to me?
Guys, I don't think being blessed by her was a good thing.
What else is over here?
Knock, knock.
I'm just gonna walk around a little bit.
It's such a big area.
The seed.
Oh, that's two.
Oh, this is new.
What is that?
Unseal?
Is it?
Wait, I want to see you.
want to steal this.
That's fine.
I feel like the seal... Okay, the casting is so good,
though, in general.
The freeze casting?
Okay.
As long as I'm over here, it's fine.
That's right.
Can't get me!
Get frozen, bitch!
Okay.
That's right.
Can't even touch me.
Your attacks hit two times.
Your attacks are...
Oh, 5.50% faster.
Press and hold Q.
Oh, wait.
Two or three?
Two.
Two for the freeze, I feel like.
Because of my freeze?
That means the freeze will last even longer.
Just because of how fast it is.
Oh my god, there's more?
What the fuck?
Wait, that's so broken.
Oh my god, not again.
Oh my god.
Oh god, not the darkness.
Okay, it's fine.
I have the mega freeze.
Yeah, okay, that is so strong.
Wait, my freeze build is actually so strong.
I think the freeze build is good for minions, but for bosses
is not like the best.
wait eras blessings based on devs telling you you're doing
too well on these not in real life what do you mean devs
i have thank you for the super chat thank you guys this is
not fair this is not fair
check your bones what did he do to me I don't know what he
did.
What?
How do I check it?
Boons?
I don't check boons.
What item is that?
What do I press?
B.
What did he do?
Oh my god.
Um, this grows each encounter?
What?
Bro, we're fucked.
I need to grab to shit and blow my nose up in a rack.
The fact
that it grows.
Like, what do you mean?
Oh, just because I beat the second boss on my third attempt,
they're like, no.
No, I'm just playing the game how it is, devs.
That is so bullshit.
Oh, just because I'm good at gaming, I get punished.
I...
Oh, my God.
Just like Narcissus, it's so hard to be such a good gamer.
Guys, guys, it's such a prudent to be such an insane gamer.
You have to be...
Bro, it's my second encounter!
Okay, woe is me.
Okay, do you get to meet her or are heathen?
I mean, let me stop.
Bro, this run was so good!
I had such good abilities, too.
Oh, my God.
This was actually a really good run.
Fire?
Alright, fire.
It doesn't matter which way I'll go.
Bro, and when she...
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
Bro, she does so much.
Okay.
Guys, I had a lot of HP just then.
The keyword was I had.
Really?
What the fuck hit me?
The thorns?
Okay.
How many mortals have you tormented?
Just died.
since i was probably your age rat proper dame oh since last
we saw each other come to think what can you do she hates
everybody i hate everybody bro at one point like it's gonna
be like a hundred like at one point jesus like i get touched
and i'm dead
your sprint oh no i don't want to get rid of that your
special inflict scorch that's my right click you deal more
damage to flows there are nowhere near other flows okay
stuff canada Yeah, or the boss fight.
Okay, let's pick up this.
It's getting...
Doki, it's much worse than you can go over 100.
Oh, that's good to know!
That's...
Oh, wow!
Thank God!
Thank God it can go over 100, guys.
Thank fucking God.
A path of golden petals shall...
Oh my God, at least we get an another.
Like, it just kills me.
Like, I die and I still die.
My next run takes damage from it.
That's how strong it is.
Like, at this point, my next run will take damage from her
goddamn curse.
Oh, wait.
Another one.
No, no, I got the other one.
No, I did.
I got it.
Wait, it doubled again?
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
Wait, no, that's a different one.
I'm lost.
I don't even know where I went.
Oh, it doubled the mana.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay, I just want to go around it first.
Just want to make sure I got everything I need before I do
the goddamn...
There's so many things here.
I just want to make sure I get everything I need to get.
Alright, there's the coins.
Alright, we'll get out the heart first.
The tree?
Which tree?
Oh my god, I need to make sure I don't get into the thorns.
I'll grab all the free stuff first.
The gold tree?
There was a gold tree.
Oh, there it is.
I should try an incantation back home.
I need to do an incantation, guys.
I can't touch it yet.
all right we'll grab the hp what's this oh shit oops it was
broken when i got here i swear guys it was broken when i got
here oh my god are you fucking oh my god the thing is i
can't i tried not to get hit
oh my oh i get the
okay god these reduces are so annoying okay i have to kill
these guys first it's no use oh my god i don't have spells i
didn't even notice that i'm seeing it i'm gonna die from one
hit i want to know oh my it's only 40 it's only if oh my god
in another thank god thank god i gambled All right, we got a
fight and we got to get the money one.
Do I have to get the money one or can I just leave?
I technically don't need the money.
Okay, at least the forest doesn't do like 80 damage to me.
You have to?
Okay, god damn it.
I don't want to take the money just because it's just too
much of a tomb risky.
There's more to find here still.
God damn it.
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
Ah!
God!
I keep accidentally walking into the thorns.
Okay, it was an accident.
Oh, I did not see them.
I'll put this out just in case.
Alright, nice.
As long as there's no Medusa's, we should be fine.
Nice.
Oh my god, these guys are easier.
I guess it's because it's for money.
And another!
Gamba-gamba!
All right, 50% damage now.
Right here.
All right, here we go.
At 50%.
Oh, yay!
Three!
Oh, you know what?
Three things!
You know, I'll take you.
I get three.
Three is nice.
What the fuck is that?
That's just a rock.
Oh!
All right.
What the fuck is this rock doing here?
I talked to this?
Okay, incantation still.
I'm gonna try to find like the...
Alright, as long as I have the rock here.
Alright.
Thank god for freeze.
God, I'm gonna miss this.
I need to find the meter again.
The freeze is so good.
Freeze is actually so strong.
The rock, Jaws, it's the rock.
Nice.
And another!
There's that boon.
All right, let's grab money.
All right, grab money here.
And another!
Oh my god, I'm winning the 50-50.
Oh my god, the 50-50 is working out, guys.
All right, we can grab.
Okay, we'll grab the boon.
Okay, where is he?
Oh god, not...
coming though oh my god they're coming oh fuck not the
medusas oh this is so bad not in the dark too i think it's
worse that it's in the dark too oh this is so bad for me
because i can't see the electricity here okay there you go
i'm just gonna try and kill this one there you go nice all
right i serve I just start on counter.
We'll do Ice Strike.
Ice Strike.
Oh, and another!
Alright, which one?
Chat.
I did Ice Strike.
Should we do another Ice Strike or change?
To two or three.
Okay, we're not...
We can't prime more, I think.
What do we want?
One again?
More freeze?
And another!
Alright, we're doing the freeze build.
There should be...
Poseidon's here.
It should be like...
Other than Poseidon, there was one more.
Oh, there's a coin.
Nice, I'll take that.
And another!
Oh my god.
The Gamba.
The Gamba's actually working, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
I'm gonna kill the Shadow creature first.
Okay, we unlocked.
this all right yeah where's my another that's why i'm greedy
i want more you're not even gambling anymore it's just
cashing out all right nice side in time what the that's a
werewolf what's he doing here that's a that's just a dog
Jesus Christ Oh my god I don't like that I don't like that
he got closer Guys I can't let them touch me Well I actually
just fucking pass out
Okay nice That has to be the last one Alright Poseidon The
special hit flows with a splash that knocks Other foes away
Your cast also immediately hits foes with a powerful splash
at inflict frost but your moves makes you briefly restore
any magic you use repeatable after eight seconds wait one
it's left i think it's at 50 now because i'm in two rooms we
had two your cast also immune i guess so because i use cast
a lot i do use cast a lot or like oh i'm a little yeah i
should i'll go to okay shop okay i have a lot of money we'll
use shop this way feels right we have so much money now uh i
can't afford everything yeah max life facade in all right
one two or three am i any minor fines and money are worth
more you see and you receive money uh heart and okay but i
don't even know if i'll make guys i don't know if i'll make
it guys the thing is the thing to make this worth it is if i
defeat the boss Guys, the thing, I, guys, we don't even know
they'll make it past this boss, guys.
Guys, I have to survive the boss fight to make this work.
Just don't die.
Bro, just, it's easy.
Just kill the boss.
Just win.
Okay, fine.
All right, let's go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, it's all money.
Okay, cool.
It's just all money.
Wow, all the money I can't use
Wow, that's great It's just all money, let's go, I guess
It's just all money, okay Okay, I just
Okay, I don't know I don't guys, I don't know Okay, I don't
know Oh shit, Cerberus.
Hello?
Oh, okay!
Oh!
Okay!
Wait, it's Cerberus!
This is not good.
This is not good for me.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
It's okay, right?
I think oh God.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh no.
Guys, guys, it's not.
What?
Oh my god.
This is actual bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
Oh, I'm only halfway.
Oh my god, I hate this move.
Hey, get back here.
Yeah, get back here.
You all stay out of this.
This is so bullshit.
This is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
It is so bad.
No, it's one hit.
He does 40 damage, guys.
It's what that's the worst part is not it's two hits It is
actually It's for it's one hit Oh my god he can move now
Oh god I hate that move so much I'm trying to like
Oh god
Oh god Oh god
Okay Oh god Oh God, okay.
That's fine.
Where did he go?
Oh, fuck!
Oh my God.
What am I looking at?
Oh, this is so much visual clutter.
Bro, fuck you, Aeris!
Fuck you!
Naturally, fuck you!
Oh, fuck.
I don't know where he is.
Ah!
I'm very calm.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, that's okay.
Don't get out of the comments.
Oh, we did it.
We're safe service.
torment oh my heart is pounding so fast reveals that it is
not the monster it appeared oh save them infamously vicious
oh god good boy glory's a good boy he was a good boy oh yeah
we did it i'm so crap everybody thinks oh my god ah she's
scream calmly oh where am i now you save the doggo god
please tell me please can i sell okay what can i sell oh
okay okay let's see okay 60 damage okay that's that's okay
that's fine unseal now
Congrats on beating that boss, Bruce Trial.
Well done, Guardian.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't think I'm going to live, I don't think I'm
going to be alive for much longer in this, in this area.
Central control.
It's only 60% Doki.
Okay.
You are trespassing on private property.
Oh no.
Yeah, what you gonna do about that, huh?
Coronas?
Fucking old man.
Oh, it's like a clock ticking.
Kobo, thank you for the 20 gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Damn right I'm trespassing.
Gotta do shit about it.
Oh my god, it's 14%.
That means it would have been a...
Oh my god.
That's what 60% damage upgrades, too.
That's right.
Yoink, my pet.
I grab him here.
Oh, God.
I'm just going to put this out just in case.
Because I don't trust myself to live.
Wait, what?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, okay, now I know what that does.
Okay.
That is also a time stop, too.
all right that's so risky that is so risky all right what
chambers what do you mean what I don't get any oh my god
okay I don't even get like anything out of that it's just
like it's just have fun the gift is that I get to progress
what a wonderful gift they're like congratulations you can
progress the game That's your prize.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Okay.
Okay, thank God.
The freeze is actually clutching right now.
Holy shit.
Like they can't even get me.
Okay, we gotta get freeze again.
It's actually so strong.
No traitor to the house shall go unpunished.
Oh.
Okay, wait, there's extra blue.
That's three boons.
Can I get some three boons, guys?
Yeah, freeze as such is so clutch.
I break this before it kills me.
Well, I guess everything kills me first.
Okay, grab these guys first.
God, I'm so low in HP though.
Oh my god.
I gotta pay attention to three different things on me.
Oh, fuck.
I've never let it get so close to me before.
Nice.
Three fucking boons.
You deal more damage, your freeze last effect longer.
Oh my god, wait.
Should we get two?
What damage does Kournos will sneeze in your direction and
send you all the way back to the dinosaur?
the super chat they get thank you we get two or three two
right yeah two seems really good i mean i've been like oh my
god and another okay now we can get wait now wait hi his
surrounding flows with powerful splash wait we should get
three here yeah i'm getting three all right we got three
there and another could head straight for chronos or yeah i
could get or or get to do uh the meter no i i can't risk the
boss fight guys guys i can't risk the boss fight guys bro um
i think it's at 100 now like oh oh my god oh my god oh my
god bro this is a baby
80% damage guys guys the moment I go to this this is going
to be 90% right here Robert thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you I had 70 HP going to that room I in this
room it will be not in this room guys it will finally hit
90% in this room alone because I'm very scared I'm very very
scared this room alone will be 90% guys oh my god oh my god
even a tiny thing will fucking kill 20, 200 damage on me 10
HP and a dream baby All right, here we go at least I can
pick this up Oh my god, I might as well just progress the
plot and see how this goes all right a hundred percent
damage Give it up for a hundred percent damage Give it up
guys this is a boss fight.
He's gonna we will not last that long either rooms
like this beer I know it guys either room is not looking too
good for us all right oh my god okay
I'm like really hoping that God doesn't get too close to me
this isn't I'm like, my corner.
My safety corner.
Thanks, Aris.
Fucking, thanks, girl.
All right, Chrome, that's time.
Lock in, token.
Lock in.
Right here.
Where is she?
All right, 100%.
Oh, hey, nice.
Let's shop.
I'm, I can technically afford this.
Wait, I can salute her?
Salute.
We moonlight guide you.
Oh my god, I don't think food's gonna help.
I don't think it's gonna.
Don't buy the anvil.
Guys, food is not gonna save me.
I think I can.
Food is not gonna salvage this run.
Why no anvil?
What does the anvil do?
You'll take two hits instead of one.
Guys, I feel like I ticked the...
It's still gonna be one hit.
Oh, swaps upgrades.
Yeah, we don't need a swap upgrade.
Let's just grab this.
Your caskings power and knocks the foe away.
Your special hits foes will splash.
I never used right click, though.
That's the thing.
Which would be good against boss.
Flourish?
Two?
All right.
I'll grab this one too.
Oh, shit.
Might as well get one, right?
I mean, let's do...
I mean, it's rare, epic.
One is...
It's epic, so might as well.
I'd be surprised if we...
I'm going to be so surprised.
The House of Hades now has but a fading memory.
For in its place, a new-formed palace rises.
the final area technically i like made it to the final world
or is there more levels after this i'm not beating chronos i
know i'm not i i'm not sorry i made it guys know there's
guys no because because the moment i go to this area it's at
a hundred percent please work on my authority just don't get
hit
hello open up knock knock how about what dive oh all right i
guess i dive all right time to swim in the death water it's
nectar water right
Hello!
A guest arrived so soon.
It is not often that I entertain of late.
Perhaps after this house becomes a little more presentable.
Though for the moment, you must pardon the ghost.
Oh, it's just sad.
Oh, gross.
That's actually worse.
I wish... Sad is actually worse, to be fair.
You can't... It's hard to get sad off of anything.
You know who I am.
And you know why I'm here.
Come now.
everywhere there is no need to rush you have come all this
way and i have so many questions how have you been and how
exactly did you find the media i mean i just opened it was
like literally one path hear me you enemy of night and
darkness now for your transgressions you shall imminently
die i'm cooked just because the devs were like oh you're
doing too well i'm so why did you make
Cursing is forbidden in this house.
By that token, fighting is forbidden as well.
But for you, my girl, we shall have to make an exception.
Time for you to go.
God, I'm scared.
I don't know what she does.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Bro, that is not fair.
That is not fair.
You have minions.
Oh, God.
Oh, this is not fair at all.
This is not fair.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared.
Oh, God.
I don't know what she does.
Or he, sorry.
Like, what does he do?
Oh no Are
you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, bro.
This is so bullshit 100% damage Oh, yeah, that's bad.
At least the food gave me three hits three hits.
It's fine Thanks, there is I thought we were on the same
side.
Do you not want to save the world?
Red you're not hence I go over this flashback
I bid you farewell for now Lord hypnos by hypnos Oh, that's
cute.
I have no fire the princess finds a set of tracks Suggesting
that her foe she has just chaos right?
Hope not very long before I hope you never find love I hope
no one will ever fix you Aw, she cute describe my every move
oh my god fourth wall the princess of the dead refers as she
quit teasing me and help me look oh look at all these
kitties oh that's cute and then the dogs yes have you seen
haggardy about just a tiny little girl goddess though i'd
expect that pointy hat of hers to give her away I'll look
for it.
Thank you.
That's why no one loves her because she's a fucking bitch If
she's not a bitch, maybe people will actually like her Oh
heckity.
I found her Got me you did millennia way, but I dare say I
can escape your clutches yet I did I'm so good at how to
seek guys Yeah, wait, she disappeared again.
Oh Where is Hegety about?
Yeah, where is Hegety?
Where do I go now?
Where does she disappear to?
Oh, there she is.
I found her.
God, I'm so good.
You are.
Got you again.
Ah, so persistent.
Give up already, witch.
For I'm a Titaness.
You cannot vanquish me.
No!
I will kill you.
That's right.
So I need to double check my sound real quick.
Because every time I unmute myself, it, like, goes lower.
So I want to be sure.
Oh, there.
I knew it.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, I heard her.
She's on my right.
Oh, there you are.
Okay, like, even if you can't see her, okay.
Her strategy for hide and seek is, like, if I can't see
anything, no one can find me.
Like, yeah.
I've not heard your laughter before.
Reminded me of your mother.
A much preferable sound to that of grief.
I promise not to cry again.
I still get sad sometimes, but...
Because you're an orphan.
Do not make promises you cannot keep.
When tears well up, let them spill forth.
They're not so precious that they need be contained.
That run could have been the run if that bitch didn't
fucking curse me.
But you never cry, Hecatee.
I think I could have just been in the game in that one run.
That's the fucking worst part.
And then you could hear my mother's laugh again.
And I shall do everything in my power to prepare you so that
you may succeed where I failed.
If not for your family's sake, then for your birthright.
as the princess of the underworld what do you mean you
failed you tried to beat Kronos yourself he hurt you yeah
what did he do concern yourself with your own pain not mine
destroying Kronos shall not change the past and the pain
shall linger they will set itself less frequently with age
but enough of this on the morrow we shall teach you to hunt
greater prey oh hey nice jolly
death to chronos death to chronos i mean it could have
happened it could have happened in that run we could have
got it if we're being honest mel i want to talk about it or
at least tell me the
errors bro that bitch she'd be like oh my god i know right
she's such a bitch i'm like god next time we don't invite
her that party oh no so scary hey that worked i know right
like oh my gosh did you hear like no one even likes her like
girl apparently apparently like no one even likes never been
on a date before oh what a loser um oh my god girl dish okay
do okay don't even mean girl yeah i'm like girl did you hear
okay who do i gift my nectar to rumor doki is scary okay
okay oh that's messed up not fucking cursing me to get take
a hundred percent damage is not more messed up What she did
to me?
I have 10 nectars.
But who do I give it to?
I don't give it to her.
I have five.
Fuck you, liars.
I have five nectars.
The best hunter in all the crossroads.
It was her blessing.
Yeah.
I have a ghost onion.
It's just a prank.
Can I only give it to Demeter when I meet her?
in the rounds.
What is that, Artemis?
I can only...
Okay, I can only meter it there.
Okay, oh hey, I'll give it...
Hey, Melinawee, I just wrapped a debrief here with Sister
Hecatee.
This place has changed a lot since last I checked.
Hi, Artemis.
Welcome.
We've had to scramble a bit to make ready for everything.
What?
Can I show you around?
Oh!
He said hi to Nemesis.
Oh, No, I have to go.
Olympus needs me back up top, at least a little while.
Again?
But he's got here.
Ares doesn't have a husband, but she has 13 children,
including murder, hunger, pain, discord, lies, and disaster.
Such a great...
Oh, my...
Why do we not stop her?
She literally...
Like, why do we need any of these kids in our world?
Did no one try to stop her from having more kids?
Like, Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for all these men trying to fix her.
what you did.
You gave us hunger.
Imagine being a husband of the kid whose kid is murder.
I hear you.
She should have been stopped after the murder child got
born.
Whoa, I didn't know.
My bad, guys.
Okay, we need this.
May bows throughout the morning fields revive.
so moat it be oh nice we got the golden tree now we're gonna
get okay we're gonna get the what's this oh we got the um
the three fates you may proceed that would have the murder
gene tomorrow's please help me avenge both our family's
sorrows yeah wait what where is she i give you my spawn okay
she gives he gives me one next day please listen to my
thoughts so moat it be okay you've expanded your shop yay I
reached the house headmistress did everything as practice
was planned except he was probably because he left me on red
no this is an excellent result you are still here, having
learned more of what it takes to reach our enemy and what he
can do to resist.
I cast my hex, please respond.
I definitely skipped like 20,000 Hecate's dialogue because I
went to Kronos.
Yes.
If I can reach him, I can take him.
Take him.
I think she was supposed to say a lot of different things to
me before I got there.
the house of hades shades of the dead residing there all
scattered to the ends of the earth you shades are welcome
here and safe what did he get me oh more nectar oh no oh man
i don't really need to get anything right now what's fate
fabric what is this guys what is this buy the nectar okay
appreciate the deal but what is this Yeah, I don't know for
for the pot.
Oh, it's for the pot.
Is there anything I'm missing?
I need iron and I got everything else
Back in one you found him goddess your looks is it all along
with my reports Even something to remember you by I reckon
even if the battle didn't go your way.
Oh Hey, that's fine.
Yeah, I wonder why it didn't go my way Kronos was exactly
where we Eat it, eat it, eat it, eat it Odyssey.
And my ability to withstand his magic went only so far.
Well, fortunately for you, the old are often rather slow to
learn.
You run into him a few more times like that.
Yeah, I wonder why.
Do be very careful out there.
Guys?
That tooth is loose right now in my mouth.
I
Feel it moving Every time I close my job it's it's moving in
I open the jaw the tooth is moving out
Guys it's moving guys Stop moving I'm not and I'm just
opening my mouth i think i can raise my grasp oh okay i need
more grasp i can't help it okay but if it comes out then
it's fixed right is it bad if it is it bad oh wait because i
don't have baby teeth anymore yeah teeth don't grow back no
more i'm past the age I hate the team can't grow back guys
Did you guys know that It's a grow back I can do this Game
plus two grass
Not me
It's a molar.
It's the very far back tooth.
Doki loses a tooth live on stream.
Whereas thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I have one more death defiance.
I should grab that.
No, I don't have wisdom teeth no more.
Okay.
I forgot about that.
I forgot like.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Which is the best weapon?
Is witches staff the best one, or is there better weapons?
If it's only part of tooth, it's bad.
If it's the whole thing, roots and all, you should be okay.
Just don't mind.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I'm trying to...
I'm not touching with my tongue because I'm scared.
Marshall, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Always go to it, but which is the best one?
Umbral Flames?
Okay, I'll try that.
Ignium, the umbral flames.
Alright.
Guys, I don't like this weapon.
Guys I don't like this weapon.
This is not the type of encouragement that's of benefit
right now.
I had Kronos cornered, but he overpowered me.
And now I've lost the element of surprise.
It does a lot of damage.
The projectile is so weird.
I hate to say this, but I'd probably hang it up if I was
you.
But I want a chance like that.
Commander.
All right, let's see.
Oh, let's check the chest.
I can only quit one thing, right?
Whenever you exit, fully restore your HP up to the chest.
total the onion okay i can't have more than one item okay
all right this is fine all right this is fine because every
time i look up it's a different dialogue few places oh it is
where two rounds meet
marcia thank you for the super chatting thank you definitely
go to dennis what what happened so yeah and my the earliest
appointment is tuesday so i'm waiting for that don't worry i
have didn't support did they say if anyone cancels on monday
they'll let me know so let's hope oh go up i can't yet i
thought i had the fast travel yet ready or not hence i go
all right let's go oh moonlight she's deviated from moon
night great titaness the eye of night i'm gonna hear voices
good evening to you little oh oh she's pretty well her horse
is i was looking at the horse oh our cycles now are
intertwined oh fuck don't you hate it when your cycle synced
up like oh shit girl we synced up the moon
oh my god look we're syncing up our cycle echoes what did
she mean by that your hex launches a seeking projectile that
flicks more on up to five suspectable foes your hex makes
everything else wait press f to invoke oh f i have what the
is hex um zero thank you a super chat thank you thank you i
want the symbols of royalties and that's the only one count
for it your justice we don't know if it's I just
accidentally cracked the tooth, guys.
We don't know that.
I just cracked the tooth.
Three?
TikTok.
Okay, we'll try that.
I don't know if I like this move.
Oh, my God.
I'm taking so much.
How much damage already?
That's mine.
Okay, nice.
Oh, thank you.
Alright.
Oh, nice, we needed that.
Okay, I'm gonna put this in here for now.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I like this move.
You know what?
Fuck y'all.
Wait, how do I up?
Oh, I can't up yet?
Wait, what?
Oh, it's time.
Okay.
Wait, who's still alive?
Oh, I need to grab the ash.
Okay, I was going to say, who's still alive?
Oh, hammer.
Hammer time.
No, it's the meter.
I just noticed the meter.
I was just like, hammer time.
I went with hammer time.
Notice it because I was thinking about hammer time All
right, your special deal 100 plus 100 damage to armor while
you challenge you move 5% 20% faster I actually don't know
your challenge attack 50% faster and it uses one You need to
spend mana to activate a oh Two okay I should better light
my way.
Yeah, I need to spend my mana.
I need to spend like five, right?
I guess that's what it meant.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, nice.
I am melting!
Oh!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh, so that's how you do it.
Okay.
I don't know, this is weird.
I don't think I like this weapon.
Oh, hey, I can't tour required compel follow me.
I don't have the tool for it
Oh, an M1 okay God
Okay, I guess I could use it for more so for range I guess
would take you all right Aphrodite So you're the star
student of great Hecatee a little bird He told me she'd been
training up a real prodigy.
Imagine my surprise when it turned out to be a missing
princess of the underworld.
How positively scandalous.
Oh, it's not.
Okay.
Attack steal more damage to nearby foes.
You cast inflicts weak and damage falls while dragon and
rushing damages surviving rounding foes inflict weak and
again once you stop.
We want two or two, right?
I think the cast is strong.
Oh, hey, narcissist.
Hello?
Oh, it's not Narcissus.
Wait, I'm going to steal your stuff real quick.
Ma'am.
You won't need the rocks.
You're just a spider.
Ar... Ar...
I don't know how to pronounce...
What is that?
Arachai?
I can always make more perfectly good silk.
I can't always see you.
Hi, Arachni.
Oh, Arachni.
Sorry about all this.
Seeing more of one another now.
My task has begun.
Truly.
Why then?
I'll get out of your hair.
You have to go.
But first...
You're not fucked a spider.
And don't worry about any wear and tear.
I have plenty more in stock.
Oh, is she the first spider?
Okay, someone fucked the spider.
Lab Don and armor that makes you channel 40% faster.
Do I have one channel then?
Don that makes you...
restore two no two hearts is not that much it makes you
restore oh wait this one three right yeah but Zeus fucks
everyone three right because it like channels um mana and
mine's a mana build do you like it why this is beautiful
thank you it's captured the meter to your success bye spider
God not the shadows again
God not him again, I think I'm shooting him
Like is he oh my god.
Yeah, I'm not fucking looking at him need to recharge Okay,
that's fine Okay, I was not shooting him apparently Are you
fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
Nice.
I already lost all my armor.
I thought I was shooting him, but apparently not.
Let's go.
Your recent descent took you deeper than my deepest roots.
Close to where the Titan Kronos now resides.
And hold your mother captive.
Yeah, my ex is already half gone.
There is no way to inform us of what happened.
Oh, when I'm not spending mana?
Oh, I forgot to gift her.
Enemy that stops one instance of damage range, but you are
prime, but you prime.
One instance of your sprint forms a gust around you that
lingers.
Your special deals more damage and inflicts freeze.
Oh, okay, let's get Ice Flourish.
Yeah, Ice Flourish.
I just have to use Right Click More.
Like, there you go.
So you don't get that.
And then...
Cast!
Oh!
I still...
I don't know.
I think I do...
Oh my gosh, I don't have a lot of energy, though.
There you go.
I gotta recharge when I'm not using it.
Okay, we'll get more ash.
Worth.
Okay.
Okay, I'm recharging.
All right, I'll get rid of all these guys.
I think I can charge it.
I can cast again.
Nice.
Yay!
I don't know.
I still don't know if I like this.
Heals are born.
Let's get born.
Born time.
Yeah, I'll do.
Freeze so I can freeze it.
All right.
Hex!
That's our chest for you!
Because fuck you in particular.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking...
Oh, no.
Oh, I have to keep mob.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm still recharging.
I still have four.
Four HP and a dream.
Uh...
I'll do this.
I think my special is the best.
All right, healers.
Okay.
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, they're everywhere.
This is so risky.
I want to make sure I don't take any damage.
I have to be careful.
I need my recharge.
Okay, I should have enough for shop now.
Yeah, I know.
If I lose...
I know, I don't want to lose my charge.
Okay, we'll grab that.
Hi, Poseidon.
I know, right?
Wait, Asa.
You're a god of time.
That god of the sea and hell.
And everything else.
Okay, I think one, right?
Many minor fines and money are worth more and you receive.
Oh, should I get three?
One or three?
One?
Yeah, we don't have Gamba, guys.
Uncle doesn't want to talk to me anymore.
A special offer of some sort.
I've returned as much gold as I could, but know full well it
isn't easy for you to procure the goods you provide.
Oh, he gave me a special...
Oh, a credit card!
Here, you know what?
Thanks for the credit card.
I'll give you a nectar.
Here you go.
If we're to restore the old old...
I got credit card.
I was thinking, why not start?
like this thanks sharon
yay are you certain there's no i'm gonna have good credit
now let's go shall again confront the one who raised her and
taught to her the means by which she may prevail there's
always more to learn i can beat her i can do it again right
i'm feeling like i'm I'm not that good with this weapon.
The subconscious I descend.
Remember well those words and those that follow.
Unless the shrill of battle cloud your memory.
To the abyss of the subconscious, I descend.
Night and darkness guide me to my blood beyond the grasp of
time.
I understand.
When do I fucking, like, win the test?
Like, when do I pass this test?
How many times do I have to beat her up for her to, like,
stop testing me?
opportunity to make the invocations in the proper place and
time
are you fucking okay okay i fucked up
guys i messed up
okay i'm just gonna get rid of these guys are you fucking
okay okay nice oh no i can't chat I know the thing anymore.
Okay, it's here.
It's fine.
I don't need mana.
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh, fuck.
Get out of here.
Oh, my God.
Barely do damage.
I barely do damage.
It's not even worth it.
whoops whoops okay that's fine that's fine it's okay see see
I'm okay see see see it's fine it's so fine oh my god oh
okay I might be doing worse with this weapon but it's so
fine see i told you guys
test complete you have survived against me yeah yeah
freestyle well technically it's not free i had to earn it
yay reward the book of shadows book of shadows okay yoink
got the book of shadows fuck is that?
Oh, I guess it's this.
I'm a little more edgy now.
Closer to Tartarus.
All right, here we go.
Back here, I'll go.
Time to be my DB and auntie again.
Yeah, it's like, yeah, it's like an encyclopedia.
Time to spread hate.
That's right.
I'm I'm back to spread hate!
Okay, I'm gonna use this real quick.
The ante's back!
Uh, oh, I do have...
Let's grab more magic.
It says there's a magic build.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
Technically, we're fine, I think.
Okay.
Oh, thank god they all lined up too That's good Oh yeah, the
last minute Fucking shot Um, I only have enough money For
shop anyway Oh Yeah, I'm siren's strongest Hater Okay, I'm
put this here Okay, maybe the worst area to put this in Okay
I'm gonna put Use this too just in case.
Are you serious that hits me?
Okay, it's fine.
I have range.
Health or Apollo?
I haven't seen Apollo in a long time.
I don't know.
I don't really want to fight a boss.
Guys, do we want boons?
Do we want a boons?
Let's try.
Let's try the mini-boss.
What the?
What?
Helly fish.
What the?
Oh my god.
Why?
Why did I pick this?
Oh, I can't see.
I can't see.
I am blind.
This is your fault.
I can't see again.
Oh my god.
I literally can't see.
I'm dead.
I'm dead because of this area.
I'm...
Oh my god, okay.
It's okay.
Surely.
Surely I can...
Okay, thank God.
I'm 1HB.
I just don't get hit.
I don't even Athena knows what.
His assaults on Olympus always fail.
Even if they've kept us occupied.
What's his next move?
I'm so healthy.
Okay.
When you cast, expire.
restore your sprint is faster and flicks days one or two
guys i feel like we'll always need to i forgot to get i keep
forgetting to give them gifts i'm they should post they
should be gifting me gifts not the other way around um why
am i gifting things when they should be gifting me stuff i'm
the youngest which floats eternally toward death and decay
and so invariably find themselves exactly here All right, I
just stepped in one.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm not okay right now I'm gonna use this just maybe Maybe
I'll activate something for me.
Oh God, you can tell that I am not healthy right now You can
tell you can tell she is not healthy at all Oh my god, that
scared me
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
It's okay.
Oh, this is not okay.
Oh, this is...
I don't feel very healthy here.
Okay, I have the fishies.
Alright, nectar.
Oh, hey, can I mine this?
Yeah!
Mining!
We're mining.
Uh, money or mana?
Manna always.
We're in magic build.
Oh.
Where are the scary monsters?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, God.
Not these guys.
These guys are the worst.
Oh, fuck.
They're actually the worst.
Wait, that hit me?
Wait, where did I get hit?
Oh, no.
This is not good.
This is actually not good.
I'm going to stay here.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see it!
Oh, no, I have to use one of my death defiance in the baby
level.
I used to be so good at this game.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, God, I can't see.
I can't see.
No!
Ah, it's goddamn trash.
I knew it.
I knew I would use death defiance accidentally here.
Oh, my God.
Now you're running Wait, oh my god, you're such a pussy.
You're actually such a pussy
That goddamn pussy I'm gonna go to Apollo What time stop?
Gosh, he's here.
How is he so tough?
No
Unfortunately, we shall never know if yours was a mere empty
threat for you are going on a little time out you can't do
that you're not my dad
what no wait where am i you wish to trace through this realm
i'm here what is this oh this area where does haiti's one
where am i wait send me back to haiti's one
okay what witchery is this oh god i can't see shit you knew
how to resist my little spell what's this what's this oh i
have to stay in the circle oh oops oops
did i do it Guys, I did it, guys.
Guys, I did it.
I did the speedrun shot.
Guys, I was speedrunning.
I was speedrunning, guys.
Alright.
Alright, 1, 2, 3.
Yeah, but the item might have been not Good guys.
Oh, I guess it has two times a hit.
Guys, the item just wasn't that good.
So I just...
Oh yeah, I have to...
Oh yeah, it's 60.
Okay.
All right, we gotta go.
The anti's coming back in.
Oh, good.
You're just in time for a set.
Been working on a song called I Am Gonna Claw.
Out your eyes, then drown you to death.
Oh.
Comes from a real person.
Like...
Who's the you?
Not me, right?
That isn't the one I heard on my way in.
No, it's not because all our songs are...
Oh, they're not where?
Each like a perfect little child.
Oh, I didn't get the dialogue?
Oh.
Alright.
That's right, the haters here!
Oh my god, that was a lot of damage.
Oh my...
I don't remember how I could kill.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm already dead.
It's already...
It's already over before it could begin.
Oh, yeah.
No, this is not good, guys.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's okay.
I have one more death defiance.
That's right.
This is where it's for, girl.
Okay.
That's okay.
Okay, I got rid of your bases.
That's right.
How can you?
You can't sing acapella, girl.
You're not that good.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I ran into her.
That was my bad.
Okay, I ran into her again.
That's my bad.
Nice.
That's right.
Can't keep tempo now.
Oh, God.
I have to kill her bases so she can't sing acapella.
That's right.
What you gotta do When you have to sing Acapella, girl!
Okay, it's fine.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
I can just kill her.
Here.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I can still just kill her.
Alright.
I did have to use my Deftify.
I have no more Deftify.
That's awkward.
It's a little awkward.
I don't have Death Defiance anymore.
Apologies.
Yep.
Technical difficulties.
Guys, no refunds.
No refunds.
The haters won again.
Let's go.
Collected works of Sailor Slang, Skiller, and her sirens lie
conspicuously scattered here.
A parting vengeance on the sensibility of those who dare to
take a closer look.
That's right.
Concerts canceled, guys.
No refunds You're such a mess That little dress Oh gods
Alright nice Next area I swear to god If Ares comes back I
swear to god I use two death defiance You can't say that I
deserve it It's so I swear to god Ares There's no way I
deserve another I swear to god I Why is she She back!
Why?
You again.
What?
Are you concerned?
My task just isn't difficult enough.
Going a bit too swimmingly.
Toki, I sold my house for this content.
How?
I assumed death defiance.
Actually, yes.
I was a little worried about that.
You got past the sirens.
What next?
You'll go kill Kronos and then what?
I mean, I could have.
Let's not do anything.
I could have!
Oopsie.
No!
I don't depreciate.
What does she do to me?
Oh, okay.
Back at it again.
Maybe they should have just made the game harder.
It's the punishing me.
Here we go again.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I know what to do.
Ha ha ha ha.
Guys, what am I...
If they're gonna curse me, I might as well go God mode.
That's all I'm saying.
Like, I might as well.
Do it, do it.
I'm so thankful.
Don't go there, Joki.
You're better than her.
Am I, though?
Am I?
curse me and I'm mad.
She's the one that cursed me!
Okay.
I need to get her out.
I don't like the Medusa.
I think the Medusa one is the...
The Medusa is the one that I don't like.
Alright.
Like, I had to use two Deft of Fire to get here, Eris.
Your specials create one projectile.
Your attacks linger for two and launch back towards you
after you dash.
What?
Oh.
Oh, I feel like three.
Yeah, three.
I need more range.
I definitely need more range.
There's the other one.
Where the fuck is the other boon?
Where am I missing it?
Oh hey, tree.
Oh this should work, right?
Oh nice.
Alright, that's good.
Oh my god, not the fucking shadow man.
Oh no.
It's okay, I have the moon beam.
Moon beam power!
I know, but I know.
Transform!
Oh!
Rushing damage surrounds foes and inflicts weak.
Your weak effects are more potent.
Do I have other weaks yet?
I do.
I'm cast.
Uh...
I don't know.
One or three?
The moon.
Two?
I guess two.
That's more power.
Two?
Alright.
My heart.
I want to make sure I'm not missing any, like, those, like,
bonus boons.
Demeter Posada.
I mean, I could have Freeze.
Can I still get Freeze?
I can, right?
God, I fucking hate her.
Can I still get Freeze with my attack?
Like...
Yeah?
All right, we'll go...
We'll see if we can get Freeze on attack.
god fuck this bitch okay i have to get rid of the queen
first are you serious
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh you bitch god if you didn't
have that 30 goddamn percent shit are you serious that would
have not done I've got too close to her.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
The worst part is, like, I can't even get too close to her
because of it.
There we go.
Stupid snakes.
This is why Zeus turned you into a snake.
Your sprint for his weren't clear enough encounters.
A random boon you have gains rarity.
I feel like two I'm gonna get two I didn't let you guys read
Oh hey another Another talking thing Hello Lord time Someone
there Someone there Oh Where's she I mean you know harm I
mean you know harm No harm Hello That makes two of us What
else is an echo Is there something I could do To ease your
burden ease your burden ease your burden ease your burden
yeah i knew it i knew it but she's not worth talking to all
right and if that's the copy of your most recently claimed
award gain plus 50 dodge but lose percentage of this each
time you dodge gain 60 percent max help but lose after each
location blessing was doing wait what did i get for it what
was my number two what was my what did I get again don't
even remember
we get to a new meter again oh okay yay
your castes oh my freeze last log oh but I don't use your
cast deals more damage your body circle the okay two or
three no attack still i know
one oh i guess it gives the sprint i guess yeah okay i'll do
that i can gift her no i can't she doesn't want to talk to
me see she doesn't want to talk to me anymore even though
she's a fucking echo that's more than usual Oh, more
Demeter.
That's gonna be more at max HP, but I don't think it
matters.
It gives me Demeter and Boone and Apollo.
But that's just gives me magic and health.
We want magic health or Demeter or more Boone?
Chat, which is better?
I didn't count him a second time?
Okay.
Left?
Alright.
I survive if I can survive if I can live guys that's the
that's the thing I'm not doing so well right now if I can
live to activate it then good good
nice Jesus Christ how did it get closer to me all right
we'll activate this then okay let's grab the ice Let's move
first.
Oh god.
Alright.
I hate you, Ares.
I fucking hate you, bitch!
Found you at last.
Princess of the Underworld.
I regret having to contact you at such a time.
It's not my custom to intervene during moments of doom.
Only to observe.
Oh shit, do I get a third chance?
Hello?
Moments of doom.
lord morose emissary of the three fates so your sisters hurt
me after all oh the three fates they actually respond oh
whoops oh my god they saw my text they're responding to my
text guys i expected me to find you but there's something
they intend for you to have wherever you're going look for
it when you arrive i'm uncertain if we meet again farewell
okay all right look for it
an offering, too.
It didn't ghost me.
It just takes, like, three to five business days.
He's gone.
Alright.
I must be hiding for a bit.
Why?
Oh, hey, is that...
Yeah, that's it, right?
This is from the three fates.
Oh, nice!
Preveal and the Daughter of God, there shall temporary
setback, which is the underworld and prevail and battle
there.
And meet the Huntress, the Messenger, Give out five.
I mean, that's easy.
I can get that done.
Sister blades, crescent, shadow of death.
Okay, I got one of the things.
From the shadows.
Aha.
All right.
What else can I make?
Oh, I can make...
Okay, become alerted to a vow that may sometimes be found in
any...
Oh, okay.
What?
Mostly used with incantation involving...
How much do I have?
How many plants do I have anyway?
I have...
Oh, I have just enough for two.
Nice.
Alright, get me that soil.
Great Gaia.
Share your secrets if my worth is true.
You know gamers don't look down.
So moat it be.
Yay!
We can plant now!
We can garden!
Let's go!
The fate's indulge.
you after all that is their scroll beside your tent it
followed you out of the timely farm simulator perhaps it can
provide some answers nice would that it does the fated list
has tasked me with ensuring certain day gardening fulfilled
those as little else as yet may it reward your efforts at
least oh god but do not expect the fates to always favor you
the bane of our enemy is not necessarily our friend.
Okay.
What do you mean?
Why won't they be my friend?
There's something by the broker.
Oh yeah, what's this?
Oh?
One credit card gives me what how many?
Oh.
It gives me 20 ashes.
Do I want that?
Or should I save for psyche?
I feel like I should save, right?
Should I spend I did her save, guys.
Save it for Psyche.
Alright, I'll save it.
Oh, hey, Nemesis!
Knocked your scrawny ass all the way back here.
It's insane that she's sending you out on foot, all on your
own.
You're fortunate you have even this responsibility for all
your questioning of all disease.
Yeah, what are you doing with your life?
Oh, shut up.
Exactly.
Oh, y'all see?
God nerfed, didn't I?
I'm more important than you.
I'm the princess of hell.
You're just a...
You're barely a fucking god.
Yeah, no, I fucking...
No, I saw her twice.
No, I know.
She's trying to stop me.
Or at least slow me down.
And she knows too much about our intentions.
What do we do?
Yeah, you're just an incarnate.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
Why are they on my side?
She doesn't know the half of what we've planned.
Besides her boredom drives her...
Why don't we just kill her?
I don't understand.
Why do we let her do this to us?
Here, I got you something.
Here's my necklace.
Or temptations while I'm on duty or off.
You're doing this because you want something for me anyway.
There's always a way to kill a guy.
Yay, freestyle.
Got an evil eye.
Okay, that's...
Okay, I got an evil eye.
I hope it's not that evil.
I mean, I have a lot of nectar.
I might as well just gift it.
Hey, Odysseus.
Got you something here I wanted you to have.
For always keeping an eye out.
Yeah, but there must be a cooldown.
If we kill her, then I can at least...
There's a cooldown for them to respawn.
Yeah.
There you go.
Yay!
Thank you.
Okay, I'm glad.
I can gift you something while you're sleeping, right?
May you have pleasant dreams for as long as you slumber.
And if and when you finally wake, know that this nectar
shall be waiting for you.
Yay!
Where would the gift come from, though?
If he's sleeping.
I love the voice acting so much because it means I don't
have to read.
Welcome to the what?
Wait, he didn't give me anything.
That bitch.
I'll give her stuff too.
Headmistress.
If it isn't inappropriate, I have a little gift.
Seeing as your personal supply ran out a while back.
She is sleeping too.
I should be allowed to, like, rob something.
Like, not rob, like, take something from.
after I give her something.
It's a trade.
Yay!
Silver wheel.
I can have this.
Yay!
Okay, I should...
That's enough, right?
Yeah.
This wasn't on the list before.
Oh?
Oh.
There's still one where I gifted five...
Those are not...
Oh, here we go.
Yay!
I did a...
prophecy I did it okay I should be able to increase my grasp
I increased in my psyche the cast makes you impervious when
you have less than your attack and special deal 30% damage
you gain plus three your sprint is 5% faster you have I feel
like the Huntress card.
Yeah.
Since I always have, like, less in it.
The next guardian loses minus 5%.
You take minus.
You gain 50% this night.
We're going to fully restore.
Gain a plus 100 this night.
Deal 20% damage to the last four that you vanquish.
Okay, yeah, that doesn't fucking matter.
Oh, I could buy it.
You're right.
Oh, I could buy another.
Oh, yeah.
I could buy another card.
I can't equip it, I feel like.
Right?
Can I?
You cast momentarily.
Sprint lets you pass through most foes in your way.
Your castment makes you impervious and move.
Okay, I should grab that.
Oh, I can!
Nice.
I should be able to get the blades now.
Yeah.
Yay!
New weapon.
Okay, let's try this weapon.
Okay.
okay this is more so close range all right what is the oh i
have like dash okay what is my cue or the engineer oh it's
the same okay oh it's like a boomerang okay i can also get
the tools i forgot about the tools the tablet tablet piece
you are mine now I assume that that one I have oh I can fish
wait okay give psyche if I find them Oh all right we can go
now All right let's gaze into the sky The eye of night
Oh it's a half moon oh is this when I know when um Is it
when it's a full moon The moon girl comes over?
I wish.
The lightning sigil.
Zeus?
No?
Oh.
What does the moon mean?
Yay, Zeus!
The whore!
The man's done.
To help us settle an old score.
If you possess your father's strength, then we have the
advantage.
We got a Zooch blessing.
Your attacks inflict blitz.
What is true?
He fucks everything.
Whoa, I mean, you're not wrong.
Yeah, you guys didn't know.
Okay, for those who don't know, his lord, is he literally
fucks anything that moves.
Even a goose.
One?
Or a swan.
He doesn't care.
And if you reject him, he turns you into a snake.
That's where we got Medusa.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
He was the goose.
Bro, I can't remember all his fucking fucked up sex stories,
guys.
I...
I can't...
I can't remember.
That was Athena.
Bro, I know all the gods are fucking assholes.
I just grouped them all together because they're all bad
people.
There's too many scandals I don't know One or two guys Which
one's better
Not my god Oh she though Yes What I see more ones I'll do
one
Then...
Okay.
I don't know if I like...
I think the staff has been my favorite weapon so far.
But I don't know.
Oh my god, that was fast.
I can't tell yet.
I think the staff has definitely been my favorite weapon
though.
Okay.
Because it has a good between...
It's like a good balance between...
the two the river coquitis winds through endless misty
passageways the wailing souls within its languid waters all
denied their eternal rest oh it's because like there's no
hades anymore which is better i mean if i do i only have one
power up so it automatically upgrades my lightning that one
hammer hammer is always better okay
what the fuck okay i don't know what hit me i'm like what
the fuck hit me
goodness it's so fast too i'm not used to it all right nice
hammer hammer tab your special deals 15 years each hits oh
attack wait wait but my special is a boomerang oh two i feel
like my special is a a boomerang too three three okay one
for three or three all right let's do three dead my blades
shine like the moon come maestrels what the okay okay i i
was not expecting that insane range Jesus Christ.
Okay, that like...
That messed me up.
Oh, that's bad.
I did not expect that.
I was like, where the fuck did he come from?
That was a long-ass range.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah, that was fucking bullshit.
Okay.
Okay, we'll grab this guy first.
Okay, fuck it.
Don't let him charge it up.
What is, like, the charge for this?
Uh...
I don't have enough for shop.
I'll do shop.
I don't have enough.
Lord Keron, I've returned.
Hello!
I met one of your brothers, Lord Keron.
It was Moros.
He delivered to me a certain artifact.
But then was gone.
Oh, it's a teleport?
All right, good talk good talk It's been in my family's care
before.
Oh Oh, what of morose?
Where could he have gone in all of this?
Oh, it does a teleport behind you.
Oh, perhaps I can locate him again I'll do heck it here
Here's the gold Or has here
underworld like he used to nothing to do for those these
days except to burn whoa your sprint leaves the trail but
any damage you take from burning is when you're attack or
specialty deal damage restore don't use a lot of magic
though should i just get old cast to aim the fire by the
explodes on i don't think i i don't know two is big i don't
really use magic that much i mean i can try oh i got another
zeus okay let's let's see if i live oh my god oh my god are
you serious
oh my god bro no no no no no no no no that is not that is oh
i'm alive yeah russian cars are surrounding first we struck
you're strike inmates.
Oh, wait.
Wait, your strikes?
Admits.
Isn't two good?
One?
I thought two would be good, right?
I forgot to gift.
Lightning from on high.
Oh, I wish we grabbed this.
Yeah.
Each time I strike.
And I do a lot.
Yeah, oh my god.
Oh my god.
They're dead.
They're fucking dead.
Yeah, that's- this shit is strong.
Yeah, I was gonna say, don't I- Does this do a lot?
There you go.
Boon or heart?
I feel like- I can upgrade my stuff, yeah.
This one's hard to decide.
Okay, nice.
Okay, oh.
That's right, can't get me.
Boomerang!
Fast rep!
The power!
Okay, this is strong as hell.
I like this.
I'm getting more used to it.
Okay, your attacks and flip-flips.
Your strike.
Four!
Okay, I don't need magic.
Okay, one or three, guys.
One or three.
I'm sorry, upgrade time.
Palm.
Three, right?
That's right!
More lightning!
Aphrodite or Apollo?
For my build, who would offer me better shit?
Chat.
Apollo Aphrodite.
I feel like I don't know well enough about what they offer
me.
Apollo?
Don't think with your...
Guys, don't think with your dick right now.
I need...
I don't think...
Don't think I was...
think what's your pee-pee right now?
Apollo or Aphrodite?
What?
But what if I'm thinking with my heart, Doki?
Too late.
I am thinking with my pee-pee and I say Apollo.
Okay, okay.
I'm thinking with both.
of heart choices.
That guy is not thinking with his heart, too, key.
Aphrodite.
Okay, I swear to God if you like, you better not be thinking
with your pee-pee, The woods aren't so my cool.
Okay.
Alright, we're...
Okay, this is strong as hell, though.
The Zeus food is so good.
Okay.
I love the boomerang.
Boomerang!
I forgot to gift her.
I have been around quite a bit longer than appearances
suggest.
Oh, shit.
The so-called golden age that Kronos would restore.
It was the dullest time.
Like you would not- Hag Friday?
Alright.
This special deals more damage for you.
to nearby foes.
That doesn't really help.
And for the rest of this night.
Rushing damage surrounding foes.
Wait.
What?
I don't know for this.
Two for a week?
Hmm.
Two.
Okay.
We'll do more damage.
Let's just have more damage.
We'll grab health.
We don't use magic that much anyway, so it doesn't really
matter for us.
So on weepers.
What the?
Okay, I was gonna say, how the fuck do I am I taking damage
right now?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Alright, that's fine.
There we go.
Thank God I got healthier.
I don't have a lot of money, but I feel like I don't need
mana anyway, so I might as well go to them.
Uh, might as well buy food, I guess.
Food time.
We broke it anyway.
Alright, another test.
Apollo's the damn son.
I don't care how high for the idea.
She can't beat nuclear fission.
Loveful of hot.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nom, nom, nom.
Oh, unless Aris...
Aris is coming back, isn't she?
Perhaps you do.
However much I've taught, what's important is your capable I
have to be more than that.
Oh my god, I fucking hate that.
Oh my god, there you go.
Okay.
For sure.
Oh, there you go.
What?
Okay.
That's bullshit.
That's fake, but real one's here.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
Alright.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Okay, how...
Oh, my God, I made it.
I was gonna say how many times I have to dodge this.
What, nice.
Die every time!
Every...
He's tapped.
Okay, that's fine.
Yes, we did it!
Oh, that's fast.
Oh!
We did it.
I dodged her stupid sheep attack.
Okay, I like the build I have with this weapon.
I think it's because my weapon is really good for this
build.
I mean, that's why.
I have a good, good build right now.
But...
I think I definitely need more health.
Oh hey!
Don't worry.
Uh...
And...
When shown?
I'm helping?
Why don't we try again?
Okay, wait wait, wait.
Come join.
Okay, I got this.
I'm a little confused.
Oh, stop!
Shit!
I-
Why I need him?
Go stay in hell!
I'll need you
It said let go left click and I let go right click I don't
need him He doesn't need to be saved Fuck him Guys it's
because I let go left click I let go right When I told me to
let go left I need his psyche I can get my psyche anywhere
else As thick I'm a V-Tuber.
There's plenty of that to go around.
It's five.
Okay, here we go.
We did it.
Moon.
We'll get moon.
We can have extra moon fight battle.
Actually, I don't know.
because like the only issue is the fact that like i don't
use a lot of magic so it's gonna force me to use more magic
there you go selenie selenie come on we have heard nothing
from fleet footed hermes since he told us where did hermes
go but he's fast and yet hold to faith that some night hence
he shall return to us with news about what else the titan
chronos has in store I forgot to give her to again.
The hex makes you rise up and crash down the target area for
grass blasts to large guys.
I don't have a lot of magic.
Um...
I don't think I have...
One?
Okay, one.
I don't have the magic to...
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Use one on sirens.
Oh, that's true.
I can do that on the sirens.
Do I want...
I can't afford anything.
I don't think I can.
Okay.
But I didn't just do this.
That's right.
That's why.
That's why I can't get near me.
There you go.
straight what are you gonna do about that huh oh shit he's
oh shit that's what he's gonna do oh my god okay lost one
can't block forever get out of there that's right all right
heart or Zeus I'm gonna get more HP I think I need it with
my close range What's the goddamn vapor?
Of course.
It's always the vapor.
Oh my god, I stood in the vapor again.
I can't stand in it again.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I keep standing in the vapor.
I...
It keeps happening.
Wait, what is this?
Is this lore and...
I can't help it.
Okay.
Like, what is this?
It's a sauna move anywhere.
No, but there's a thing next to it.
There's like this.
Forget.
It's new encounter?
Oh, it's a prophecy.
Okay, we'll try it out.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, this is bad.
This is bad.
I'm...
This is so bad.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Alright, where is he?
There he is.
It's fine.
There we go.
We got him.
In the name of Hades.
I told you it was fine!
I keep forgetting to give him stuff.
Okay, your special inflicts scorch.
That's good.
Your cast inflicts scorch on foes.
Oh, shit.
Okay, your foes perish in a blast that damage.
Oh, wait.
Should I get flash?
Wait, one.
Wait, not three?
Two?
One or two?
I use three, two.
Well, I use scorch a lot.
I mean, I use the right click a lot.
Hmm.
Two is great for bosses.
I should...
Oh, that's true.
I used two for bosses.
I accept this gift.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I forgot to talk.
There was a glowing thing I didn't see.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my favorite.
The mirror sheen of the standing waters all about revealed
to denizens of Oceania's their full selves.
To their horror.
I mean, I know it's so hard to be this beautiful, man.
It really is.
God, what torture to be so handsome.
Excuse me.
All right, let's gift him next day.
Of course.
He's the one.
Yes, this is the one I remember the gift guys I just relate
to him so much just as a casual acquaintance to be clear I
like how it's like I'm just doing it as we're not friends by
the way, but here's a gift You give me such tokens of
affection full knowing.
I've already got a lot of them and more importantly I'm
spoken for bro.
You're you're not single?
Who can love you as much as you can love yourself?
Nice.
How could I ever forget you, Narcissus?
I know, right?
He's so unforgettable.
Whoever you are, at least you've got more guts than all my
other would-be suitors back there.
Though you still don't have a chance.
He is taken by himself.
I know, I was like, who would love you more than yourself?
This truth must have felt strongly for you in life if
they've been lingering nearby.
But it wasn't my intent to be out of town.
Meany to thank you for your gift the other night.
I know every opening line there is and merely to thank you
is one of the classics acting all to mirror Well, I know
what you really want and you're not getting it.
Just this Just this All right, what do we want?
All right, why you guys help me decide?
I need P up your back
All right Two or three?
I guess I'll get three right for the mana Oh We're seeing
what you guys decided on.
Have the Council of Dragoons.
What have you decided?
Bite Medi.
Thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
All right, for mana.
All right.
There you go.
All right, let's go.
God, I hate these guys the most.
All right.
Get rid of him.
my god fucking course the last second all right are you
serious oh god i'm just too fast for me sometimes i just go
way too fast oh i should be a i have enough money for a shop
but zeus or shop guys zeus or shop i feel like enough zeus
is it not worth the shop Okay, Zeus for the...
I guess his power-ups are really good.
Okay, I gifted.
This time I remember, Chad.
I remember this time.
You might have, Uncle Zeus.
Vanquisher of Titans.
Your strength has saved our family before.
You're most kind to now share some of it with me.
I did it, guys.
I remembered.
Alright, Uncle.
Oh, my God.
He's back after being the...
His hundredth women.
He actually has time for me.
Yeah, thank you, uncle.
Your foe is struck by, and again, 50% of the time.
Damage from Moons immediately activates Blitz and makes them
stronger.
Oh!
Your special inflicts Blitz.
I feel like two or three is better, isn't it?
Sorry, not hundreds.
I'm sorry, I meant that's me low-balling it.
A thousand and...
There's a thousand women.
Uh, only women.
Sorry, a thousandth, one thousandth women and the three
thousandth men.
Because we were in those times.
We heard about the saunas, guys.
All right.
Oh, and then the 50th animal.
I heard about the bathhouses, guys, back then.
Uh...
We're like three.
Yeah, let's do three.
Just for the boss.
The ante is back!
You thought you could...
I'm gonna...
Guys, I'm canceling the third concert.
Let's go.
Now we're ready.
How did you like our latest song, lady?
Oh, did it not do the dialogue again?
That's right.
I'm here to cancel the third concert.
If you seek feed...
Okay, I think it didn't work again.
That's right.
I'm going to make sure none of you guys can watch the
concert.
The course was catchy enough.
But the lyrics and their disturbing themes were rather
disturbing.
distracting.
I'll never let their fans hear the end of the song.
That's right.
You'll never get to hear the end of her song.
No more
music.
That's right.
rhythm for you, girl!
Oh, shit!
Oh.
Alright.
Gotta get rid of the rhythm.
Oh, shit!
Oh, are you serious?
No!
Death Defiance!
Okay, I was so cocky there.
I fucked up.
It's so hard to see.
Oh my god, it's so hard.
It's so clever.
There's so much clever, though.
Oh no.
I might have to accidentally.
She just...
She's so hard for...
This is not the best for...
My...
Yes!
Oh!
That's okay.
I lost the depth of fives, but that's okay.
I canceled another concert.
You'll never get a concert, dragons.
The anties shall win.
I'll never give you guys another concert.
And down I go.
The power of the anties.
Eris's back isn't she?
It's dry a hair at least.
she's back oh my god why when does it stop when does she
stop don't be wasting any further breath on you while you
perpetuate this nonsense you never understood me trouble
fine you don't have to just remember that I'm doing this for
your own good what do you mean for my own good I almost
fucking saved the world.
See you later.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to slow you down.
Blessed again.
Alright.
Is it the same curse?
It's always this curse, isn't it?
It'll never be different.
Let's just go straight into it.
Oh my god, I can't see shit.
Oh my, there she is.
Are you serious oh my god it's it i i don't know if i like i
don't know if i like uh oh do i want this i don't know if i
like the fire cast because it it like fucks with me because
the attacks are red and my cast is red too she really hates
you get blessed
uh yeah it's so hard to see the attacks because my cast is
also red.
Alright.
So it's like, I'm not sure if I like it.
I mean, I actually no, I don't like it.
You know, fuck it.
I actually don't like it.
I literally can't see shit.
I'm gonna do this for now, because I don't want to get
close.
Alright, nice.
in the name of Hades.
Yeah, my two ranked up.
Your chain lane deals more damages and bounces up.
Whatever you use this, I should get electric overload.
Yeah.
My special.
I feel like I should get two, right?
Yeah.
I can get out now.
Yeah, no, I'm not going to fight that boss.
Yeah.
Let's grab.
Let's grab the food real quick i think the food might
actually be pretty good i'm not really doing so well hp wise
uh let's get hammer
yeah oh my god i'm gonna kill her first the thorn the
goddamn thorn I was like, what the fuck hit me?
Ooh, he's fucking growing flowers here!
Okay, each hit you from your special deals.
500 damage to armor.
Wait.
Damage in a...
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Ah.
Wait, your attacks deal on your striking.
Okay, from behind.
Okay, I feel like one.
Yeah, one for the armor.
Armor seems good.
Wait.
Because I don't know about...
Oh god, okay, not you.
Not you.
God damn it.
That's why you can't get me!
No, fuck it.
There we go.
Money.
Uh, oh.
Is it Echo?
That's Echo.
Oh, no, this is different.
lives here oh it is who are you may I ask hello echo wait I
can't gift her we're not have enough items no she just won't
accept my gift because she's not real who are you may I ask
may I ask she's not real guys she's just an echo so I am
Melina we family business down in Tartarus and you are do I
hear an oh after this talk okay
Oh, she said...
She finally responds.
Okay.
From the previous night, manifest a copy of your most
recently claimed rewards.
God damn it.
If I knew I wouldn't have got the coins first.
Being 50% dodge chance.
Okay.
I should get...
Yeah.
I should get boon, boon, boon, right?
Three?
A dodge?
No, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
I feel like I'll spam the dodge and use it up in, like, two
rooms.
Be strong.
What do I get?
Your attacks gain power, but you prime 20.
Whenever you clear enough encounters, a random wound, you
have gained rarity.
Oh.
Wait.
Your special deals.
Oh.
One.
Freeze.
Yeah.
I use one a lot, too.
Okay, now again.
Even in a place of sorrow such as this, there's beauty.
Yeah, don't worry.
I'll throw money at you, and then you'll be happier, right?
Perhaps this will help.
Here you go.
Pick a gift.
What do I get?
Concave stone.
It's an honor.
Yay!
I got a stone from her body.
She gave a piece of her body to me, guys.
Jealous?
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll grab this.
Dodge is not dashed.
Oh, okay.
That's good to know.
That's actually really good to know.
All right.
That's right.
She gave it to me.
Ooh.
She picked me to hack.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Who was through that?
Jesus Christ Okay, who keeps throwing that?
That's not cool Oh, it's these things
Okay, nice Okay, I have to destroy these Wait, I can't
destroy it Oh, that's fucked I don't like that
Okay, I think I can kill these guys now.
Nice.
Okay, I should be able to do the magic stuff for this now.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ!
Boom!
Okay, wait, I can kill this wolf.
Nice.
All right, gift, here's a nectar.
Great Aphrodite.
You must get more offerings than all the other gods and
goddesses combined.
Though this one comes from me.
Yeah.
I feel like I gave so many gifts today.
I must return the gesture.
So please.
I'm in means I'm so lucky with all my runs lately.
Like if Ares didn't fuck me over, I think I wouldn't be in
this game by the way.
I know.
I actually think if Ares didn't exist, I would have fucking
beaten the game.
Ooh, it's flipping over.
Don't just take my word for it, gorgeous.
Your wise and even-handed uncle.
Oh.
Wait, which one?
Wait a minute, which uncle?
The thing is, this does not narrow it down.
Aphrodite fucked everything, too.
She was literally the goddess of love.
Oh, oh, okay.
This is based on love of family and of mortal kind.
Wait, I'm going to talk to him later, too.
Oh, shit.
Okay, rushing into foes with Blitz immediately activates the
effect.
Oh, nice.
Romantic spark.
Uh, all right.
That's cool.
I'm going to talk to him later, too.
All right, there he is as well.
That's awkward.
Yes, another duel.
though.
Oh my god.
He did so much.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck it.
I don't know who is going to summon.
I'll take it.
Whatever.
Oh my.
I have.
It took so much damage.
So I'll take it.
I'll just summon it just for the sake of it.
In the name of Hades.
Yeah, he definitely has...
Oh!
Another duel?
Also cost his lightning balls to be refit.
Oh, shit!
Let's go!
Double duos!
Okay, I have a lot of money.
See, I can do this.
That's my way.
My mom gives you two duos!
Okay, let's grab...
I have so much money.
I'll grab food first.
Because I need this.
Another duel!
duo?
What?
Feels damaged faster.
Oh, shit.
Guys, which one do we want?
The duo or the epic?
I got three duos in a row.
I got so many duos that they stopped talking to me.
That's crazy.
They stopped talking to me.
Alright.
They want...
I don't giving you another one.
Yo, dog.
I heard you like duos.
Wait, he's evil again?
But I thought I saved you.
Call me yourself, Severus.
We're going to fix this.
Yeah, I thought I saved you already.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, 39.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, I hate this.
No,
fuck this.
I fuck this.
I hate you, Aeris.
I fucking hate you.
I hate you.
Why are you harder?
Wait, why is he harder?
Wait a minute.
Why is he harder?
Return to shadow now.
is that singing
when does eris leave when does or how can i kill her i've
heard our old song in a while have you i'll enjoy it while
she's here how do i kill the witch i'll start brooding I'm
brooding right now.
And you'll have so much to talk about.
That the longing for them spur you on.
Eris did this to me.
Tad runs!
That whore.
That fucking whore.
What you say is the most frightening thing you've
encountered out there lately, Mel?
It's important for someone in my position to keep up with
the latest on this front.
Well, I'd have to go with the raging infernal beast guarding
the only viable way into Tartarus.
Absolutely massive.
Countless sharp fangs.
Three fire-spitting moors.
Though he's also my family's dog.
How did he get fucking infected again?
I thought I saved him.
How did you get me going?
Well, if you're telling me there's nothing scarier out there
than a pet dog, it means I've got no competition.
Time to rest on this.
God, if you're listening, please kill Aris Parker.
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please make yourself comfortable.
All that you see is me.
i have to find lord morose once again and call him here i'm
so sad because like okay because like i had the best i had
so many duos too i had so many duos what's the point is she
here the rivers have afloat back there oh there she is oh to
interrupt i had not expected this to be a time for
That's a good start.
Hey, since you're here, why not lend me your voice for all
time's sake?
Let go your burdens for a bit.
I'll sing with her.
La la la.
That's it.
La.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
also sound been good the last four out i'm not sure i've
asked this earlier i hope the sound's been okay the last
four hours welcome lord karon oh karon's here i think i know
how i can do the bidding of the fates wow wow forget me not
press on recipes for aglass and which resources you need.
I don't think I need that.
That's good.
Sounds been good.
Gives her each night to have free thirst yielding.
Okay, what else do I mean?
Oh, I don't have materials now.
I mean, I might as well just build this just because I can.
all right
notes this so any fruit three forgive me after acquiring the
resources okay hello sharon
these shipments shall be very valuable to us we remain as
ever in your debt karon they swift hermes hasten your
voyages across the realms wherever he may be used to be the
fastest god alive.
How could he just be disappear?
Thank you for the supplies, my lord.
Yay.
More supplies.
Let's go.
Oh yeah, what were you doing?
Huh?
You just stood there.
Why aren't you there distracting Eris?
Isn't personal.
You don't see my mother around either, do you, Nem?
They got him.
What?
Yeah, they just got him.
Kronos took them all.
Bro, she's my auntie.
My mother too.
And I knew mine.
What's yours to you?
All you ever did was fall out of her womb.
What did you do?
Bro, she's such an auntie.
I still don't have...
I'm still trying to save up for...
I mean, I have a lot of bones.
I might as well just buy Psyche and this.
The crossroads.
That haven hidden twigs the surface and the underworld.
You mean they got him.
See, she hates me, and then I hate the Sirens.
It's like a circle of hate.
I'll never stop the cycle.
Together we'll retake my father's role.
I once was desperate to hear the Sirens' song.
I barely resisted their temptations.
Of course, I was merely mortal.
Perhaps you're less susceptible to their allure.
Yeah, I've ruined three concerts already.
I failed to see the appeal.
Although it's possible the Sirens were better off.
without skiller she seems rather bossy yeah they don't need
her she's a menace caught half a dozen of my crew like she'd
a separate set of teeth for each of the poor lads we'd
little choice but to pray to the gods and sail on tell her
hello for me did the gods answer your call at least yeah did
she or did they for the most part i mean you're dead so i
don't know he's dead
Oh, let's plant too.
Oh, no.
Alright, let's plant this.
Oh, I can.
I see it now.
Can't upgrade?
No, I can't.
Okay.
Restore every...
Your sprint is 5% lets you pass through most foes.
You have 200 coins.
0.8.
I feel like everything moving slower would be better.
Your hex also charges up automatically as you used...
Okay.
Centaur is good?
You gain when you pass through...
Oh!
We'll get that later.
Swift is good for early runs?
What's Swift?
Oh, this?
Oh, might as well.
Your need requires...
You may use the grasp below to extend...
Okay, we'll need more grasp later.
I lack the grasp for this.
Uh, we'll grab swiftness then.
Okay, let's grab that.
There's the grave thirst aura by the silver pool.
I think...
Witchstaff?
We did the best with Witchstaff.
She fucked me so much.
So much with the goddamn curse that Witchstaff has...
Has been the only one that's saved me.
Oh,
I don't know.
Should we get...
Should we get this?
Uh...
That's true.
We could try it.
If we can make it.
The tube has been doing good for us, though.
Purse or Zeus?
Who's the guardian?
Stone will get better with more rings?
Should we just upgrade this?
When do we get the thing where we can change our items?
When do we get that?
Oh, the arena boss.
Okay.
Later?
But when is later?
So we get...
You know what?
Let's Let's do this for now.
I don't think we...
We have one death defiance, so it should be fine.
Yeah.
Oh?
You once held a place of honor in my father's house.
So you must know Cerberus, right?
I found him in the morning fields, coated in miasma, heads
to pause.
Was he always prone to uncontrolled fits of rage?
Oh, no.
He mostly sat around.
Yeah.
You go way back.
It's just...
I don't know why is he so mad seeing as he's kind of like a
dog and I'm kind of like a bone yeah I think like yeah he's
giving you some trouble huh it's not his fault Kronos must
have cast him from the house put him out to pasture I broke
through all the grime and calmed him down but he may need
another cleansing soon he never did like bears all right
let's go he is not a good boy that dog is not a good boy
right now oh what the fuck you are Hermes house things you
good i'm good mostly and good to see your task is underway
but change your plan though it's not to ask
everyone's been trying to find you what do you mean olympus
my task is to stop chronos in the underworld i can hardly
breathe the surface air much less get to a mountaintop come
on em you have your ways grunts is up to something bad more
than his usual attacks so just give it some thought i
wouldn't ask if it was nothing right now gotta run and so do
you i'll be in touch by boone okay bye so long for now oh
goodbye goodbye
bro we're all trying to find you on the surface yeah on the
surface Josh chance and mood increase the more boons you
have wait do we want more dashes or dodge three right okay
we just got five boons we can do that but yeah no I
definitely I like I like the staff the most not even those
with the power to enter the crossroads at will can entirely
anticipate which of its three hidden paths shall be there's
three i still know the way yeah i was gonna say what do you
mean three good yeah definitely i think the staff is the
best for me just because of the my how i play three is so
good for buddy mashing make a lovely gift it's really like
my play style okay Alright, money time.
I think it's the best just because I can button mash too.
I think that's why.
It's the easiest to button mash.
And it's like hit scan.
Uh, Zeus.
Zeus for the lightning.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay, he has armor.
I was gonna say.
How is he so strong and tanky?
My FPS brain.
Please explain this in Apex terms.
Oops.
I got distracted.
That's right.
There's more of us than there is him.
Uh, okay, attacks.
Attacks is better than...
Oh yeah, I use attacks more anyway.
Yeah, Ash.
Come, caskets.
I use...
Oh, shit, okay.
It's good.
That's good, we need Blitz.
We just need, like, thunder, and then...
God, they're so tanky.
Alright, nice.
And then Flower!
Let's grab...
We need boons anyway.
The more boons we have, the more dodges we can do.
Oh, my god!
Okay, that's fuck me, I guess.
Guess I won't go back in there.
Okay, danger.
Just do this.
I didn't do any damage, right?
Wait, no, I'm not.
God damn it!
Okay, that's fine.
That's five.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
This guy is so annoying.
What?
Okay, that's five.
Okay, I hate.
I don't think I do not like that boss.
That boss is so annoying.
There you go.
Yeah, I had to go in.
My dad and I got on all right.
Comparatively speaking, I suppose.
after we put the titans in there it's okay i can rebuild
myself i can rebuild myself guys oh that's why you weren't
there in haiti's one your special inflict scorch you hold
cast aim and fireball i guess one so i can inflict scorch
yeah one attacker special deal damage restore magic i don't
use magic i don't know one or two three i'm so bad like if i
have to hold the cast.
I think it's gonna fuck with me.
3 for range?
Yeah, I remember I really didn't like 3.
Go for 2?
When we attack?
Yeah, I don't hold 2.
It's 1.
Okay.
We'll go with 1.
Oh, hey!
Oh!
She's back!
Oh, I thought there was like a mic.
There you go.
Yeah, that I'm fine with.
There you go, see?
I do this more.
Okay, nice.
There you go.
That is very convenient.
Moonlight.
Have I gifted Moon before?
I don't think I have.
I'll give her one, too.
Marsha, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
FYI, Odyssey was the only survivor, his whole crew died.
That's right, it was your fault.
But little star, you offer this to me.
The connection that we share as Silver Sisters is already
more than I can.
See?
We sink their cycles.
Yay!
Moon be- oh shit.
Moon by Barano.
Alright, let's see it.
Alright, we have up now.
The moon.
is to work in shadow to uphold the will of night olympus
remains unaware of us that their own goddess of the hunt is
one of us that their own messenger serves us as well wait
what let's keep it this way double agents your hex raises
the less last respectable vote okay i don't know um turns
into living nightmare of her own what which here complete oh
invulnerable to damage wait which one one or two
oh what is easy you're right I have to build up too much alt
for that nah I agree I would use two if it wasn't for the
fact that there's too much alt that have to build up for it
and like I don't I don't know if that's possible guys oh
shit there you go alright broke the armor I think that's the
only issue God, it's so weird not having freeze though Okay
That's fine
There we go You know what?
Go!
Oh my god That's right, I mean like You didn't do anything,
but yeah Oh shit the meter Okay We need to dodge
That's fine
all right it's fine we'll do casting here
boom oh my god i have the worst one
it's okay i believe in him i believe in this little guy he's
got this he's doing his best guys he's dead guys he did guys
he did his best and he's dead but he did his best To think
the goddess of seasons herself is my grandmother.
More boon!
I am honored to have made your acquaintance.
Hey, here's my gift.
I see the witch of the crossroads taught you not just
strength, but grace.
I hereby accept your offering.
Yeah!
Risa.
Thank you, Grandma.
A gift from Grandmother.
Yay!
More stuff from Grandma.
Grand Grand.
You've been locked in conflict with Kronos for so long.
so long?
How long?
I thought she's like, what?
In her 20s?
20 years is not that long for gods.
Really?
The meter, I need freeze.
Yeah, but for gods, it's like fucking nothing.
It's like one internet year for them.
Alright, I'll do the sprint.
Yeah, I'll do this.
Oh, that sucks.
I don't have nectar for the gifter.
The intricately woven spider silk ensconcing the environs of
one gloom-filled recess.
That sucks.
I don't have any more nectar.
Wrangles and quality.
Even the weavings of the gods themselves.
Arachne knows how stuff...
It's truly you.
It's me.
Ah, but...
okay bitch what the fuck was that for me was so beautiful
I'm sorry to say I got into a bit of a scrape why did you
kept her ear that was her Tokyo is your fault that was her
dinner oh that's quite all right silly yeah sorry I'm so
sorry I'm I'm so sorry for ruining your dinner, guys.
Alright, nice.
That makes you cast deal 100% more damage.
Wait, what?
Donnie.
Do we want channel or 100%?
I don't use cast for damage.
I don't.
I just get channeled, right?
So then I can channel it faster.
Okay.
For more armor?
I rarely cast, but maybe I will cast if it's faster.
Okay, I'm gonna do one, because then if it's faster, I'll
start channeling more guys.
Of course.
Think about it.
Thank you, Arachni.
No, you won't.
Believe in myself.
See, look at that.
Oh, look at that.
I'm channeling.
Look at that.
Look how fast that is!
Guys, look at that!
See, I told you!
And then I almost have no more armor.
I- Okay.
I might have almost used up my armor, but look, I was trying
to send a message here.
I already lost half my armor.
But I sent my message.
Alright.
Uh, 150, okay.
Oh, wait, I want to talk to him first.
Yeah!
I didn't get into the details of what he discovered, though
perhaps you know more.
Oh, okay.
I thought you'd actually say something, but I guess not.
You really have to pay that care on character in these
situations.
What sort of daft system is that?
Yeah.
I mean, he's got to make his money somehow.
A cast repeal and inflicts scorch.
God, I did not like that.
Like, the enchants which is doubled against scorch
affiliate.
Oh, wait.
That's more dodge.
I don't know.
Do you have more damage?
Oh.
Oh, I don't know.
Snuff candle, right?
I could have more dodge.
Two for more dodge, right?
Because I already have a lot.
I could have, like, if I have more dodge.
Then, like, I'll never get hit.
Yeah, it'll stack.
I'll never get hit if I keep dodging.
That should be how it works.
Okay, let's see.
How much do I even have now?
For my dodge.
Where is it?
Gain dodge chance with the more boons you have.
I have so many boons.
How much more does he want from me?
What concerns you?
I heard from Hermes headmistress He gave me the impression
that Olympus needs me Yeah, my 2.5% is building guys It's
building up Your task remains As does the adversary whom you
Guys, now I have 4% guys We have other matters elsewhere We
have other matters first Oh yeah, the stupid test That I
still have to do Are you seeing?
I dodged it Guys, I swear to God, I did dodge it Okay.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Return to fight, sisters.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright, fuck this.
I gotta get my summons.
Oh my gosh, She literally just barely made it.
Come on.
Fuck!
Oh my god, this is the real one.
Got you, girl!
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, not a stupid sheep.
Oh my god!
It's fine.
We're okay.
We still have four more armor, guys!
We still have, guys, we still have four more armor, it's
okay.
Okay.
That's right!
I'm using your girls against you!
Four armor and a dream, I still have it!
Impressive show of force.
Hold nothing back.
I told you guys!
I told you I'll use cast more.
I used to cast more 5% more.
guys five percent is five percent the armor survive okay i
definitely want to get max health oh you again can i give
him a gift such fire in your eyes how obstinate the members
of our family can be have you learned nothing from our
previous exchange i mean he's quit sending fucking eras on
me maybe i'll actually start learning why don't you get out
of my you know i don't learn i force my way to everything
but try to slow me down exactly he doesn't deserve a kid
come find me if you must have learned some more you know
where i reside i do not hide from gods see you okay here we
go how do i Oh, I was gonna say, where the fuck is the path?
Alright, here we go.
Back down, we go into hell.
Uh, oh.
I swear to God, I was gonna say, if I took damage before...
I didn't say, I swear to God, if I took damage there.
Okay.
Can't touch me.
Oh, shit.
Did you like, right, bet?
Okay.
I'll make sure I don't get touched by this.
Oh, nice.
Mine now.
Uh, do I have one Hermes or max HP chat?
I feel like...
I feel like I need more HP.
I don't know.
BGM.
I mean, I still have it.
Boon always?
Uh, alright.
Down the drain.
Oh my god, it's these guys.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's five.
Oh, I missed my cast.
Okay, it's five.
Okay, that's five.
God, I hate...
These guys have armor, too.
That's the worst part.
I think the worst part is that it has armor.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Okay, as long as I get rid of these guys...
My clothes!
Oh!
It is so much!
Okay.
Ermi's tab.
Oh, yeah.
My attack's special and cast are faster.
That's good.
I will do chop.
I lost my clothes, guys.
Oh, really?
Oh, come on.
I don't have enough.
Cast, inflicts, freeze, and...
That's good.
Wait.
One or two, chat.
One or two.
One?
For the freeze, right?
All right.
Yeah, the freeze is good.
They're both.
Well, that's the better boons, chat.
Hestia I don't know which one to get I mean freeze is always
good Oh wait Even the faintest
Wheresoever he may please Okay Since you're running staff
Mama Managine Hestia is better Aphrodite is for short range
Okay we'll do Hestia then Oh that's true there's a dual
chance Oh my god okay am I gonna fight a rat Oh no Oh Oh,
no.
Oh, no.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Oh, boss.
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys, he's so fast.
Guys, why is this rat so...
Why is this rat so fast?
Guys, guys, this rat is so OB, guys.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I'm so scared.
I'm actually so scared.
Guys, this rat is so...
fast oh
my god oh my god oh stop oh holy shit it truly was an uh-oh
moment oh thank god oh wait is this dude oh shit dude okay
it was worth it you had abandoned us to be an olympian is
not merely a birth oh my god it was worth it oh please don't
come back uh oh restore your rightful status and join me now
to aid my granddaughter yay oh shit
electric clothes take a hundred percent wait two dude fuck i
don't know um
We get thermodynamic?
Three, right?
Wait, this is Zeus' thing.
Where?
Oh my god, it was technically trio.
Yeah.
Wait, where the fuck did Zeus come from?
I was like, wait a minute, this is Zeus's.
Zeus, like, is in the bag.
He's like, hey, I'm here, too, guys.
I like how, like, Zeus was just here, too.
He's like, I'm also here, guys.
Yeah.
I'm also part of this.
That's funny.
Silence.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Mining.
Oh.
Is this Narcissist?
Man, you just... You are so...
Oh, I know.
You're just so beautiful.
It's so painful.
Whoa.
What's wrong with you?
coming in here like that you don't need me tell me you need
a doctor or healer or something of course I'll skip the
hardware it's narcissists are you telling me to pick the
hammer over narcissists what is wrong with you what
is wrong with you guys is God's gift to the world all right
what is wrong with you guys look at him chat all right one
or three do we want max hp or eels
three yeah he's god's gift to himself three
okay just don't get hit that's so easy yet i can do that
oh my god this is um okay just so like he can hit them god i
hate these guys so much
god i miss freeze
okay that's five
okay I have a hundred dollars but I don't think I I don't
think I have enough money for anything it's on my cast oh
yeah I forgot my freeze is on my cast yeah I might as well
get mana yeah I don't think I can afford anything anyway
alright it's time again it's time to get a four concert
canceled that's right all right skilla will she do the thing
this time surprised to see us again lady because we're not
going anywhere another comeback tour oh nope i thought i
dealt with you last time that's right i will bankrupt your
fans
Oh, I don't know.
Your biggest hater is here again.
He and Roxy to play their hearts out.
No, I'm not.
Because that's just what they do.
Don't you, girls?
Really don't even have, like, an opinion.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even see it.
That's right!
Out of...
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
It's fine.
Okay, we just dodged it and tagged.
Are you serious?
That... Oh, shit!
Okay, this is bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
That still hits me.
No!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's on me.
I fucked up.
there.
It's on me.
Oh no, not her.
It's fine.
Okay.
I just need to get rid of our percussionist.
What?
How did I lose so much HP?
Oh my gosh, she's gonna fucking survive.
No!
Be honest.
The hater, she lives!
No!
Oh, I'm not a fan.
I'm so sad.
The hater has fallen.
No!
They finally got their concert!
No way.
that time I fought past Erebus down into Oceania's it was so
strange being underneath the sea do you remember the sea
Dora yeah do you the sea the sea the sea the sea that's the
thing with all the water in it right heard it's nice
sometimes also kills a bunch of people death by drowning
yeah I've been getting mixed messages I guess yeah drowning
doesn't seem so fun at least I got the fates I got the
message and the huntress the last wheel of the three fates
those reclusive determiners of all that is to come is now
under the princess of the underworld's care with their aid
we may have a chance yeah all right we have some at least we
have some new items we can put I'm glad that every time I'm
here we got new stuff and Elemental, Phenomenes.
Well, okay, we can get both at least.
Within the boons of Mount Olympus, I would see their
elemental essences.
My victory.
Alright.
Yay!
Upgrades!
Okay, we'll grab this, too.
This lets me have, like, an area to fucking heal.
Thank God.
I need it.
Boomed beckoning.
Veseech murder.
Okay, I need...
Oh, I can get this right now.
Nightshade.
Rise, uh...
Cause location to sometimes contain a whale chair on?
Oh!
Okay.
Reactivate in the pathway.
Eventually fall...
Okay, we can grab two of these right now, too.
Back in one piece.
I already have the nightshade shit.
Alright, I just don't have any more plants.
I can oh and I can get like the fate thing because I've been
yeah all right nice yeah I can buy fabric okay I can't get
the other one I realize the other one requires nightshade
too oops where are you Lord Moros so it goes at times
Edmistress what is it that you and Odysseus are planning
he's always with his charts and diagrams why is the forget
me not again and is plotting a course from the nearest
underworld entrance all the way to Olympus oh there's a deal
enemies ranks in case of what I can't go up there oh how do
I use it?
we are awaiting confirmation about that these are made of
possibilities for now distractions even remain focused all
right let's oh i can still get it okay i thought i didn't
have enough i had two okay that's good oh at the right click
oh okay okay i'll use that into the night so moat it be all
right now i can have more wells all right right uh up to the
house of haiti's fell those loyal king struggle to keep
mostly used for communal gifts to the for shades and others
rest Restore it a cat.
Okay, it gets me one nectar.
Oh, I can get rid of boons.
Yeah, I'll get that.
I'll get that.
Fuck some of these boons.
Oh, I have another credit card.
Okay, we'll grab psyche.
Okay, where'd Nemesis go?
Oh, yeah, where did she go?
She actually finally moved away.
In regard to an impediment you may confront when finally you
reach the far end of the morning fields.
Reports suggested some sort of infernal beast.
a big one our shades had to stay very far away i can
corroborate our shades reports and add that this infernal
beast is none other than Cerberus my father's household pet
acting on instinct and pure rage why is he so angry i
thought i fixed him not that way but you know i'm pretty
sure he's not fixed this time and let you pass
of those things but like you know i fixed them the altar of
ashes i can extend it right extend though was the centaur
the center is good right yeah the centaur i don't know do i
need two something new there okay next path will start to
find grants three upgrade okay wait Oh
I'll take I'll take knuckle bones right now.
I don't think I need the death defy thing I mean with arrows
here to fuck me up.
I don't I'm not gonna risk it Silver spade is moon stone axe
good or now
Is moon or moon stone axe
It's pretty slow Oh It's nice, but slow you guys know I
don't like it when it's slow.
I'll get the spade then you're mine I can dig now alright
you guys want me to try the moon you find grants plus three
grants your choice of three or more linked upgrades for your
hex this night I don't know
which one should I try
probably Zeus or Demeter oh moon the next path of stars
grant you it's crazy if you you don't have the moon arcana
okay i'll do the guardian thing again then
oh i wish i could have two oh okay i'm gonna do the i'm
gonna do the rocks Where's the commander?
Yeah, where did he go?
The moon waxes.
I can't yet.
I haven't upgraded to be able to change it.
Okay, it's this moon.
I tried.
I don't have the upgrades for it.
Yeah, everyone's gone.
Where did everyone go?
Hello?
Where did it all go?
I urge you spirits of the crossroads thus Look well upon the
wards about this place I didn't activate centaur Yeah, no
one wants to hang out with me What did I do?
I am out here trying to save the world right now What do you
mean no one wants to hang out with me?
Huh?
I bought somewhere ashes I don't think I can do this No I
needed psychic you no i rather get this over oh i still
don't have enough how much do i need for that i can't wait
what
no use oh my god must be alive i can't activate it yeah it
costs zero one through oh i need three four five okay I need
one, two, three, four, five.
Oh my god, this is fucking stupid.
I'll do a center.
I don't think I need faster.
I've reached my limit.
I don't know.
I'll do speed, actually.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was like a little confused.
Into the dock.
I don't even have a five.
Alright, back.
I gotta go.
Wait, what?
What's this?
Is he going to fit me for a suit of armor?
In the name of Hades, Olympus, I accept this message.
Whoa!
They told me you needed a weapon or something.
You already got one.
Right, lousy one can spot that piece of war workmanship from
here.
Though, I could tune it up.
Oh, what does he offer?
Your special can cost a divination of the elements i cannot
see the essence of olympian boons these incidents in print
only have no bloom somewhere i offer power for you to grow
stronger of your elemental essence when you take damage
shrug off and restore oh oh minus one damage okay your cast
can damn succession of flows in the binding uh your specials
can cause blast That is 500 damage.
Oh, one is good.
Yeah, isn't he supposed to be, like, super ugly?
And then, like, the gods forced a woman to marry him?
Isn't that his lore?
And they're like, Yoki, that is so mean.
I don't write the lore.
Like, I don't write it.
Why are you...
That's...
I...
Don't blame me for how fucked up they were.
wrote it?
That's his lore!
Just like me.
No, apparently it's like super ugly or some shit.
But like super smart.
Oh hey.
The send.
Minus 11?
Is it worth it?
Yeah, and then his wife cheats on him all the time.
Okay.
It wants some of my life essence before letting me in.
All right.
Fine.
Yeah, it's only blood.
It's not that bad.
Oh, it's, oh, it's, um, chaos.
Well, in the name of Hades, Olympus, are you there?
Oh, yeah, I forgot it was Aphrodite.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Bro, that's a fucking baby.
I can't wait.
I'm honored to make your acquaintance.
What sort of quandary would concern the origin of all
existence?
Yeah.
I can't even use that baby.
I can't wait.
But at present, I have inferred that your response, in
essence, was affirmative.
I'll say our newly formed arrangement, fruit posed
interesting.
I can't wait.
my mark and go and later i shall open the abyss for you
again okay
two two or is three i mean nine every one second though or
one three right three is there it sounds very strong yeah
i'll do three this that looks very strong How many counters
was it?
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, next two boons.
Okay, I need to just find boons.
Okay, I just need to...
If I fast-track the boons, it should be fine.
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's just get that out of the way.
Oh, yeah.
Dig a tunnel.
Alright, let's go the meter.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, wait.
Let me kill these guys, and then I can read it.
Whoa.
It's okay.
She can't move anywhere.
That's right.
Got you.
Okay, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you.
I know it's off-topping, but I passed my chem lab by 0.08%.
Thanks for being here.
Doing my long lab write-ups.
Congratulations, Gil!
Congratulations on passing.
I know you can do it.
She must have deemed the risk too great.
I understand.
I'll try to understand.
It's okay, I'm alive at least.
I swear to God, if that was the freeze, I would have been so
fucking mad.
I swear to God.
One or two.
I would have been, I swear to God, this was the freeze.
I swear to fucking God.
Too early is good, yeah.
What's this?
Is there anything good?
I don't have a lot of money.
You know, receive in that amount instead.
Oh, expires after one hit.
Yeah, no.
Your move deals 50% damage.
Six encounters.
Yeah, it's not worth, right?
None of these are worth it.
Yeah.
It's 15 gold?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
It's 15 good.
Yeah, I pass.
I'll save it.
Aphrodite?
Oh, this is hard.
Husband or wife?
Hef?
All right.
And I get my thing, too, here.
I remember that that.
get hit by that.
Oh, there you go.
Alright, that should fix my thing too.
Olympus, I accept this message.
But you primed.
I'm so sad.
I'm... Fuck you, Chaos.
I'm...
I don't have enough money.
I'll go... Oh, wait.
I got it.
Okay.
So...
What was her bonus again?
What did she eat?
Oh, yeah, I used minus 6%.
There you go.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
Fuck this.
I'm new.
I'll kill her first.
Okay.
There you are.
I broke it.
That's just good.
Nice.
I broke the thing.
I broke the curse.
And I still got hit.
The shadows dissipate.
I broke the curse, but I still got hit.
Yeah, but now there's more of us.
Because you guys kept fucking.
I don't understand why it's taking it harder.
There's more of us now.
a trade uh no i'm keeping that your foes perish in a blast
that damages
uh any surrounding foes oh wait that's good yeah too felt
that such deep impenetrable gloom surrounds the underworld
princess that not even her infernal eye can easily discern
what horrors lie therein i want to love this bird through
her shorts oh thank you the super shadow show thank you
thank you glad you've enjoyed my content bro i'll cut
through streams are also just as good the hunt is on yeah
that's right my cousin's here i brought my cousin to the
fight bitch
that's right don't mess with me my cousin's so strong nice
shot
all right don't have enough magic right now oh god bro how
much fucking how many enemies are there there yeah grab this
first and then we can talk I don't know never met my brother
at least he did his part as soon as I told him about you
sure enough he was plenty eager to let all Olympus know
Apollo was very kind say i'm not his twin i thought you
meant my actual brother only the truth that i ran into the
reclusive which of the crossroads while scouting oh no they
have so many siblings i'm doing track everyone's everyone's
sibling you just didn't tell him how long ago that was so
now they really think this long-lost relative of theirs is
going to find chronos and slay him i don't think you don't
stand a chance but they don't have a lot of She calls me
sister.
I don't know one of them calls me sister.
They all blur together.
Damage by my cast.
That's cute.
Wait, that's good.
Oh, wait, that's also good.
Any damage you deal may be critical.
Oh, but 3%.
I don't know.
I feel like this...
Okay, 50 is not that.
good i mean it's three percent though
uh i mean this one is 10 percent
all right i i will go with the higher percentage i feel like
the higher percentage is
uh three comes in clutch for bosses okay we'll do if i mean
we'll look at the bosses then Mining.
Mining.
Alright.
Yeah, three is any.
Yeah, I was thinking about that too.
I was like, well three is any attack, so.
That's like the only thing that's cool about it.
Boop.
Alright, max health.
Oh.
More armor.
Alright, yoink.
Mine now.
Yeah.
I'm back.
I'm back, girl.
I saw you get into a scuffle with the great big witch.
Why are you fighting?
I thought you were on the same side.
I'm in this eternal test that she's giving me.
It's like the SCATs that never ends.
Headmistress and I aren't really fighting.
Well, no, I suppose we are.
Except it isn't born of anger or misunderstanding.
It's just her way of making certain I'm prepared.
Huh.
Well, look.
You show her for me the next chance you get.
you my friend and no pressure so yeah i failed the sat so
many times i have to keep retaking it god damn heckity
okay that makes you restore it whenever you exit location
okay i think i would do emerald dress because i'm gonna do
emerald guys because i don't think i'm gonna cast enough
wait unless T.
I'll never do emerald.
I'll do the boon.
We don't need magic.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of damage.
Alright, nice.
Oh, my god.
That was a lot of fucking damage.
Holy shit.
Cause of blast.
It deals 500 damage.
okay 12 seconds recharge okay when you enter the location oh
my god 20 armor that damage is okay wait two is earth oh my
god wait oh no they're all so good that's so much damage
though you're right damages any surrounding
Yeah, I'm gonna do one.
Very well.
Hammer time.
Stop.
Yay!
Oh.
Alright, what do I get?
Her attack hits two times.
You can channel your special to deal 300% damage.
Oh, shit.
Wait, three.
Should I do...
I think three, right?
Or two, one.
or two but three it has more range
300% on special though
oh one is crazy oh my god I don't know plus add it on top
yeah but it does so it takes so much it channels 30 oh my
god this is so hard i have 40 out of i have 40 magic
stop using your brain
but i could be so far away though
i'm gonna use three i'm gonna use three i like the range
even staldia i'm gonna do it i don't care i'm using three i
do rage more here however my view is you are unprepared for
the surface um that is not true i'm so prepared the airs
fucked me up like three times meaning you won't lift awards
barring the past i literally got the chaos like i got the
chronos in my third try then you'll be more prepared than
you are now till that is not i am i'm so prepared What?
I learned an incantation.
Ow.
Oh.
What?!
Okay, that was bullshit.
This is bullshit.
Alright.
God, not this goddamn Toho.
Jesus Christ.
Stupid Toho!
All right, that's fine.
Not her.
Oh, her.
Oh, I know it's you, girl.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Not again.
No!
Oh, God.
It's fine.
I can live.
I have a tree.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
Me and my tree.
Jesus Christ With the power of the tree Okay, nope Not this
one You
Alright This guy Toho Not you Not you You Found you Peekaboo
tree buff we did it go on melanoi the greatest teacher is
out there that's right i don't need to learn from you no
more i'm so good all right off i go it's so easy all right i
still have the armor right i'm moving i wonder have i even
got a random boom of rarity I don't even know Into the
depths Okay this time This time The ante is back I'll never
give up I'll continue to hate Hating is free And by God I
will continue to do it
That's right
Where's the last guy there you go uh oh more ash can't stop
me holy shit okay that was insane that was a lot of damage
oh my god okay that was my bet i feel like i actually took
that oh do i have enough um i think i do i have enough for
the shop I could get guys, should I get the upgrade or the
shop?
I feel that Palm was shot.
I'll go palm then.
There you go.
Look at this guy in particular.
Oh, shit.
No, I can heal it from here.
Yeah, range!
That's right.
Oh, hey.
Flower.
Oh, shit.
I was like, ooh, flower as the enemy slowly walks up towards
me.
I'm like, ooh, flower.
Oh, 20 shield.
Wait.
Okay, one, two, or three, chat.
Chat build.
One?
Alright.
I grew strong.
Where the fuck?
I feel like Zeus, right?
Zeus is always better.
For the Blitz.
Oh my god, it's him again.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, not him.
Not him.
I don't know why, but he's my kryptonite.
He's so strong.
I get hit.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is about this guy.
Oh, fuck.
I told you.
I don't know what it is about him.
fucking I just keep getting hit by him and just him
there's just something about him guys
there you go he's always come back oh wait what the fuck
okay I was like what did I dig where exactly are you young
lady the outskirts of Poseidon's realm You mean to
circumnavigate your father's domain?
Why confront the armies of Tronus head-on when you could go
around?
Exactly!
He'll never know- expect me!
Why don't we all do that?
A cast-cost lightning.
To repeatedly strike.
Your strike- Oh, wait!
No!
Your strike's aim!
We should get three!
One or three!
Because then there's, like, lightning, too.
There's the lightning strikes that bounces up to four
attacks.
But Prime's 50.
Oh, I don't have magic anymore.
Guys, that takes up all my magic.
Yeah, I'll have zero magic.
Is it worth it?
I have four.
Does two.
Okay, we'll do.
One does a ton of damage.
Okay.
I like the sound of that.
I hear lots of damage and I'm like, I like damage.
That sounds good.
I like lots of damage.
Jesus Christ.
Get nice.
Get in the thunder!
That's right!
Zeus, take you.
Oh, hey, nice.
It's Narcissist again.
You know where I'm going.
Hello.
I'll always pick you.
Why do I always see him?
In fact, why don't you stand a little farther back?
I'm sorry, I know.
My ugliness is making your handsomeness go down.
I'm sorry.
It's my fault.
I know.
I thought I'd take this rather scenic route through this
chamber of yours.
Oh, it isn't my chamber.
I just find the waters here particularly cleanly.
And far fewer would-be suitors than I have seen.
him look even better to take a gift before you go all right
uh oh one boon plus two wait hmm okay one random boon oh i
want more hp yeah i'm ruining i'm sorry i'm i'm ruining his
like his time here all right we love gambling thank you all
right what did i get storm ring the was that oh nice wait
that's what we needed that's actually good that's where the
zeus oh god look at that see oh my god that was actually so
fucking strong what the fuck it literally killed everything
that's crazy there you go okay we're gonna lightning strike
you because fuck this guy in particular
All right, get rid of him.
Wait, you're still alive?
How?
There you go.
A boon.
All right, let's grab the leaf first.
Oh, shit.
I sense the elemental essence is here.
More boons and build.
You have two now.
Wait, but then I can restore magic.
Oh, fuck, this is hard.
Old cast again.
Okay.
I have two right now.
So I feel like...
I just need more Hestia stuff.
Yeah.
I don't need Magic Restore.
I feel like...
Oh my god.
I do need one.
But two is so good.
Two more damage.
You're right.
I don't need Magic if I can do more damage.
Ain't a random item offered from the...
Well, a gain plus two now.
When you would take, receive, okay.
You know what?
It's on the Gamba.
Python skills.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, yay.
Minus 10% damage.
Look at that.
We won and gotcha again.
Oh, shit.
Unseya?
Sure.
Let's see what's here.
Let's check it out.
Okay, let's go.
Put the electricity here too.
all right what is it oh hermes oh shit i have so much money
too ah shopper hermes fuck i have a lot the thing is i do
have a lot of money and this is the last one before i i
didn't have to go shop just because like it's the final one
and i have a lot of money right now i want i might be able
to get like a special like i can definitely get him like
Yeah, I'm gonna do shop.
I have a lot.
Oh, shop at Zeus.
Wait, this is good.
Ah!
Yeah, I've got chaos on me.
Yeah, this is a good shop.
Bye, Zeus.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, yeah, no.
We gotta...
Gotta get the Blitz.
That's good.
Blitz.
Boon.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
That's more Lightning.
Or Attack.
Attack or three.
Okay.
Blitz, right?
Blitz damage 100, though?
There is more Survival?
Yeah, but Prime's 30.
I'll do one.
And then we'll grab them where Ash.
Alright, let's try again.
I don't think it works, guys.
Every time I go in, she's not mad at me.
Okay, now she judges my clothes.
Oh, wait!
Is that the dialogue?
Is that it?
Why is she so mad?
Man, your singing just sucks.
Or else what?
I'll use what tactics I see fit.
Not having to listen to you spout your nonsense makes it
easier to send you back to the depths for the night.
Bro, your music is just not my taste, bro.
You know you like our song.
Can't live without it.
And I will not be silenced.
No matter what you do, I'll always be singing in my head and
yours.
Not my fault.
Look.
I just don't enjoy it.
Some people just stop Okay, I was not expecting all that
damage guys Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine Jesus Christ.
It's fine.
Okay, rhythm gone That's good.
Rhythm, God!
Are you serious?
Oh no.
Okay, it's fine.
Nice.
Gotta get rid of...
Just gotta get rid of her now.
Nice.
Alright, it's featuring time.
Alright, she's the feature artist.
Oh god.
Oh god, I gotta be more careful.
Fuck!
Are you serious?
Oh no, I might lose my tooth.
No, I'm not my tooth, but...
Oh god.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no!
Am I?
No.
It's fine.
Rhythm god, rhythm god.
Nice!
No more basses!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, God.
This is bad for me, though.
No!
Oh!
Oh, that's so close.
That's so close.
I almost got hit.
I almost got hit by the fishes.
Oh!
I just lived.
3 HP in a dream, baby.
3 HP in a fucking dream.
I clutched it.
That's right.
Canceled another tour.
You'll never get the music.
Your fans will never get your music While I'm still alive
I'll make sure to cancel every tour you do
Okay Alright Hello Aris I'm back Hello I'm back Where is
she?
Is that goddamn Oh my god she's gone Oh my god I'm free
Oh my god, this is it.
I'm freed.
Oh my god, I'm fucking freed.
Oh, I can finally see what normal damage is they actually
do.
Oh my god, I didn't think it would be possible.
I didn't think I don't even know what that like okay it's
over oh my god what is that even like okay
more mana okay Zeus again so I'm like so confused I was like
where do they come from
oh my god there you go all right Zeus tab in the name of
Hades okay in each encounter whenever you use held cast use
a random surrounding foe is struck by lighting what uh an
aether font appears in an area and restores all magic when
used all of these are dog shit bows within are struck by
light i don't heal much uh i'm gonna do this just tap it oh
okay thunderous power Okay, yeah, okay, I'll just do that.
Oh, hey!
Hammer!
I'll just tap it then.
Where'd I go?
Excuse me, where are the items?
Okay, there you are.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, it's up here.
I was like, where the fuck is everything?
Are you serious?
Alright.
Okay, that's actually good.
Okay.
Shit.
Nice.
Oh, and there's a chair on too.
I need that.
Oh, your tax rate.
Oh, fuck.
I think faster.
Oh, hammer last.
Oh, whoops, too late.
It's too late.
Oh, fuck.
No echo.
I forgot echo existed.
One or three.
I forgot about it.
It's been so long.
Whoa, you can't say that.
She's my OG.
Power or faster?
Ah.
This is hard.
This is so hard.
Maybe for moms?
One for... Okay, bosses.
I'm thinking about boss fights.
Parts not claimed.
Okay, I need to grab the rewards then.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna think about the bosses first.
They're over here.
You know, fuck you.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's right!
Grab the life.
And then now another flower.
Okay, I gotta kill her first.
Hate the Medusas so much.
Medusas are the most annoying one.
Alright, hey, more HP though.
More HP.
Wait, there's another tree?
Goddammit, it's the Echo.
Restore 37.
Wait, how much?
Okay, oh, I could get HP now.
Uh...
Okay, I'm gonna get HP.
So I can be fully healed.
Uh, alright.
It's okay, guys.
I had more HP.
Wait.
Is this an Echo?
Oh, it is.
Oh.
I was like, wait, I don't remember this area.
Because it's been so long in this area.
I actually forgot what her area looks like.
I was like, this is an Echo.
Oh, look, there's Echo.
Is that you?
That's me.
It's me, alright, Echo.
I don't know how come you've been assisting me, but I'm a
long way from home and could use all the help I can get
going farther I'm going farther going farther All right
All right, we could get the double the palm Because like
it's I think it's palm time I think it's palm What do I get?
Oh shit, nice Oh my god, that shit is so strong too
Nice.
Money, heart, and magic.
Or Demeter.
Guys, I'm worried about Demeter, though.
I think I'll lose a lot of my HP if I fight a boss.
I don't know.
I'm really bad at the mini boss fights.
Demeter?
Are you sure?
Yeah, boss here is hard, isn't it?
Trust the...
Okay, I swear to God, if I lose this run.
My blood is not for you.
I swear to you.
Oh, there it is.
There's my armor.
There we go.
My armor is, guys.
Guys, my armor is now gone.
Guys.
Guys, my armor is gone, guys.
All right, there you go Oh my god, that took up a lot I just
died, you get it back Are you serious?
Okay, what does that replace?
Oh, come on It replaces that Yeah, but it replaces my plus
six Replace is Blitz?
Where's Blitz?
No, I think it replaces this, doesn't it?
Oh, no, it's Blitz.
Oh, okay, thank God.
Freeze is better than Blitz, right?
Or Gus.
Okay.
It depends.
You have three?
I don't hold it enough, though.
I don't hold it enough.
Her boss is Blitzing.
is better?
That might as well get Gus, though.
I don't look at...
Yeah, I don't have mana regen.
Negative two, then.
Blitz is better for boss, right?
Oh, I don't know.
Is freezer Blitz better?
I don't have enough magic for a three, or one or two.
Guys, I don't have a lot of magic.
I have 30 magic.
30 or four.
I don't have regen too.
I don't have regen so I can only use those three times.
This is a lot for damage.
Okay, we'll do this then.
Yeah, we're going to help.
I don't have shit for your shop.
Actually, I could buy heals.
Oh wait, I have 60 now.
Oh, never mind.
I thought I had less.
Um, I could buy heals.
No, Can I afford heals?
I don't remember if I can afford heals.
I don't know.
Moon or heals?
Oh, he might give more armor.
That's true.
He might give more armor.
I'll take that.
And you gain some now.
Oh, shit.
Last effects also inflicted.
glow what's glow oh plus 50 damage oh shit this is all good
two yeah i'll do two my silver okay here we go god server is
just so hard he's so hard but i also have like less he does
okay he might do less damage now but still Oh my god.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Fuck yeah, I'm just gonna use this for now.
Are you serious?
Alright.
I'm just gonna use this for now.
What the fuck are you?
Get out of here!
Oh shit.
Alright, it's fine.
And here we go.
Oh god, no.
No, you don't do this to me.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where is he?
Ah!
It's fine.
Oh god.
Oh my god, where did he go?
Where the fuck?
Oh my god, you bitch.
You're a bad boy!
I don't take it back.
He's a bad boy.
We all know it.
Oh, fuck.
There we go.
Oh, we did it.
Wow, it's like when he's no Ares, it's so much easier.
true form revealed oh watchdog seborrace regards the
underworld princess yeah recognition in his six terrible
eyes okay here we go we did it i did it now calm yourself
yeah but he's gonna get angry again that's the worst part
luke is making him angry all right all right we lived
somehow even the doleful residents of the morning how can
you be mad at that face i don't know what he's trying to
kill me only the most wretched shades reside only the most
wretched serving chronos oh i made it it's chronos time
maybe because i i called him a bad boy after he tried to
kill me all right nice at least i got heals unsealed
unsealed the chamber down we go almost there oh my gosh no
bitch get out of here get out of here get out of here no way
you could have access to this place unless unless i could
like fly come off it babe you're way too stuck in your own
head Go away What happened no Great
No, no, no
Oh, yeah, at least I won't stack to a hundred percent We
seem to have a bit of an infestation here Okay, it's the
little things.
It doesn't stack to a hundred at least.
That's it.
It's the little things guy.
Okay, these guys are annoying, though.
I will admit.
Are you serious?
Okay, nice.
I didn't see the fucking trap.
Oh, hey.
Who's over here?
I forgot who's here.
Oh, it's Saberit.
Hello, Cyprus.
The infernal beast that wrought such terror in the morning
fields now sits there calmly and expectantly.
See, now he's a good boy.
Stay back.
Why doesn't you want me to pet him?
Wait, Hades?
Or to try?
Dad?
It's dad and dad.
That's the Titan Lord, a lack of a decent help.
You... are you... the master of this beast?
The master of this beast?
Well, if I'm to be remembered, I could think of far worse
ways than that.
Though this beast has yet to so much to snarl like you.
Lord Hades, you're my...
Yeah!
Dad!
I'm Melinoe.
I'm your daughter.
That's me.
My daughter.
Melenui.
Yeah.
Why not?
I'm here to save you.
He'll find you and...
Yeah.
I'll beat him up.
He's in the area, is he not?
Don't worry.
I'll beat him up.
He's in my blasted house.
Where you were meant to be and I.
Look at me, daughter.
I cannot confront him on my own.
Yeah, but you're old.
Not me.
You're watched, old man.
Father, let me free you from these bonds.
Watch this.
Never mind, I can't free him.
Now get out of this place.
Then let me lend to you what strength I still possess.
Step back, old man.
I'll save the world.
Yeah, what is he gonna give me?
Oh.
Until you reach the limit when you use to summon three soul
urns around you.
for your rage.
Destroy them to destroy.
And your Kronos summon sphere reinforces.
Okay, wait.
That, I like that.
I think I'm going to get three.
That means I just need to fight Kronos, guys.
Yeah.
I mean, life task is safe, but I feel like three is the long
game.
I'll be back for you.
Don't be a fool.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck their statue.
right watch out if you must that's right i'm angry now all
right let me go there you go that's the ghost that's right i
spoke to my father and he helped me
oh god i'm not the sniper thing
god it's so far i'm trying to trying to like get to it but
oh my god are you serious I didn't see the trap.
The goddamn trap.
That's everything, right?
Oh, Demeter.
Oh, guys, I don't think I'm not going to go to Demeter.
No, I don't think...
Guys, no.
I think it's going to be similar.
Like, no, no, no.
I'm not risking it.
I'm not risking the HP, guys.
I cannot afford to lose HP.
I'm sorry.
I legitimately cannot afford to lose HP.
I need as much HP as possible.
I think it's the auto rats.
I have a feeling.
It's the rats.
I have a feeling it's them.
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
Yeah, it's a trap.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Just don't get hit, Toki.
I guess that is a lot harder than you think, guys.
For some reason, that's very hard to do.
Oh my god, like right now.
Oh god.
Just go for these guys.
Where is it?
One last chamber?
Oh my god, I can't.
I cannot go to the meter, guys.
I can't.
I do not trust myself.
I need as much HP as possible, guys.
I really do.
You don't understand.
I am so desperate for HP.
It's the only way.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
I have a rock slowly moving forward.
Okay.
Here you go.
Pressure point required.
Oh, hey, money.
Okay, but we don't really need...
Oh, forget me, not.
Uh, we don't need that much money.
We already have a lot of money.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
We need this.
uh We'll grab if we grab okay, do we get Zeus or we can only
afford one thing guys the princess's assault on her eternal
foes stronghold The boatman carron brazenly cuts through the
hostile river waters with a variety of smuggled wares at
hand He's definitely the night Zeus or double upgrade
Zeus or double upgrade grade uh guys i didn't realize how
expensive the shop was that was on me okay i will admit that
was on me that was palm and you know what i believe in my
gotcha luck i believe i need this oh my god okay wait this
is good okay guys okay we got double pot okay Okay, guys,
this is also- this is fine.
This is good.
That's good.
Glow!
Yeah, two.
Should have never- Two is good.
Two is good.
It's time.
All right, here we go.
There we go.
We got rid of half his summons, too.
Look, there's only three.
Happens if I pause.
You were telling me to pause.
To throw my fingers before.
Only to return and give to me another opportunity to add you
to my collection.
Oh, I could have got the other pot.
I forgot about it.
Truly get all the wisdom in our family.
I could have bought one more pot, guys.
Just...
Your collection.
I just wanted to fight him so bad.
You don't understand.
The gods ought to put you on display after cutting you to
pieces.
That's right.
Or separate you in pieces.
Like how to get away with murder.
I'm still rather sore about all that.
I truly thought my children would be different.
That they would show their elders some respect.
But they did not.
And my tolerance.
Get with the time zone, man.
The youth is now.
Like here.
Or like in the middle, midder.
Oh, shit.
I'm fucking up there.
My bad.
Oh god.
Oh god, I need to be careful from this guy.
Oh god!
Okay, nice.
I just missed...
Okay.
Oh my...
No, I do not.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna chill here first.
Oh my god, I don't know what I don't know what that is Oh my
god, I don't know what that was
What the fuck
Oh, no, oh no, oh no, oh
Okay, it's fine
Oh, god, oh
god Oh god, where is he?
God there's no time for me to pause my brain is like so
tired oh no oh no oh no it's a second phase
what the same predictable result yet you persist I hate your
goal once more.
Again, our journey's intertwined.
Why did you call upon me, Princess?
I was going to go...
I realized the circle the last second.
Oh.
Lord Moros, I did receive the fainted lift.
I realized I was like, on the other side, I was like, wait,
this is not...
I want you with the circle, the safe place.
i have many questions one thousand three hundred i don't
know whether i can answer them as my own search for truth
has not been that was a good build though not decline your
cordial invitation please lead the way all right we're just
a bait one to take me oh yeah i summoned him i bought him to
come here oh where did he go happen to see a tall horned
fellow passing through oh my my god i saw dad though will
this truly come to pass princess we've not met formally i'm
called morose doom or the official bearer of bad news oh
that's cool why are you why can't you why are you here i
don't need more bad news to invite me to stay for now you're
welcome here and safe lord morose so then you know of my
task to vanquish the usurper of the house of haiti seems
more than a task i regret this burgeon is yours to bear and
much sooner than expected it's all right i was born for this
i was born to kill him god i need like the revival the thing
where i can swatch my swap my fucking shit i need pure
shadow to permeate the surface wards and i have pure shadow
I don't dance past through that location Okay, we're gonna I
can't afford anything apparently I'm fucking Broke Alright
Okay, I need this
At least I get another thing To revive Okay, I need iron,
nectar Okay Cleansing.
Any cattail.
Okay, I'd rather get the cattail here, too.
Can I plant anything?
Oh.
Yeah, I can plant the cattail.
Might as well.
Oh, she's gone.
Oh, the responsibilities of Hecatee, which of the
crossroads?
Oh.
Unseen watcher between realms and keeper of the key to
pathways hidden even to immorality.
Why can't she just find me easier pathways?
That'd be nice.
Oh, I have a gift for you, though.
Hey, though.
Lord Moros, as our honor guest, we wanted you to have this
to make your stay a bit more comfortable.
The nectar of the gods.
Thank you, Princess.
I've not received an offering before.
Though I do like to come prepared.
So here, for me to you.
Oh, he's so tsundere.
He's like, oh my gosh.
I've never got a gift before.
That's cute.
Oh, our new stuff.
Where's Psyche?
I'll have to see how much Kronos still loves his gold after
all this.
The good thing about traitors is their loyalties can be
bought.
All right.
Yay.
Psyche, Tad.
Still added.
They're saying you got all the way to Tartarus, damn right
how far did you get make it all the way back that's right i
did yeah i fought i fought the old man twice at this point
he was waiting within just as expected and was strong just
as expected to okay he he could have been weaker if this if
there was this one girl that didn't fucking show up he could
have been a lot weaker well can't fault you for
Buffed him!
If that hasn't happened already.
Some more buffed this guy.
So, there's a bit of a new wrinkle in our plans.
We've been able to verify some of the details that Master
Hermie suggested to you about what's brewing on the surface.
Please tell me what you may.
And if you think it wise for me to deviate from my objective
to address whatever's going on up there.
on olympus through a channel cut across the land you're
poised to disrupt the enemy ranks from within aid olympus
and your chances against chronos may improve that's not what
i've been doing oh the warded pathway leading up should drop
me right into the heart of our foes forward garrison it
seems so reckless call it a calculated risk all right this
is fire this is fire i should be able to increase my grasp
oh yeah i can all in the mind more grasp What can I get?
And one chance this night to turn any minor fine to be a
major fine.
Such as...
Oh, okay.
That doesn't really matter.
At least two curses from two.
Oh, no.
The boatman?
I guess so.
I guess I can have more money.
Don't have enough just yet.
Okay, I'll get more money.
Oh.
Use more cards.
Oh, I can have more cards.
Oh, yeah.
No use.
I'm at my limit.
No, I can't.
Fucking liars.
Got them liars.
I can't.
I need three.
I don't know.
I need this.
I can't quite grasp this one.
God, this is so good, though.
Ah, I need...
I don't think...
Yeah, I'm not...
I'm not going to risk it.
Do I have enough...
Wait, do I have enough?
Let's see.
Oh, yeah, psyche.
Let's keep buying psyche.
Do I have enough?
how much do i need oh 120 okay i just need to buy it three
more times
good evening broker fair trade never mind i just need 10 oh
my god i need 10 more i need fucking 10 more what the fuck
he chose to just be a die there you keep sake there is this
clear in time for it become doomed and clear okay that don't
think that's gonna happen to me i i don't think let's just
grab let's just rank this one up it ain't happening
practicing as though you still had lives that depended on it
yeah that's not gonna happen within the haunted crossroads
reside shades and spirits of all sorts some resembling their
mortal selves and others rendered down to purest essences
your have you seen commander lord carron's come to visit us
at last our supply lines are secure We're doing it.
It's been quite some time since good Lord Karan visited us
last.
We'd better all be on our best behavior.
Finally visits us instead of me visiting him.
Supply line stuff.
All right, guys.
I need to get some water.
He told me himself.
So we're good.
You guys are going to chill here with Skelly real quick.
I'll be back.
I'm going to get water real quick.
I ran out of water.
Right, I'm back.
I am back.
I will kill the old man.
This is it.
This is the rhyme!
I also peed, so...
Yay!
There you go.
This is it.
This is the rhyme.
Death to Kronos!
Papa, Rice, Mike, and Seven to give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is it!
I know it's on an easy trip or even possible for you right
now heading all the way up here, but just imagine how hard
it is for our family to swallow our bride and ask a raid.
Things are that grim.
Really?
That'd be that bad.
Okay, this is bullshit.
The third one was actually bullshit.
Uh...
I don't know.
It gave me... I collected so many wounds, and all I got was
2.5%.
I'll grab that.
I'll try this.
That's why I was like, that shit was bullshit.
I thought I would get more, you know?
Yeah All right Nice
It's fine All right, let's go We're so good at this game now
This is baby shit Mine Mine Oh, hey Oh, let's go to the head
Actually, oh, Poseidon for the I should have went for the
Gamba That's my bad I forgot about the Gamma.
I don't know how I can fuck that up.
Okay, that was awkward.
It's bad.
Alright, hefty.
So, you're a witch or something I'm to understand?
What do you need me for?
They have that fancy magic of yours and all it's cracked up
to be.
My work, witchy, is reliable.
It was one, right?
One was the really...
Yeah.
If it was near after your dash, you can cause a blast or
deal 200.
Wait.
Or two.
But then this also has, like, the 200 damage in the area.
They're both pretty good.
Also, Captain, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
is exactly what i expected would not recommend watching okay
but is it worse or better than uh than the first movie such
strengths okay the meter that's like that's what i gotta
know is it worse
okay there you go all right nice i just dodged that get
dodge Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
God, I can do this in my sleep.
When Bright Apollo gathered us and announced that his twin
sister was out hunting for our enemies, stumbled upon a
long-lost relative with the Witch of the Crossroads.
Like me.
I was overjoyed and furious at once.
Yeah, that's me.
Oh, God.
Nice.
This is it.
This is the run.
This is the run we have!
Freeze!
Uh, this has steel 35%.
Okay, we're saving money.
Uh, let's get nectar.
There's like people we have to gift that haven't been able
to gift yet.
What's she doing here?
Yeah, wait, what is she doing here?
Wait, friend?
One word of this to Hekken.
I'll go on while I take care of things.
Oh, friend!
This is my task, not yours.
And I'm disappointed with your dereliction of duty.
Let's go!
I'm so desperate to prove you're superior to me.
You know, maybe I am.
So how about this?
Got some gold on your right?
Those wretches ought to swarm in any moment.
Whoever takes more of them gets the others coin.
Oh, wait.
What do you say?
Wait, not friend.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Bro, you cheating!
You're kill stealing!
Bro!
bro he's she's kill stealing she's kill stealing ref ref
that's right bitch that's for kill stealing that's the key
right I'm the winner she's just better you don't know
anything about me thinking being as far from your post in
violation of head
me i'm thinking you don't have what it takes to take the
titan down i do okay to do it why haven't you been doing it
huh because you're weak and you fucking know it you're weak
and you know it oh what did she just what what that what
that was my story wait that was back have you that was that
was my story Wait a minute Wait a minute No shot for me
Well, they're not giving a gift to So are here and covered
in dry brush far as the eye can see well next time you're
there you burn your way on through hear me hot stuff All
right, uh You need more damage to flows that are nowhere
near.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
So, hold cast.
Okay, maybe I can do three.
I don't know.
You've heard Kielsen get ready for stories.
You're like, absolutely.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
One is good.
All right.
The only shot I had was that it's red.
Fine little piece there.
Save for the prickly embrace of the gnarled branches of
those writhing woods That's what I don't like that's the one
thing I don't like it's just that it's
Oh shit whoops that was an accident but I'll take that
Because it's so hard to see the attacks that's the only
thing I have issues with
Like I can't see shit
There you go.
Nice.
Nice, we want the extra HP.
Uh...
Uh, we don't need mana.
More HP is good.
Nice.
Oh, that's not part of it.
Okay, don't worry, I freeze.
Can't do shit, I got freeze!
I got freeze for days!
How did he get here?
That's right, get burned!
Oh hey!
Take time Nice, and then oh, okay, I can do this Hold when
shown
All right Okay, wait It's I don't know why this is so hard
for me
Okay Okay, okay.
I did it.
Okay.
I can read guys.
I can read.
I I did it guys.
I learned how to read guys.
I did it.
I When I created life, I had my doubts.
Would it invite more problems than it solved?
I would be curious to see Thus my experiment continues to
unfold its outcome.
Are you uncertain?
Okay, I understand.
I don't.
Let's go.
One individual achieve.
The quandary.
I saw one of Hades.
I ought to clarify.
I do not care for idle talk.
Ask me no questions.
You put in there's chaos.
Chaos is a long game, guys.
Arachnia loses in three hits.
Game two.
Oh.
Oh, that's...
That's rough.
Wait, this one's rough.
Um, it's good.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Uh, these all fucking suck.
Okay.
Let's try it.
I believe.
I just got a cat special.
I just can't attack.
There, I just gotta do this.
There we go.
I just got...
It's fine.
Oh, shit.
It's so fine, guys.
Don't worry.
It's so fine.
See, I told you.
Okay, more ash.
What's he doing here?
He's just chilling.
Oh, God.
Okay, let's see.
I told you.
you it's it's so bad I fuck that tree fuck that tree in
particular there you see I told you guys it's so we're so
healthy okay there can't touch me that's right oh god oh god
okay you still can't touch me oh god okay it's fine see I I
told you.
I'm so safe.
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
Gotta get close to me to touch me.
Alright.
This is just a special run.
Alright, last encounter.
Oh.
Oh nice.
We need this actually.
Oh, and I have a shot.
Oh.
Is there anything good here?
Anger is offered by Sharon cost 3% less I mean we could do
this oh wait it's the last encounter the boss I fucking oh
is it worth getting this for the shop right now is it worth
getting three for the shop right now Yeah?
I have 455.
455.
Is it worth it?
No?
Okay.
Alright, we'll just...
We'll just go in.
Jesus Christ.
You were able to reach the house of Hades before me, my
lord.
Doubtless why that final stretch was clear.
You must know...
Get to?
Oh.
Well.
guess not trusty carron reached you after all and just in
time to face the gravest threats along your path so may my
blessing bring you victory all right uh
your attacks gain power but you prime wow i wish i could use
my attack
I automatically inflict what?
Yeah, I feel like one, right?
Because it's automatic.
Okay, I feel like volcanic.
I feel like one, right?
One here.
Just because we're going to be spamming five.
Or, uh, one.
Just because I'm spamming that.
Come.
Oh my god.
I want to skip a skipper right now.
I don't want to talk to you anymore.
I miss the armor shit.
That armor shit was so strong.
That armor shit was so strong, man.
I missed that.
Oh no.
This is all I have.
This is so sad.
Alright, that's fine.
I was here.
Whoops.
Fight?
Okay.
Ah, fuck!
Okay, it's no longer fight.
Oh my god, my poor sheep body.
Oh my god.
My poor sheep body.
I'm trying so hard.
You know, fuck you.
Oh my god, are you serious?
It's fine.
My god, I wish I had other attacks.
Must be nice.
There we go.
It's okay, we did it.
We've completed another SAT test.
May they strengthen your craft.
Yay!
We did it.
Okay, now I should have the thing gone.
Is it gone now?
Nice.
What did it even do?
Where did it...
Okay, I fucking don't even know where it imbued it.
He's back.
Oh my god, why are you back?
You, my girl, are meddling in matters you do not understand.
Your father made certain choices.
He was bound by them, but you are not.
Oh, okay.
Oh, so I don't get punished for what my dad did?
Yay!
You brought ruin to the underworld and the surface.
I'll never accept what you've done.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I could have just walked away.
Like, I'm not part of the problem.
How very spirited.
You truly think you can stop time.
Well, then.
I would like to see you try.
Oh, we're free of debt.
Why do I have to take children?
my dad shit it's my dad's fault anyway all right back here
oh my god how many when will they quit your music sucks stop
playing okay that's fucked up oh my god okay I did not
expect that I forgot what it's like to use my other attacks
guys I forgot what it's like it's been so odd I forgot that
I could do like I could left click oh shit wait hammer time
I'll never stop being a I will only stop when they disband.
That's right.
Okay, we're gonna wait here.
Was I hit him?
Can't tell.
There you go.
Nice.
Your special bounce towards up to plus two.
Dealing.
channel your attack steal and also strike sideways oh by the
whole and channel and here's to deal 300 oh wait that's good
should i do that one or two i would be a generational hater
i would hate hurt their kids too one is better one or two
okay one because i like spamming damn right i I do.
I do have...
Do I have enough money?
I do, I think.
Oh, it's chaos.
Okay, I'll buy something.
Oh, I do have enough money.
Oh, I'll do another chaos run.
Let's do...
Am I can afford... I can't afford to.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Um...
I fucked, guys, I fucked up the math.
I messed up the calculations somehow.
It's scorch, right?
Pyro technique?
Or two or three?
I'll do three.
I'll do three, and then we'll go down to chaos.
I think, all right, I do chaos.
God, 18?
Hello, I'm back.
Three, right?
Yeah, but like, I don't use my magic.
I don't...
Yeah, oh, man.
But it's great if I use magic, though.
I just two or three.
I don't know.
We'll do two.
I got this.
Oh my!
We're gonna go to the booth.
Okay.
Ah, shit!
It's okay, guys.
We don't need...
We resisted it.
The mistakes might have been made.
It's okay.
Thank you.
All right, we live for one area.
Okay.
I can speak.
I can still dash.
Got some blasted deals.
I think one.
Yeah.
One seems good.
When you next take damage, revive.
We'll be offered your moves deal.
50.
Okay.
I don't know.
Money or...
We'll do...
Oh wait.
We need this actually.
Carefully now.
Boon time.
More boon.
More power.
I keep calling it boom, because I don't know.
It just sounds better, you know?
I don't know.
I think boom sounds better.
More boon!
I demand more boons!
Yeah.
I fucking hate that move, though.
So annoying.
Okay, nice.
too hot for you there you go freeze your specials can oh my
gosh it's the same thing it's the same thing I think one
excellent more ashes definitely okay we We're five.
Oh!
We're five.
You guys are really fast.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
We have... We have our magic.
I stood in front.
I can't see the paper!
I'm fucking close.
Okay, it's okay.
We're really fast now.
It's okay.
fast now I'm gonna grab HP it's okay we're fast though but
look at how fast we are though guys we're to the stage no no
no we're not gonna run into every projectile look at max
that I'm back the great tactician Odysseus says hello me all
about you you claim you never let anybody get away though i
understand all but now i can run into the attacks easy hey
hey hey hey you don't know that you don't know that we'll
see it when it happens big fish like that just takes a while
to reel in as he might say our song will still be bouncing
around in his pretty little head and now for yours i swear
it'll be different jesus Okay It'll be different you don't
know Okay It's
fine see look how fast I am that world
That's right
Bam Your turn bitch
Boom boom Boom.
Oh my god.
How did I get hit from there?
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, it's just the basis.
It's fine.
Do I stand near here?
Okay, it's fine.
Okay.
Cool.
God, like I said, I, oh, I really, I, I hate the red cast
and just because of that.
Only because of, okay, she's almost dead.
Oh my god, oh my god, okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's
fine.
How did that hit me?
Oh god, that was close.
Okay.
Your turn!
Just you left, girl!
Oh my god, I'm tanking everything.
Oh my god, I never learned.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I did it.
Oh!
I hate when she summons all those little fishies.
It, like, throws me off.
Because the fire?
The fire is so bad with the little fishies, I feel like.
Just not as good.
no zero out of five don't even know how you still have a
career that's right i said it okay nice i need the heals you
don't know why they keep hiring this this wash group
there's no clear path in sight at least she's gone i'm just
happy she's not here anymore Like, oh, fuck, I didn't see
the little shoddy thing.
It's so tiny.
The circle is so tiny.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh, my God, the goddamn roots.
Okay.
Boop.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of the Medusa's at least.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
I might as well grab this, too.
I'm at it.
Fire!
Fire bad!
into the purse I bid you shine for me again tonight yes
Selene I descended into Tartarus and must have seen what
Kronos made of that most Selene I know your confrontation
did not go as you desired but this is a new night and you
are all the more prepared uh rise up then crash down in
Tarka area that's your launches that inflicts more fun up to
what's more
60% then turn into a harmless critter.
Last four seconds.
Oh.
Want curse?
Yeah, but it's like one, right?
Does it work on bosses?
No?
Then what the fuck am I going to use it for?
The fuck am I going to use it for?
All right, we're gonna do one then.
That's bullshit if it doesn't work on bosses.
It's good, though.
Crowd clearing?
Too late.
Or is it even two?
I don't even remember what two was.
I wasted that.
No, I...
Boom!
That's why I don't want to get near these guys.
That's right.
Boom!
Alright, now we got the hammer.
Your attack hits two, but uses plus five.
It has more range.
Five.
Oh, no, we like the range on my special.
One or two?
Good old two?
Or one?
I don't have...
Do I have mana recharge?
I do, right?
I think I do.
I do not.
I do?
Oh, I have Aphrodite.
Oh, I do, yeah.
So I should do this then.
Oh, but I do use this a lot, too.
Okay, we'll do this.
Such secrets in this stuff.
Oh, we don't get...
Oh.
Yeah, I'm not fucking, I don't know, I don't know, guys.
I don't,
I don't know.
What if it's, oh, again?
Is it?
What if it's there again?
Let me post.
Okay, we'll try this.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
No, this was, I regret.
regret.
Oh, fuck you.
No, I regret.
I regret.
I absolutely regret this.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That's a lot of my HP gone, but we did it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, deal damage and remove scorch?
Okay, wait.
Whenever you deal damage...
Whenever you inflict freeze on foe, deal damage and remove
scorch.
Wait, what?
Is it worth that?
That's worth it, right?
Okay.
Oh, shit, nice!
We get Hestia again.
Hello!
Barely made it this far.
please don't tell anyone but i come from arabus all the way
across the outskirts of the underworld i seek the house of
hades to slay the usurp or miss materials that doesn't
matter it's fine i'm just trying to kill i'm just going to
try to kill the the old man as fast as i can all right there
we go get the hastia even knowing you still support me you
still support me
one or two I feel like sprint really?
Sprint maybe?
Really?
Do you think I could do it?
Alright, if I die I swear to God if I die
I swear to God Okay A deep ravine within the fields of
mourning spreads forth like a gash across the underworld's
heart And even hateful spirits know to see it away You need
to keep pushing forward out of here I want to test it out
I'm gonna test this out Okay her means Mourn okay wait okay
I can do it here Okay that's fine it's so slow though That's
the only issue Okay, we'll do the left.
It gives me Zeus and Aphrodite.
Okay, Ash.
Where the fuck is...
Okay, Hermes.
There we go.
I missed it.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
That was awkward.
I missed.
Alright.
I told you guys, Roguelites, I could play this forever.
You channel your cast faster and your cast expires faster.
I don't like that.
Any number gain is worth more.
Receive 100% now plus the bonus.
Your attack special.
Oh, wait.
Nimbo Limbs 3.
I told you guys, I could play this for so long.
I love Roguelites.
Oh shit, nice.
I need that.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I need to remember to use my cast more.
Alright, mining, mining, mining, mining.
Okay, armor.
We need...
Oh, I should have taken that last.
I should have fucking taken that last.
Where's the last one?
Where's the...
Okay, there's that.
Okay, Aphrodite.
Uh...
We'll get Aphrodite.
Okay.
Oh no.
It's fine.
I froze him.
Can't do shit now.
That's right.
Get frozen.
Oh, nope.
Black Spark's coming in.
It's okay.
I don't know where he is, but surely he can't kill me here.
Still have my armor, too.
Oh, shit.
Okay, your blast effects also creates a heartthrob.
That orb is surrounding burst when hit.
Oh, yeah, love handles.
Let's go.
Husband and wife duo.
Can't be that bad.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What is that?
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god.
Get this guy out of here.
Get him out of here.
Okay.
There you go.
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
I never seen him before.
You should be able to get out, I think.
Oh, I'm going to get a shot.
I need HP.
Okay, food.
I need you.
You can cause every blast effects also inflict glow.
Your attacks deal more damage to armor.
Fuck.
It's all good.
All of them are good.
Wait.
Head?
Head fuck?
That gives me good shit.
Yeah.
Oh.
Two or three.
I don't know.
Or one for free boss damage.
Oh.
I'm going to do two.
Just for the glow.
You know what?
I have money.
Let's fuck it.
Alright.
Time to.
Time to see the bad.
dog again god this this guy i'm so bad i don't know why i'm
just so bad at this particular
nope okay
okay are you fucking okay it's okay it's okay boom oh my No!
This fucker.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ!
A fucking quest!
You summoned them!
You leave that dog alone.
Of all the...
Oh my god.
Of all the mobs you want, you summon.
A fucking quest.
A fucking chorus, you summon the most oppressive ones.
Oh my god, I hate that summon the most.
Oh my god, now you fucking run?
Fucker.
Oh, okay, oh, okay.
Now you run away.
I hate you.
Oh god, okay.
It's fine.
It's okay.
We're fine He just He's just having a little tamper tantrum
Because he's a bad boy Oh god It's fine It's having a little
tamper tantrum right now
Okay It's fine Oh my god Oh fucking course that hits me Oh
Oh Oh Oh A flash of recognition passes across the
countenances of the monstrous hound of hell.
How many times did I teach you a lesson?
Be sued.
Why does he keep getting mad?
I don't understand why he keeps getting mad.
Tears.
Oh, tears.
Oh, no, he's crying.
Oh, guys, it wasn't me.
Yo, keeps keeping me.
Good dog.
Back to Kronos.
Again!
Here we go again!
Chronos time!
Oh, I still can't access this, I forgot.
Here goes.
I didn't throw the buff.
Maintenance access.
Please, Ares, please.
Please, Ares, please, please.
No!
Fuck you!
Here to set another curse on me.
Ares.
For all your idiosyncrasies, I never took you for a traitor.
I think Ares is the worst thing they've ever added into this
game.
I don't understand.
Why haven't we like cyberbullied the devs to remove Ares?
By the way, disclaimer, that was a joke, guys.
That was a joke.
Do not cyberbullied the devs to remove Ares.
True.
For legal reasons.
That is a joke.
Okay, gotta go.
This again.
I hate this.
Punishing me just for being good at a video game.
How is this fair?
fair this is not fair you know what fuck it I'm looking
picking this up okay I'm gonna kill this thing first before
anything happens don't get hit just don't get hit dokey it's
just that easy oh I'm
gonna fucking get rid of this one
okay all right that's fine oh my god it is so fine oh my god
oh my god I'm so longer fine it's no longer fine I did not
expect him to charge in here oh my god guys that was no
longer I did not feel fine anymore oh my god this guy is so
take it for no fuck to use it there you go any longer than i
must mining mining mining
hello dad i told you i'll kill him for sure dad i'll do it
this time and i told you i'd be back for you then my
priority is chronos you vanquished him before can you reveal
to me time anything at all yeah any weaknesses i've been
questioned him with the aid of five other gods what hope
have you that's what i'm saying there's like more of us
there's a lot of gods started fucking worrying having kids
so can't we take him down this time what there's like 20 of
us now father how long have you been this way is there what
i can do you think i have any sense of time in such a place
and i've said already what you can do risk not your
everything like what's the point of having all these gods
and you can't take him down
after you take go dark and deal more dirt damage you're in
the to run for for five then this can crawl only after 40
seconds oh wait isn't this good against chronos
it bursts of damage after the first three wait chronos life
reduces oh one is a meme two is
Three is free DPS.
Okay, less HP or...
I feel like this would be better long-term, right?
Yeah.
You'll be avenged.
Oh, yeah, this would be better long-term, yeah.
Oh, I have a gift for you, Dad.
I don't think I gave it you a gift yet.
Father, while I know this wasn't necessarily permitted, I
thought if maybe it would be of any comfort at all, that I
might offer you this nectar.
Exactly like your brother, Blast.
I fear I'm not in any mood or state for such a thing.
Concerning yourself not with my comfort, but with the target
of your wrath.
Alright, yay!
Now what you pet- What?
Just because I call you a bad dog, I'm not allowed to pet
you?
God, so stubborn.
What the fuck did I do?
He started it.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm just gonna kill the ones that are frozen first.
Yeah, I don't...
Oh, I don't trust these guys.
Boom!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Like, I can't see anything.
It's all...
Oh.
I don't know.
Guys, I don't know if it's worth it.
I don't have the HP.
I feel like...
I don't know, guys.
I think I'm fighting...
Uh-oh.
I don't know.
Guys, I don't know if the HP is worth it, guys.
I...
Do it.
I swear to God.
I swear...
Okay.
I swear to God.
what the fuck why do I kill this guy oh my god oh my god oh
my god it's Toho it's Toho oh my god
oh my god this is so hard guys guys what
is HP is forever
Oh my god Wait, does this HB stop?
Oh my Oh my god, please Oh my god, okay, okay, this better
be worth it Oh
Deal more damage, whenever it...
Okay, there you go Plus 15 armor Wait, I get plus 15 armor.
Oh, I don't know.
Do I want armor or free armor or one?
Ah.
Okay.
Long term.
I'm thinking long term here.
Not now.
This is the long term.
Oh my god, that's three boons.
That's three boons, guys.
Guys.
That's three fucking boons Okay There you go Okay, it's fine
I froze him can't do shit
Okay Fine It's
okay as long as I don't take damage it's fine We cannot take
damage, guys.
The moment we take damage is over.
Alright, nice.
Three big boons.
Okay, 150, though.
Deal more damage and inflict freeze?
Okay, wait.
Oh, this is high.
Oh, my God.
Wait, but two, though.
But two.
That's seven.
seconds.
Okay, we're doing two.
Oh, moon.
More moon.
Okay.
This should be fine.
Oh!
Okay, I did not.
There's so many things on my screen, guys.
There is no!
Oh!
Oh my God.
That's unlucky.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I didn't see the fucking clock Okay, there's I did not see
the what the fuck?
What okay
We want bottom I feel like the bottom
I want to do this
Go for blues?
The fuck you mean for blues?
See your end goal?
There you go.
It is decided.
We did it.
Alright.
We're a little fucked though.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
I can't see shit.
I can't see anything
My god, this is the worst part.
This is actually the worst part about having red casting I'm
dead.
I'm not even I'm not even gonna make it Oh my god, oh my
god, and then there's more I can't see shit
What the fuck do you mean?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I hate these guys so much.
Yeah, we're not making it.
I am not okay right now.
I am not okay.
I have all 11 HP and a fucking...
Let's just mind this before I die.
Like, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna mind this before it all comes down.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine, but I'm coping right now.
Oh god.
Okay, it's not okay, but it's okay It's never okay, but it's
okay Oh god, oh god Alright Okay Okay Hello Oh, no, oh, no
heals Okay, I'll just, I'll take Okay, that's okay, I have
40 armor I don't need the heals, it's okay don't need the
heels.
It's okay.
You don't have to give me the sign.
You don't...
What do we get?
You're right.
HEPK is armor.
Maybe he'll give me more armor, guys.
Maybe he'll give me more armor.
Okay, last for...
Okay, you know what?
I like that.
That's... I like that.
Oh, based on my magic limit?
Wait, okay, does that...
Oh, wait, wait.
Okay, two, yeah.
Yeah, I have a lot.
Oh, thank God.
47 HP.
That's better than 11.
That's good.
It's better than 11, guys.
It's a lot better than 11.
Moving against Olympus whilst holding the underworld in his
thrall.
Your weak effects are more potent.
Okay, um...
Your attack's gaining power, but you prime 20.
Bonus power.
Okay, I feel like curse is better, right?
Two?
All right, before we go in, I gotta pee.
I'll be right back.
Back.
Oh, Alan, Medi, right Zechra.
give a super chat thank you thank you okay here we go again
here we go again river take me back into the sand I'm home
welcome back you look a bit unwell you saw your father out
there I presume he required a special arrangement for Fuck
you Incarcerated countless souls within this place.
Fuck you.
This is your fault This is like your fault I could have beat
you ass up if Ares didn't fucking cuck me seven times You
couch it in morality when vengeance is reason enough.
You're so lucky.
She's a bitch Did you take the other no one fucking likes
her.
You're so lucky Because they opposed me Except you have this
rather
You're literally getting carried by Arras.
He was not so fortunate.
You too shall break, however.
Oh no, what did he do to my brother?
God, he's so lucky.
He's literally getting single-handedly carried by.
Okay, how?
By Arras, like, look at this.
Oh my god, wait!
You mean that doesn't stop shit?
Okay.
I did not know that.
I thought it stops.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this minion's face before I do
anything.
I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, I don't know what these are, but I'm gonna get rid of
it just in case.
Okay
I'm gonna get rid of it.
I don't know what it does, but I don't like it
Fuck you God can't like help to do anything Weak ass imagine
getting help.
I would do the same thing though I'm jealous because you
have help
That's right, I'm jealous!
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking close.
Okay.
It's five.
My god, it's not so five.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
It's not.
But, oh my god.
It was not fine, guys.
It was not fine.
Like, I still don't know what this does.
Oh my god, I can't be so good.
No!
Stupid goddamn minions.
Father.
Father?
i you have your orders now return to shadow and take care of
her for all of us oh stupid god that minions my stupid lore
in this because of eris that i can't skip i'm joking i like
the lore i'm i'm just a hater i'm just an eris hater he's
only there so i could like make sure i see this lore Oh,
I play as Hades.
Okay.
Oh, I'm playing as Hades now.
Oh.
Hello?
Nix?
What's going on?
Answer me.
Oh, no.
Oh, she's time stopped.
She got time.
Wait, everybody's time stopped.
Hello, Hades.
Hello?
I don't just walk away.
Like, what the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, time.
There you are, my son.
Oh, son?
Oh, shit.
Granddaddy?
And now you have a family of your own.
How full of life they are, despite the Tao environs.
Oh my god, it's grandpa!
Oh my god, someone beat up my phone.
Fucking sent him to a home after this.
Fuck this guy.
I was not expecting your arrival.
You must forgive us that the house was unprepared for
guests.
To what do we owe the pleasure of your company?
You know, for one thing, I was in the area.
You might recall the time you and Zeus and the rest of you
little brats cut me to ribbons i mean you're a really bad
father so like like we gotta send you to a home like i'm
gonna send him back to the home that was a war you started
and you know it we took no put this man at home but how can
this be i thought that you were gone do you not sound so
disappointed it is i who should be disappointed here not you
You thought I was gone?
I was.
But it turns out spite...
Oh, he's like me.
See, I inherited that.
Blood sacrifices also helped.
What do you intend to do?
And what have you done to the others?
To my family?
Your cries fall on deaf ears.
Fear not, my son.
I have not eaten them or anything.
I have merely set them aside.
They stand imprisoned in a moment that that shall never pass
my qualm is not with them Olympus shall have your head you
can take mine for all I care blast you But don't you dare
harm anybody in my house.
Yeah, why does he does he have like multiple children?
Why the fuck is he like targeting Hades?
You have grown so accustomed to issuing commands that you
forget yourself do have such a command for you tell me
exactly where the fates reside the fates how should i know
but even nix herself knows where her daughters are he's the
eldest damn that's asking me yeah but he has multiple
children that join in why target he's first bro this guy
already bro he lives in hell like he's like he got the worst
out of all the gods he literally and he got bad he didn't
even want to be in hell that was Hades's lore he didn't even
want to be in hell like he's like you're assigned to hell
now and he's like what has my family and the fates
themselves oh Freenos oh he was trapped in oh he was
literally just there he was just there among the other
shades Dora you could join them for some activity out there
it's picked up a lot of late Foolish witch.
Haunting this tent is a full-time obsession.
We lesser shades can be a little single-minded.
I guess kind of like mortals.
Well, that's Disney Hades.
Wasn't there a time where, like, stuff?
I thought it was like the original Hades.
Also, like, was like, he didn't really want it to be there.
The widely hated, feared embodiment of doom goes wherever
the ever-weaving fates decide.
And none but they can anticipate his arrival.
like super chill.
Like everyone else is in Olympus and then Hades was in the
fucking underworld.
My task began immediately following reports that Kronos
found a way to get...
Yeah, he was saying he was cheated into it, but he
doesn't...
Yeah, he doesn't care now.
But like, back then, he was like, what?
His sisters, the three fates.
He got them, didn't he?
Is that why you're here?
Now, I think he just got them.
Yeah, did he got them?
I'm making clear to me that you already know I ought to have
been there when it happened Perhaps the fates knew I lacked
the strength to protect them So they protected me Imagine
losing the gotcha and getting it like getting the underworld
He's like what should we be gods of let's put your names in
the head We'll see it That's fucked It's like whoa Guys,
what are you gonna get?
Let's draw a name from a hat, guys.
Poseidon, you get the C, even though your name was already
related to the C.
You lost the two, three, and got hell.
How did he find them?
What does he want from them?
I don't know how he found them.
Few beings with knowledge of their whereabouts exist.
As to what he wants from them.
Yeah, what does he want with a fate?
Surely he'll try to influence their weavings from here on.
Oh, I'm just like, oops.
A fated list of minor prophecies.
There's a life tax?
Interesting.
Oh my god, thank fucking god.
Finally.
If time cannot be stopped.
Oh my god, fucking finally.
If spill my blood, I must.
I can like swap it.
This is why it's needed.
So, moat it be.
I needed that, actually.
I can finally swap the thing.
Restore where shades and others reacted to dormant.
Halfway leading, eventually fought.
What does it do?
It's turning for a surplus of money.
Okay, we gotta get that.
Wait, what's warded gateways?
What?
I don't know what it actually does.
It does.
Let's grab this real quick.
Grab more cactos.
Oh, he's still asleep.
Will he ever wake up?
Oh, I have enough for this, though.
Yay!
Again, I failed to destroy the Titan, headmistress.
Night after night, he thwarts me, expecting I'll eventually
give in.
but you've no such intent correct you cannot stop him and
neither has he been able to stop you that's right to his
power and he can bro he's literally I swear to God I see her
again in this I swear to fucking God he's literally getting
saved by her every time I would have the fucking most
perfect build and then she will show up.
Okay, let's get Psyche.
Psyche is always good.
Back on your feet again, there, Princess.
I don't even know how many runs I'm in.
I would have fucking killed him, like, seven runs ago.
It's fortunate we have you vigilantly keeping watch here,
Nemesis.
Oh, come on, drop the act.
What happened?
When did you return?
Yeah.
I don't know what you're talking about.
It's not your business, anyway.
Fates help you.
You stole my fucking store.
Bro, everyone here is so mean of me.
Yet they all rely on me to save the world.
Be so arrogant.
Shut up.
Our shades have proved unable to approach the house of
Hades, so they've no reports about the way the Titan fights.
I'm afraid you're on your own for that one, goddess.
Oh, no.
I can give you a report to myself.
He looks rather frail, but he's quick.
His side has significant reach, and he can freeze me at a
moment's notice.
only for so long and his forces are present to ensure i'm
outnumbered yeah i like the 50 cut up the the summons
meaning he tries to stop you using time but can't hold you
for long just as the good witch thought then i it means his
power over you is limited you're the one that can't be
stopped not him i don't have a lot of nectar i don't think i
have enough right now for more nectar i think i can raise my
grass uh yeah we need to raise more grass uh what should we
oh yeah we wanted to grab five so we needed what five and
three or three this is beyond my garage oh my god oh my 19
oh my god oh my oh my oh okay it's fine it's fine it's fine
we can we can go we can grab more psyche from this guy
No weak guys, fucking spin it on, psyche.
I know, I don't need nectar.
I'm short on bones.
I'm gonna get rid of a one.
Yeah, I know.
But all the ones are too good.
I don't know if I can, because all of it is just too good,
you know?
I can't.
Uh, I might as well just...
I'll buy this right now.
And then, actually, I can grab a two.
No, I can't grab anything anyway.
Okay.
I'll just buy What
I should have enough Oh my god Don't tell me it's one two
three four five again Oh wait I have to be surrounding card
Oh my god Oh my fucking Okay it's fine I didn't need it I
didn't read the one I didn't need it anyway guys I I can't
I'm at my limit oh it's fine it's okay I don't need it I
didn't need it guys I mean I can afford this now Zorafet the
moon stone axe you can spit anything apart yeah I don't like
it wait where's the stab I'm just gonna go it at all not a
fan oh i don't know if i i want to grab this but i need to
get rid of i like all the other things i have
yeah i need all the others too let's it i'll grab more later
drop messenger and dash really i don't know i like Messenger
and Dash.
No, I think we're fine.
I think we're fine.
If anything, I wouldn't get the Centaur.
Wait, do I have...
Okay, one, two.
I literally need three.
Like, if I get this, I'll get Centaur, but I feel like these
are too good.
I just need, like, more...
I can grab more...
Uh...
More psyche here.
Once more.
Back at it again.
Oh, I swear to God if Aerist shows up again, I swear to
fucking God that bitch.
I will fucking kill Kronos.
Okay.
I will kill her!
Let's head this way this time.
Alright, uh...
Oh, Prophecy are fulfilled.
I did it.
Try, cast, focus build.
It's super safe.
Ah!
Who told?
Okay.
Never again.
Watch out if Zeus turns into a Zeus.
Thank you for the end.
Thank you for Super Chat.
And a C.
Never again.
Don't fix what isn't broken, guys.
Oh my god, I already lost so much HP.
What?
I heard, like, a bing.
First, you need to...
Oh, shit, sorry, guys.
Maybe I should have fucking read...
Made sure I read the second.
Maybe I should...
I should have got a good cast first.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
A moon drop.
Alright, another moon drop.
Oh, I missed the silver?
I was like confused.
I don't think I need more silver.
But leave the surface to the gods and me.
Do not become distracted by the sealed crossroads gateway
leading up.
Don't go up!
Yeah, tell me what to do.
Oh, shit, wait.
Replenish, restore hex, restores 15 up to three times.
Return turns you impervious, living while her own abilities
were...
Your hex makes everything else move slower.
Wait, this is all so good.
Wait, these are actually really good.
Why don't you want to go up?
I'm going to go up anyway.
As soon as I beat up Kronos.
Yeah, but I need to use 130.
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do this I'm just gonna go for heals I
think heals is the best right now
okay yeah I'm gonna go for okay it's fine yeah we're at the
baby level so everything should be fine I do wait what oh I
do just think uh i oh the meter just for freeze i mean do
have blitz though but maybe freeze for the special still
rooted here i see oh my god hurt oh my god oh this is this
is my worst run oh oh my god what the fuck happened to me oh
my god
What happened to me?
What happened?
I couldn't leave.
I don't know what happened.
Oh my, I couldn't leave.
I got really
tried.
I got grew up.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I was stuck.
I couldn't leave.
I wanted to leave, but she held me down.
Oh my, this is actually the worst threat.
Okay, I have to heal.
No, no, I need a heal.
Oh my god.
Nemesis, what are you doing?
Why are you here?
They'll manage.
I'm on break.
Why are you back?
You'll regret it.
you're unsafe, seeing as I cleared the path for you.
I don't need your aid in this.
Other than the responsibilities you've already been
assigned.
Oh my god.
Come on, girl.
I...
Please!
I don't want to do this contest.
Here's something for your trouble.
Then I suggest you move along.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, oh, thank God.
Okay, I didn't want to go there anyway.
I...
I didn't want to go there.
Oh, shit.
This time.
It
released the right!
Okay, okay.
It's fine.
I don't know why this fucks with me so much.
Okay, there you go.
I don't know why it fucks with me.
I don't know.
Oh, and of course I...
Of course.
There's no heals.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't you, my lord.
About the three fates.
that kronos has your sisters in his thrall lord moros is
safe with us at least oh wait they got him they got him they
got them do
you truly think so let's grab hermes you know it's gotten
hot speaking damage the underworld of late good thing i
happen to know an expert on the subject and so do you i see
all right kid this i don't know your first purchase cost
less than other item peers afterwards your sprint is and
gives you a okay yes i'll grab three and then we'll grab
this i'll grab level two blitz one time steward of the dead
now skulls the rivers of the underworld in aid of those who
yet resist the title let's be an armor i don't think this is
a run we don't have a really good build going
build right now my friend yeah I'm not doing okay Rackney I
don't feel so good
where you recharge your hex don't any 40 outfit that makes
you restore okay we'll get the one with the most armor I
don't fucking care I don't fucking care we need all the
armor we can get right now money or let's do mana i don't
think we need do we need money or mana guys oh hey moon
guys which one's better money or mana
i have plenty of mana all right money
oh my oh my it's okay it only broke a little bit yeah it's
fine Jesus Christ It's okay, only broke a little bit God
There you go, I gotta heal
I still have more
Yay, money Oh, hammer though
This girl This one, I hate these guys The screaming ones are
so annoying.
Alright, we'll send them away.
Oh my god, of course they sent all of them over.
It's fine.
Oh, oh it's fine.
I hate the screaming ones.
They're so annoying.
I hate the screamers.
Oh, I'm gonna go with range.
Fuck it.
Range has always been good to me.
I think range has always been good to me.
Especially when I've blessed too.
But I'd include blessings with grade.
Oh, okay.
Down without restoring.
Oh, but I do get more.
NSD, thank you for the one gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
I should get this, right?
I'm gonna grab it.
It should come in handy.
Oh shit.
Uh, shop.
I don't have the money.
I only have $97.
I only have 97.
I don't have the money funds to do this.
Yeah.
Lately I dreamt a father once again.
When Kronos came for him and you took me to safety.
Except this time, I saw more than before.
T'was no mere dream, of course.
What more did you learn whilst you lingered thus?
Oh, I can- I'm like a witch too.
Kronos demanded father tell him how to learn- I'm like a
prophecy.
I can see prophecies.
Where are they called?
It's here?
And must have found them finally.
I don't know, I've lost count.
Oracle, yeah, an Oracle.
Suppose us.
As though we've nobody to count on, save- ourselves
oh my god oh my god wait what the fuck is this new move okay
that move is new because I'm like what the fuck I've never
seen that one before I'm so confused I was so confused
because I never saw that move before
okay it's so weird We're not having the 200 thing.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to not doing 200 damage right off the bat.
It's just so weird.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't need armor.
Let's go ahead.
We're fine.
We got the system in.
Please.
Oh, shit!
Wow, I almost ran back into it.
I couldn't help.
Okay, it's fine.
I was like, oh, it didn't hit me.
I mean, you guys should run back and let it hit me.
I was just not used to it not hitting me.
You know?
Okay.
Get in here.
Five?
Yeah!
We don't need the armor.
We have the HP.
you have grown physically quite strong but spiritually more
is to be done the altar of ashes there is an incantation
that may make your nightly meditations at it better spend
all right nice the consecration of ashes yeah i'd learn
another spell yippee all right let's go princess stands
alone
I know there was a mining thing here.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Uh, I don't think I need a tooth yet.
I'm going to get to use a tooth on the last boss.
I think we can do...
Hmm.
I mean, she's not that scary.
Uh...
I could try and find, like, a better boon, maybe?
Let's see.
I don't know if I should swap boon.
Try to con- oh, oh yeah, let's do this for now.
You're right We should do that for this area So I'm not
afraid of the guardian for that area I'm- that's things I'm
gonna regret saying for sure I'm gonna regret saying that
he's- they're gonna fuck me up out now
I have a feeling
They're like, yeah!
Okay, that's fine.
You're gonna fucking regret that.
I'm gonna make sure.
Okay, nice.
I think I have range now.
Alright, I got the ashes.
More ash.
I'm stealing this.
Like, it's just a crab.
I'm afraid of you.
Okay, never mind.
We go this way.
We don't need the shadow, whatever it is.
Jesus Christ.
Get out of that shell, bitch.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking...
Okay, it's fine.
Got them stupid.
Got them crabs.
We're okay.
I can use this.
I wonder, too.
Maybe I can forge something.
Oh, yeah.
Mining, mining, mining.
Shield.
I can...
Oh.
Okay.
Uh...
Fuck it.
I accept this message.
The cast inflicts free...
Oh!
Wait, that's good!
Uh, yeah, no, cast freeze.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh, I was just gonna say.
Oh, it doubled.
Wait, what did it...
What?
What doubled?
Oh.
What did it give me?
Oh, it gave me Snow Queen.
Here it goes.
Oh, no.
Oh no, oh no, oh, oh no, oh no,
oh no, he's so fast!
I'm so scared.
He's back.
I don't know what to do.
He's so scary.
I've never been so scared before.
He's.
is the scariest boss fight I've ever had.
The displeasure of fighting.
Oh my God, where is he?
Oh my God, oh my God.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead, he's dead.
Oh, thank God.
He is so scary.
He's actually the scariest boss.
It's just too much stuff on my screen too.
that much is clear it's just it's just like too much screen
clutter i just don't know what to do ah it does not it's not
the 200 thing damage deals more damage based on 20 of your
shield and you gain some now armor gain 75 i'm gonna get
this one oh hey chronos chronos time
hello no no Oh yeah, that's my brother.
He was an interesting subject.
The interval since last we met grows ever longer now.
Chaos time.
Do you know his status?
Is that a gift of chaos yet?
You mean my brother's Agrius?
Kronos took him, along with my parents and their closest
associates.
They're in the lowest reaches of the underworld, where I'm
headed now.
I see.
Time appears to be the source of many problems recently.
As for your brother, I found him to be quite a bit.
using how interesting the offspring can be so dissimilar and
i mean i feel like they're both quite similar uh plus 29
what first time jesus christ okay you take 500 damage okay
each time you you take five damage afterwards oh yeah no one
i i can do that i just don't use my special one one One is
good.
Do I have?
How much nectar do I have?
Alright, that's enough.
One sounds good.
Okay, I just have to do this.
That's fine.
I feel like I'm used to doing that.
Anyway.
Jesus, fucking...
There you go.
Y'all get rid.
That's fine.
Oh, I don't have any more.
It's okay.
I don't need magic.
I don't need it.
Uh, oh.
Grab this.
Look upon me.
What?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I was so confused.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I don't need it.
Guys, I don't need it.
I know I don't need it.
I...
It's fine.
I never needed it.
It's okay.
I don't need it.
I don't know.
I don't know why I struggled it from this, okay?
There's just something about it.
I think it's the reading.
It's...
Look, it's stop reading, okay?
It's my one weakness!
Alright, here you go.
You dash more frequently.
Any gain is worth more.
Oh, okay, we'll grab Nimbo.
I feel like Nimbo is better.
I feel like that's always better.
Alright, tell me.
Oh my god, just it's fine.
I have so much.
much armor it's okay okay nice okay it's just mana we don't
need that oh my god there was a second seal that i didn't
see the other seal i just noticed the seal is it done yet
it's my oh my god okay we don't need it okay I thought there
was only one sealed okay guys I thought it was only one
sealed It's okay everything is fine Go in Look at here
Skilla I've noticed your song I am gonna claw may be
inspired by true events Is trying to drown me not
sufficiently entertaining that I must also be the She wrote
a song about me?
Oh my gosh, she's like Taylor Swift.
It's like how people don't like Taylor Swift now because her
songs, because she's too happy in her relationships.
It's like fucked up.
It's fucked up that she was a better songwriter when she
was, uh, she had, she was more depressed.
Oh, Mickey claims how obsessed will you?
No need to get personally.
detail of my private life with every deranged fan you burges
in here then it wouldn't be a private life would it no oh my
god i accidentally i accidentally pressed pressed it i
pressed the special i couldn't help it like i fought these
guys so many times at that point it was just like reflexes
for me
I was like, well, time to use my favorite move.
All right, got the rhythm, though.
As always.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Five.
Using more range?
Okay, now it's just her.
She just...
I need remember to use range for her too
It's fine Range is good range is good.
Remember All right, she's the feature artist this time
Okay Oh my god, oh my it's fine.
It's fine.
I still have my shield Okay I got all three of them.
Oh, fuck The fucking course
Oh, it's okay There's a lot of stuff going on, but it's okay
Oh no, it's no longer okay, guys It's no longer okay, guys
It's no longer okay I got hit by everything I might have
messed up, guys I Okay, I got her up
Oh no.
Oh god.
There we go.
Lee was a good reveal.
You know what I'm gonna do.
Oh, battle!
Thank you for the rage!
Thank you!
Oh, we had a good stream, battle!
I've been- I've been stuck in the Hades to hell right now.
We have this- Because of this one girl!
This one bitch that keeps ruining my runs bro i've been what
is it called for review i've been review bonding their show
non-stop i am their auntie i will keep review bombing their
concert oh hey that is hammer time
wait i should be able to use this yeah okay i'm should be i
was gonna say i should be able to use this one now Yeah, I
need to remember to use my heal.
I keep forgetting to use it.
I'll use it now here.
Like, I'm...
Oh, never mind.
I don't have enough mana.
Never mind, guys.
Apparently, don't have enough mana for it.
Except for this.
Boop.
Yeah, I'm running low.
It's fine.
Not a chance.
Okay, it's okay.
One more.
Last one.
Hammer time.
Wait, oh my god.
They could have given me an echo.
I forgot to do the hammer last.
So let me see if I can find the other one.
In case I bump into the echo again.
Where is it?
It's like here.
Okay, there we go.
God, not...
these guys again.
Okay, I can freeze them.
My attacks.
There you go.
I really missed the projectiles.
The projectiles were so strong.
Projectile freezes.
Oh, your specials are 25% faster.
Oh, wait, this one.
Mirrored Frasher.
That's what I need.
Special gains a power shot that deals 50%.
fuck it okay oh but then I have a I should don't know which
is better two or three I mean towards the end of my Hades
two runs gets harder but starting to feel like a badass now
let me go thank you the super chat thank you thank you yeah
it just gains 20%
oh once per run oh she's gone now oh okay three for now okay
I'll do three my stuff I think I'm finished here But
there's...
I don't know.
I feel like that's gonna fuck me.
Okay, I'm gonna get that.
I feel like that's gonna fuck me over.
I don't believe in myself, guys.
I have no confidence right now.
Okay.
Grab the extra HP.
Okay, I have 60 left.
cost me less.
Where the fuck are the stuff?
Okay, magic, flower.
Yeah, then I can use moon water.
Yeah, I'm thinking about that.
Oh!
I'm alive.
It's okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Don't worry.
Everything is fine.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I should be able to afford moon water here.
There you go.
Yeah.
Alright, now I should be fine.
Your cast inflicts freeze and repeal deals damage in the
binding circle.
You're like, oh.
Okay, but I could have more shield.
Oh, wait.
All of these are really good, so it's hard.
They're all really good, guys.
Okay.
Ah!
You prime 30, that's true.
I don't have mana- I do have mana recovery with my right
click.
Chill this ass?
Okay, we'll do the cast then.
Freeze!
Shit, there's the moon.
Oh, the moon is not even locked.
Nice.
What do I want?
Hex restores, whenever you use your hex, you gain...
Oh, wait, that's... I like money.
Okay, wait.
Oh, this is hard.
What do you want?
Fortune or...
Restore?
I feel like I rarely use my hex, too.
15 money is nothing.
You're right.
I'll grab that then.
You guys are fucking right.
That's fucking nothing.
No, fuck you, bro.
Fuck the snakes.
Don't fuck the snakes, but fuck the snakes, though.
Oh my god, those stupid goddamn snakes.
Oh my god, you're so lucky the fucking kid is here to
protect you.
Hello, Hestia.
Well, not I.
Stuck with this family already.
see why i'd want another one but i understand the appeal i
suppose plenty of candles and fire to it isn't there okay oh
that gives me so much mana though oh they're both so good oh
no two or three two and three are both good two i can get my
mana back really fast 2 for more regen yeah i could get more
mana but then like the fireball too i need the magic you're
right fired up i need the mana i need to figure out where
the i found it fuck where oh there it is i was gonna say
he's like you found it i'm like i did what the you talking
about is this way
Let's see here A gain plus nine Get a random item Oh wait I
want a random item Fuck it Baint Liquor discovered
What did I discover?
What did it find?
What do you mean?
Where is it?
Bro it's not even in here What did I find?
Oh, I got psyche.
Okay, I was gonna say, what the fuck did I find?
Oh, I have to go through here.
Are you fucking me?
Oh, my God, I'm fucking gonna try.
Okay, let's just get rid of her first.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
I can't.
Oh, I fucking, of course, I'm missing.
That seems like me.
No, I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
I can't be bothered.
Now, that's right.
No, I can't help you now, bitch.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Freeze forever!
There we go.
Wow, that was so strong.
Crude sorcery at best.
Okay, maybe I can get the fireball here.
Your special launches.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get three so I can cast it.
Because it does fire and freeze, right?
Okay, I'm gonna do this.
Oh, hey.
Mining.
Within the vastly sprawled.
Oh I don't know if I have a good run.
I don't really like my build that much I just need like heft
Crazy ass like plus two shit.
I don't know
I'm not sure yet Like I feel like it could obviously be a
lot better, you know That one get rid of her There we go.
Nice.
More HP.
More HP is always good.
God, I always get lost in this area.
What was the other one?
Moonstone and...
Oh, there you go, Quinn.
Yeah, I'll get rid of the Quinn.
God.
Oh my!
Don't!
Oh, he's lost all my shoes!
Oh, it's her!
Oh, it's her.
Oh, oh, not her.
Oh, no.
Okay, this is not fair.
It is actually not fair.
Okay, I'm getting rid of the suck.
Because the suck is doing too much for you.
Oh, fuck you, Quirx.
Get out of here.
There we go.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Okay, money.
Oh, is there anything extra down here?
No.
God, I hate that one.
Okay, there's the moon.
Okay, there's shield here.
That's actually good.
We need the shield.
I am not going to take the shield yet.
I'm going to wait.
Oh, my God, you fucker.
Stop!
Okay, we're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
I just, I do not like the suck.
I am not okay with this.
Okay.
That's fine.
We got the fire going in.
Okay, not this last guy.
All right, and then we'll grab the shield last.
Uh, purity, your hex restores five.
Use plus one hex before using a fountain.
Hex restores plus 50.
Wait.
What's this?
You deal.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's good.
Plus 50 damage?
Fuck yeah.
And then we'll grab this too.
Plus 20.
Boon or money?
Okay, money might have more boons.
I might be able to power up a boon with money.
Yeah, see?
I knew it.
In the name of Hades.
Your special inflicts blitz as well.
Your foe is struck.
Damage from moves activated makes them stronger.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know.
I feel like maybe one?
More blitz?
Yeah, more Blitz, right?
Three?
That requires me to use Cast more.
Really?
Three?
Do I use it enough, guys?
Hmm...
Oh...
I don't know.
I'm gonna go with one.
I feel like I spam it more.
God, it's, God, I'm back, oh, okay, I'm ready, okay, before
I fight him, okay, I'm, that you know, I'm ready, oh, I'm
ready, all right, time to fight the dog, God, this boss
fight, like, pisses me off, I don't know, there's just
something about it, like, I feel like, I told you, he just
pisses me off.
I'm fucking, every time, every fucking time.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I had 50 shields.
What the fuck do you mean?
Okay.
That's fine.
All right, fucking, okay, I resisted it.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I'm like, get resisted.
Oh, my God, you fucking.
A fucking course you sent that one.
Oh, my God, a fucking course.
Oh, there you go.
There we go.
It's God.
Okay, it's five.
Okay.
It's okay.
Okay, I knew he was gonna be here.
Oh my god, I'm only halfway.
I missed the hef.
I have not encountered hef at all.
That's the crazy part.
I missed the 200 damage.
The 500 damage shit was so strong.
That's actually so broken.
I need that.
That's why I think that's why I don't like my build.
I feel like everything is taking so long now.
Oh My god, fuck you
Okay It's five Oh my god, it's totally oh My god, it's it's
five
I don't have Guys, I no longer feel fine.
I'm just saying if I had the fucking plus plus 500 shit,
this would have been so different.
There we go.
Three red and many fenged maws turn now appreciatively
toward the princess of the dead.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Peace has been soothed yet again.
Please, Arras, please, please, please, please, Arras,
please.
Please.
Are you not entertained?
Are you not done messing with me?
Please, please leave.
No one likes you.
Out of the fields at least.
Okay, at least I can swap to the tooth now.
Okay, and water.
All right, before we go, okay.
One last drop.
I know I'm peeing a lot, but I've been hydrating a lot, too.
Not much farther now.
Oh, my God.
She's here, isn't she?
Oh, but there's hope.
Okay, I need to pee.
I'm a victory pee right now.
Like, she's got, she's actually got, oh my God.
here anymore and I'll take you out and next he's echo and
next he they give us super chat thank you thank you oh my
god she's not here she's not here to torment
me it's fine I'm it's okay like I thought you know what I
don't care what happens she's not here oh my god really just
sent 20 snipers like
Okay, it's okay.
That's crazy.
They actually sent 20 snipers here just to kill me.
There you go.
Like, I'm that much of a threat.
Oh my god.
Like, what am I looking at?
Like, Jesus.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Oh, here we go.
I was not expecting 20 fucking snipers.
Okay, it's fine.
There we go.
I'm gonna have Blitz on it.
I have not fucked- Oh my god, it's the rats.
Okay.
It takes me so long to kill them, too.
I think that's the worst part.
Like, I felt so spoiled by the 500 damage shit with my right
click that it feels so slow now to kill things.
I feel like...
I definitely think I killed things a lot faster with that
Hef upgrade.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if I won't.
I don't know.
I don't know if there's anything that Hestia is going to
give me that.
I would want.
Does Hestia give me anything that I actually want, though?
I don't know.
Is there any... I feel like Hestia doesn't have upgrades
that...
Hmm.
There is?
Okay.
If I just really got it, but...
Oh my god, who the fuck is that?
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
I do not like that.
It's taking me so long.
Okay.
Okay, he's stunned.
He's stunned.
Ladies and gentlemen, he's stunned.
Ah, resistant.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, thank god.
okay your special also launches but uses turn you deal more
damage to foes there are nowhere near other foes your foes
perishes in a blast two two for the boss oh two or three
guys
i guess three three for i guess oh i don't know two for boss
right okay two for boss
Mining, mining, mining.
Dad, come over here!
It's you.
When Kronos took our family and the house, and you bade the
witch of the crossroads take me.
I remember it somehow, or dreamt of it.
Yeah, I had a dream.
Demand you tell him of the fates.
How could you possibly learn?
Yeah, I had an oracle.
Out of prophecy, well, not prophecy, like a vision of the
past.
Oh, wait.
Oh, so Kronos doesn't have them yet.
Wait, you never told Kronos how to find the fates.
Wait, did he have?
Does he have them?
He's captured them.
Not long ago, perhaps.
But nonetheless, I'm certain of it.
Does he actually, though?
What?
No.
But if this is true, now that my father's plan for Kronos,
Conquest is much closer to fruition.
Oh, he does have them.
Who the fuck snitched?
Daughter, what chance do you have?
Yeah, but I'm built different.
I'm not like any other gods.
Okay, I feel like it's two.
This is dog shit.
I don't have the other ones.
Uh...
Yeah, I think I should get the two.
Yeah.
No, I lost one, didn't I?
Don't I still...
have i can extract pure shadow i'm pretty sure should be no
shortage of this on the surface okay will he let me pet him
now god damn it when would you let me pet you
yeah so i'm so i only have one uh one left unless you're
talking about like my poof one because i know for sure i i
fucked that up
even realize I thought I have one left that means I've been
gaming I think I've been like always like at the brink of
death for sure I've always I've always been this close this
close to dying
goodness I'll just stay here oh shit I almost got me I
thought I almost got me.
It's okay.
Oh, no, it's not okay.
Oh, shit.
One more rat.
Yeah, I have another one.
That's right.
That's right, rat.
Be gone.
And that's everything.
Moon.
Okay, moon for sure.
Guys, there's so many things happening.
That like I can't pay attention to the bottom bar sometimes
Oh god, I'm scared of those guys for sure Okay, no teleport
no teleport be gone No teleport no teleport get away from me
Okay Okay, these guys I'm afraid of like the big boys The
big boys are scared.
Okay.
There you go.
Moon time!
Okay, uh, wait, where am I?
Okay, I already got these.
Restore is 50.
Restore is 10.
These ones...
Here you go.
X5 should cast with 100% chance to deal.
Also, deal 100...
Oh shit!
Okay, that's good.
I might have one more.
Might as well...
I can't go backwards, so I might as well.
Okay, we have the purple.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Where did it go?
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
It's like, teleports actually, like, where?
Where?
Oh my god, okay, he didn't touch me Okay
Nice Oh my, I'm so in the zone right now That's fucking
right Where are, oh shit, okay, never mind Oh, never mind, I
was like Where are you?
The last guy And the 20 guys showed up I was not ready for
that I thought it would be one guy I was ready for one not
20 okay nice oh fuck okay it's okay okay because like it's
just my armor the only armor okay nice last one oh I have
840 oh Please don't be too expensive.
Okay, more money.
Grab the money here.
Wherever the money is.
Please don't be too expensive.
I'm sunlocking him.
He can't do anything.
There we go.
Oh, there's one more.
Oh, there's multiple.
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, there's another guy.
guy here?
It's okay.
Get frozen.
Oh, fuck.
That's fine.
Oh, I got nothing big boys.
These guys are hell, though.
These guys, I gotta be so careful.
They do so much damage.
They actually can do so much.
Okay.
That should be the last one.
Yay!
Oh, them but oh my god i'm fucking rich thousand dollar
runies oh my god triple food let's go this is a risk i'm
willing to take triple boom oh god okay it's five makes him
go to the frozen stone boy
okay i don't think i'm close to the laser so we should be
good
I do so little damage.
I hate it.
I just do too little damage.
I wish my damage was just a little higher.
That's the worst part.
This is going to take forever for against Kronos.
It's just going to take, like, way too long, I feel like.
You shouldn't have crossed me.
Unless, like, I get, like, the most insane.
upgrades where are you i don't think i need to kill the
laser tower it's just a waste of time
uh your cast inflicts freeze and repeatedly deals damage to
foes in the blinding circle when we attack a special does
damage you how will they cast oh i had a one or three i feel
like three three because the fight the thing is so strong
anyway i'm gonna do a three one scales better what skills
against chronos which would be better against chronos one or
three okay because i'll be chucking that i'll be chucking
that shit on him one all right
Because that thing is going to be on him 24-7.
I mean, I could technically...
I mean, I could technically buy everything.
I have to go with one.
At that point, I'm going with one.
For the damage.
Yeah, no, this final room fucking shops.
Like, it fucking sucks.
Yeah.
It actually fucking sucks.
Like, of all the fucking rooms I get.
Like, I don't need any of this, okay.
Okay, more HP.
I'll just grab the HP.
I guess.
With the grace of the moon.
Alright.
I might as well buy it.
Is that it?
your titan's stolen fortress beckons for the moment
undefended and exposed either because his forces have been
scattered or his certainty of victory complete or perhaps
both all right i mean i don't know arois is not here i don't
know this i don't like my build at all i actually i hate my
build
You are too young to know what it was like.
Before the gods reshape the world to be like this.
Mortals did not have to die in agony and waste away within
this pit.
A simpler age.
Didn't you eat people?
Yeah, I was like, don't you eat?
Aren't you a fucking catapult?
Look, then your own.
You went to war with your own children.
Yeah, we don't talk about it.
That justice yeah, how is that how is that better?
My offspring and my other charges did not always take good
to discipline.
I had too many to look after to take cheek from anyone.
And you my girl.
Bro, that's your fault.
Stop.
Should you have used contraception, bro?
If you don't want to take care of all those kids, that's on
you.
Children for having too much That's on you, bro, you wanted
all those kids You didn't have to take all those kids Oh my
god my shield's God That was bad
Okay Okay Come join us all again Oh my god, not the
goddamn...
Let me drive rid of the fucking mobs first.
There you go.
Just wanna get rid of the mobs!
Mobs are so annoying!
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
Uh-uh.
Okay, it's five.
Oh, never mind.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
That shouldn't have hit me.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, my God.
It hit me so many times.
I'm hitting everything right now.
Oh, I'm so unlucky.
Oh, no, not these guys, though.
These guys are the worst for the spawn.
Oh, no.
I'm trying to get rid of him.
No!
A fucking curse!
No.
Okay
I need to use my My spells more here
Here Oh Oh Okay I
did not blink that entire time I did not blink I need you
guys to know I did not blink during that entire fight Oh Oh
Oh Oh my god
My god, oh my god This is not fair This is actually not
fair.
This is not fair
What what the
okay?
Oh No Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Are you fucking...
You make an enemy of all my legions, not just me.
Oh.
Okay.
I healed.
Oh my god.
Please.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh my god.
I'm like so fucking focused.
I'm...
Please.
I was on.
I'm the thing!
None could resist the ravages of time.
But you, how?
Oh my god, it did it.
Oh, I was so locked in.
Oh, please don't tell me.
No, please don't tell me there's a third phase.
And I'll collect the icka from your veins.
Or whatever flows through them.
Oh.
What is death to the deathless?
A mere nuisance.
Oh my god, did I do it?
Did I do it?
Once I am gone, you shall be cast away.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that!
And I'll slay you again and again and again if I must.
Even if in so doing, it meant that you would never see your
dear old family again.
Because the mercy I have shown to them thus far It's
something I may have to re-evaluate.
Our family.
And what do I care?
I don't even know them.
Because I do know you will be dead here in another moment.
Any last words?
For you, my girl.
A mere reminder.
Having more.
I have this.
Oh my god.
I can't notice this.
Thank fucking god.
Look, look, you see that?
Eris isn't here?
You see that?
Oh, wow!
Eris didn't show up!
And then I win the...
This was the shittiest build I've had thus far.
But because Eris wasn't there, I win.
This was the worst build I had.
But oh, no Eris.
actually oh my god I only want oh my god off oh wait where
do I go wait what do I click this there's like two things
there's a door here
enter the room do I click this or enter the room on there's
like a golden room there
Oh, no.
Click it.
Examine it first?
The remains of time.
Eris bless Kronos this time.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The princess chambers.
Oh, that's my brother's chambers.
Oh, Jesus.
Bro.
That's your cousin.
Bro, that's like...
weird bro and sweet old alabama bro that's your cousin to
the abyss of the subconscious i descend and he's a healthy
boy it's normal a connection step one what appears in it now
step two night and darkness guide me to my blood beyond the
grasp of time Greek so it's okay.
Please.
Brother?
Is my hair getting lighter and my features getting fairer or
did I consume something that really isn't sitting well?
Prince Agrius, please listen to my voice.
Can you hear me?
Sweet home Athens.
Definitely something I consume then.
this is just a dream hypnosis has been growing rather bold
with these is that you and their mate I'm your sister no I
look yes technically this is a dream but it's the only way I
could reach out to you across the span of time now please
our family is in danger and I need your aid all right all
right slow down it's fortunate I rather like such realistic
dreams and what do you mean our family who are you probably
one of mother's many cousins wouldn't explain eyes though or
my father's sigil on your outfit let me speak look this is
going to be difficult for you to accept but I'm millennial
that's right your dad your mom got it on that's right see
that was going to be my next guess well dream sister from a
future time I would never want to snap a wait before hearing
you out so what's the situation what do you want me to do I
want you to grandfather Kronos and destroy him because
there's only so much I can do here myself he's I'm gonna
have to play Cyrus again imprisoned our father mother you
everybody and now he threatens Olympus all his vengeance for
what the gods once did right when you say what the gods once
did you mean the part where they got rid of Kronos
permanently long before I was ever born or you for that
matter but in the not all that distant future he returns and
single-handedly takes over everything yeah Exactly.
If Doki had a gun with two bullets and was in a room with
typhoons, Kronos, and Ares, Doki would shoot Ares twice.
Exactly.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I myself was very little when the titans struck.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to be playing Zagros.
This very moment.
But I cannot stop Kronos on my own.
We need a mod.
I should have downloaded a mod that removed Ares.
This stream would have been like six hours.
Like, like, shorter.
I literally think I could have beat this game in two to
three hours.
If Eris didn't fucking cuck me.
I should have installed a mod that fucking took Eris out.
Also, you look and sound just like a figment of my
imagination would probably look and sound.
Can you prove anything you've said?
You won't forget me when you wake, I promise you.
As for the proof you seek, you must know of Hecatee.
Handmaiden she trained me for this seek her and tell her
what I've said, but no one else
Um sister i'm afraid our mother has no such handmaiden
Although in some strange way you mentioning a name i've
never heard is better proof than anything you've said to me
thus far Oh, what's the matter?
Oh, what happened?
It's chronos i've incapacitated him, but he'll return just
as he will eventually in your own time I need to go.
Before he finds me here, I need to go.
What you just got here?
Look, Malinui, was it?
Will I ever see you again, or was this more of a one-off?
Yeah, will we see each other again?
I found you across dreams and time, brother.
I'll stop at nothing to do it again.
Why don't I just mess with the...
Tad?
Like, I would stop to exist, though.
Right, I can't even tell Hypnos.
I'll suit yourself.
See you another day, sister.
Wouldn't I, like, stop to exist if he succeeded?
Like we're fucking doing going through this paradox of
memory return to shadow now Yeah, but then this version of
her it won't exist though I found him I meant this version
Wait, how come I couldn't examine chronos vanquished and
after that you'd not believe it anyhow Hold on what's going
on with you never seen you so excited in my life death
whatever what did you discover a new species of root
vegetable or something dora i found him chronos and i beat
him withstood every trick he had until he yielded and
expired no do not say that do not do not say i gotta be
chronos and more time don't do this to me he isn't dead i
mean he isn't gone not yet i have to go all right not again
all good we not no not again just like 80s no how far were
you able to go last night princess uh i sensed growing fear
and excitement in the air even heard some of the rumblings
if the rumblings were that i reached the depths of tartarus
broken to my father's stolen house confronted chronos there
and out fought him and you heard correctly don't do this day
The thing is, I could have, I could have been able to beat
up 10 more times if there wasn't that bitch.
By the 8 hour mark, we would have been beating up 10 more
times.
Is this not a vitally important component of the task you've
been interested to complete?
God damn, fuck years.
Well, yes, it is, but...
Then congratulations.
Oh, a thousand.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right.
What do I have?
Oh, moon dust.
I mean, that's good.
Cause, nah, let's grab it.
By light of moon, together, let us shape reality.
I love toxic Yuri, but this isn't it.
a water of ashes beneath which i stand fulfill your purpose
that i know firsthand what else is that everything i think
that's everything i can make right yeah i made so much
already fucking you did it that's me some new shade i think
i did it Oh, hey, wait, I don't remember seeing.
Wait, oh my god.
Hello, guys.
Where did you guys come from?
You're back.
Now, tell me everything.
You found your mark.
What then?
I did it.
I reached the edge of Tartarus and made my way into the
house just as we planned.
Kronos was there on my father's throne.
Yeah, he finally lost.
But I know he isn't gone.
And I was unable to link.
there for long yeah he reconstructed himself i should cut
him to pieces man we were never going to destroy the titan
with brute force alone but soon enough he may yet be undone
entirely provided you have more good tidings to report the
mirror was intact abandoned in the princess chambers and the
incantation worked i found my brother in the past and spoke
to him but had so little time I barely managed to convince
him as to who I am.
Then speak swiftly the next opportunity you get.
Oh my god.
Every time I kill him, I have to, like, tell him how to
fucking kill our grandpa.
As for the Titan.
I should have just like...
I shall study what you found.
I should just write a fucking Gatbro.
I wish he had a camera, man.
I can't...
Why didn't the Greeks back then invented a camera?
I could have wrote everything down.
I'll be like, okay, take a picture of this real quick.
This is how you can kill our grandpa.
Yeah, God damn it!
Zagreus.
You proved beyond a doubt.
You're a god, but you can't even fucking invent a camera.
Put up a QR code, yeah.
And put up a QR code.
Like, invent the worldwide web.
And then link it to, like, a step-by-step YouTube video on
how to kill our grandpa.
If only you had photographic memories, Zagreus, so that I
could just put right at all on a piece of fucking paper.
You're useless, bro.
Oh, Mother Nix, my lord.
I saw her lately in a nightmare or a dream.
She was very beautiful.
Yeah, but why didn't the Greeks just take out their iPhones?
Oh, wait, you're my stepbrother?
I forgot.
I forgot she was my stepbrother.
brother.
You got there.
Had one of my dreams, Nem.
Your mother was there and my father.
He showed concern for her.
She was under the titan's spell.
Wait, oh, no wonder we hate each other.
You're my step-sister, too.
Mother Nix made a mistake in trusting Hades with so much of
the underworld.
This realm was never his by right, not till the fates
decided otherwise.
Mother worked hard.
They were probably just trying to send her help.
you're saying the fates granted my father authority over the
realm of the dead just to give nicks a hand with yeah wasn't
nicks my stepmom that's right huh you caught him didn't you
he killed the bastard for one night at least the first
report I heard I scarce believed but by the third or fourth
I'd come around well done goddess yes it was staggering
stepmom I'd not be surprised if our reports already say he's
returned but i got what i needed for now and a little bit of
payback i suppose yeah so that's my subsister but even
though we're not there yet we needed this i think you needed
this yeah i do i needed this i fucking needed him i needed
him to die after all the errors put me through i mustn't
speak of this lord hypnosis but I was able to descend to the
abyss of the subconscious, and I found my brother there.
Thank you for sparking my fascination with dream.
All that I've worked for.
Last night, it felt in reach.
It's like my little therapy animal.
A finely chiseled countenance of the underworld's unseated
king instills a sense of quiet contemplation and resolve in
whosoever dares to meet those stone unseeing eyes.
all right yeah i'm so happy oh it can't be that's what's
that the oath of the unseen oh it's to make the runs harder
as if my oh my runs weren't fucking me too what unbearable
already okay man i'll need to unlock the full potential of
each of your cards oh what inside does it increase it more
wait what does it do So that's it.
Wait, what?
Enter?
Oh!
What do I even upgrade, I feel like?
What is good?
What would you guys upgrade, chat?
HP?
Which one?
Like, this one?
The Hades one.
Where the fuck is the...
Save for Death Defiance?
Oh, I should.
Yeah, I'll save it.
I'll save it for that.
The Arcana.
I finally understand.
I mean, I can finally grab three.
Wait, fucking, I guess not.
Okay.
Don't think I can do this.
No, I can.
And then I can grab...
this that's fine I got the centaur now I'm okay with that
what do I oh what wait
that's crazy I'll grab that actually okay we'll try and
upgrade the con actually
I feel like Zeus would be the best right
Yeah.
I go to Olympus now?
In shadow I serve.
To shadow I return.
Yeah, no.
No, that's fine.
I don't need to do that.
Full moon flares, bestowing all her grace and power from
beyond an earthly canopy of trees and soaring precipices.
which provide a pristine vantage point how the fuck do i
unlock olympus the crossroads between realms
the moon is full why do i have to do it your eyes do not
deceive near the gateways out of here you'll find none other
than the oath of the unseen i think it's called ask me not
whence it came instead ask just how tough you really are by
three of the fabric go to the cauldron okay i earned of
night do I dare speak the vows and thereby spread the fear
that darkness brings I'm like slosh back on my chair after
that those nocturnal arms you got they probably gonna love
that fear and testament type stuff I say give it a shot much
the worst it could happen all mortal kind condemned to
never-ending torment and I mean mortal kind we're not
mortals we're fine it's gonna be fine yeah see look it's
gonna be fine we're not mortals so it doesn't affect us
Okay, so it's in the cauldron.
Okay, let me check.
Must be an incantation that can help.
Oh, is this?
I don't have shadow gas.
Okay, I need three fabric and 30 ash.
Okay, I have enough of that.
Okay.
One, two, three.
And then 30 ash.
Done.
There you go.
It's...
And then we'll grab...
We need one shadow.
Essence is a shadow.
It's cooking.
Twelve!
Alright, let's go...
Let's go die real quick.
It needs to cook.
What the fuck?
A death-like parra emanates now from the arms of night.
Or one of them at least.
rot thirst to separate immortal souls oh 12 minutes i need
12 rooms okay all right guys let's go let's go in real quick
okay do i need to do this like what what does it give me
like oh like what does it give me in life like what do i get
out of it guys
upgrades for your weapons oh i can upgrade Weapons?
The silver pool.
Oh!
Okay, what do I want?
Any effects or...
Percent more.
Okay, we'll just do fucking...
I'm fine with just doing that.
What's time?
Oh yeah, I know that's easy.
Nine hours?
Or is that nine minutes?
That's nine minutes, isn't it?
I was gonna say.
This I vow.
Is that nine hours?
Or nine minutes?
Okay, now I was gonna say nine hours.
Let's do that.
Okay, it's fine.
Here we go.
Alright, I'm just gonna do like...
No, but guys, I'm literally just gonna...
I'm gonna do this so quick because I just need 12 rooms.
Okay, I accidentally skipped them.
I don't do Sunday rush.
I'm not.
Like, my plan here is to just get to 12 rooms.
Like, I don't care.
Guys, we're just here to get to...
Guys, the mission right now is that we just need to get to,
like, 12...
Guys, help me.
Let me know where I get to 12.
like, I was gonna run at something.
Oh, I forgot to mind that.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
Okay, it's fine.
Someone count.
Oh, it's 12!
Oh my god, it's 12 minutes of play.
I thought it was 12 rooms.
Alright, someone count when we hit 12.
12 minutes of run time.
uh your tax has more range india is 100 i'm gonna do that
fuck it imbued with greatest strengths go in oh my god i'm
getting one guy all right someone tell me when we hit 12
rooms we'll get we'll figure it out eventually
who said 12 minutes i'm fucking looking it up all right bull
All right, you cannot handle it faster.
Your cast deals 20, your sprint.
Can I steal 25% more damage?
That's Q, right?
Wait, Q is good.
Ash.
All right, someone let me know when we're...
You can tell that I'm not like focusing too much on what I'm
picking because this is not the run.
I'm not making this the run, guys.
Okay, get this guy out of here.
Ah, Zeus.
That's...
Oh my god!
Oh!
I forgot about the stun.
I...
I forgot about the stun, guys.
I Was so confused you know I was so confused I was like how
did he do that I
Okay, okay, it's okay It's okay We're fine.
We're okay I forgot the stun existed, but we're okay now
Okay fine we're fine you could tell i'm not paying attention
because i primed my thing but my whole thing is why did i
prime it okay your moves deal oh that's restoring okay let's
just grab this fuck it
uh fuck it more
Because I know I made an oopsie and I forgot.
Oh my god.
This should be the last stun, right?
This has to be the last stun.
Okay, the stun ain't it.
This...
Alright.
I'm at damage days all foes.
You deal more damage because you take damage.
You cast Inflicts.
Daze and deals a burst of damage before they expire.
Yeah, no, we're doing that.
So bright.
This is not the run, guys.
We're just...
Guys, we're gonna hit 12 rooms.
Guys, it's possible.
Oh my god, where did he come from?
Oh my god, it's five.
we made it okay I I need a no is it God now is it God okay
it's God it's God okay I don't even remember oh my god the
run is still going guys what was my chaos boom anyway I
don't even remember what I fucking did what did why did I do
this to myself
okay there you okay okay
Oh, 25% cast.
That's fine.
Your strike in mids.
Okay, we need that.
Okay.
All right, we can do this.
All right.
Okay, there we go.
See, I told you guys I can do this.
Moon.
There you go.
Look at that.
My thing is so strong.
out it's worth it there you go jesus christ that's a lot
okay
easy i have something for you what does she have for me in
the lowest depths that much i knew before your headmistress
confirmed you vanquished him as i had faith you would if his
life Force is like grains of sand then you took one
eventually all
Your hex restore is 12% next makes you rise up and crash
down.
Okay.
Yeah heal time Oh Booner shop, you know a shop fuck it All
right Hermes Hermes time Benefits are more than worth the
asking price.
You got my guarantee.
Okay, your first purchase cost less can dodge, dodge, blah,
fuck.
Being dodged for the more boons you have.
Fucking, okay.
There's like nothing else.
You got nothing else!
The Titan can be slain.
If but to complicate his schemes a little while.
Till we can put a stop to him for good.
Don't worry, we got this.
Shall be restored.
Don't worry, Sheriff.
Descura You spoke the oath of the unseen and would enact
night's testament.
Yeah, Hermes is like all your dog shit or it actually good
There's no in between much of it.
There's no like average A healthy fear no more no less said
mistress.
I'm honored that you granted me the right to take the oath
Assuming it was you're doing rather than commander's get a
me is Where my brain is so fucking fried That Kronos fight
actually took up all my brain power.
I'm like, I'm like, where am I?
So, I'm like, Is this you?
Yeah.
Like, I'm okay if we don't beat this.
I'm okay.
It's okay, I understand if we don't.
Oh my god.
Healed.
Come on.
Okay, it is...
Not again.
Please.
I'm just a little guy.
Oh god.
Okay.
We're five.
All right, nice.
my build is actually surprisingly very strong i was not
expecting that i i was i actually was not expecting a decent
build like i have been like bullshitting this build
like the damage is surprisingly insane of the nocturnal arms
is a terrible responsibility i've been auto piloting my
build for this one I'll deepen your understanding.
The aspects of night and darkness.
Oh, nice.
Got another incantation.
Yay!
Okay, the worst part is I'm timed, though.
So, like, I'm not feeling so good about this.
Because of the fact that I'm tied.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm timed right now, please.
the bones I'll get the boon which rock did you crawl out
from under my forces they are terribly confused they have no
idea where you live so I thought I would attempt asking you
nicely here that's right I'll never tell that's why I won't
I could put you in a home, Granddad!
However long it takes.
You speak of inevitability, little one.
A subject on which I happen to be the expert.
As to whomever sent you after me, I shall find them.
Oh shit.
Okay, we gotta get Regent.
If we're actually doing this build, we need Regent real bad.
Okay, nice.
I mean, that's the hard part.
We don't have like mana regen for this build.
And that's like the only thing that would make our build
like really strong.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Oh my god, I literally just need regen.
That's it.
All right, nice.
Nectar.
Oh,
my God.
What am I looking at?
Oh, my.
I mean, it's a lot of damage, though.
But still, what the fuck?
Be not afraid.
All right.
There you go.
Oh my- Actually, my brain has to go on overtime for that.
I have to go overtime.
Uh, moon or cha- I don't have money.
I'm fucking broke.
No, I need mana regen really badly.
Like, for this build to work, I need to figure- I need to
find something that can regen my mana.
Yeah, collect reward.
What the fuck is this path?
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, let's just grab this real quick.
Gain plus 8 now.
Enter Chaos Gate.
It costs $0 to enter.
I have to restore 50% of your...
Oh my god.
Do I...
Fuck.
Do I want another Chaos Gate?
What do I get here?
Let's get health.
Fuck it.
Oh, I should have got mana.
Oh, I should have got mana on.
Oopsie.
Maybe I should have got mana.
Okay, it's fine.
That's okay.
Maybe health would be good for me.
Who knows?
Oh My god, fucking of course you're here get out of here
Okay Hef or hef Oh You again, no
Where is he?
Oh Where's the rat?
Oh my god, where is he?
Oh my god god it's no use okay oh my god one fear one fear
actually my one fear
okay you can't get me i'm like right here you can't get me
i'm so far
holy he's so strong he's my one fear in this game
Oh, fucking strong.
Okay, my build is not strong against the rats.
I know that for sure.
My build is really weak against this cat.
Okay, there we go.
Holy shit.
I hate, I hate fighting him so much.
Are you?
You might understand you gave a certain tightener right for
a walloping of let.
May have I helped in my own way?
Not like you took down Kronos with your baby.
That's fucking sad.
Alright, your task can cause a blast that deals.
That's good.
Okay, yeah, you need that.
It's hard to be a rodent.
Alright, down we go.
Oh no, there's another coroner.
Oh my god.
How did you get here?
makes you mad i know don't hold back let's see how strong
you really are oh no i don't want to fight you nemesis i
don't do oh not another it's okay i have thunder my thunder
is so strong now asking you to hit me see if you can even
make me budge it'll be worth your while let me have it where
are they oh oh my god didn't realize i had to attack I was
like, where are they?
I was like, where are they?
Where's the monster I'm supposed to fight?
Look, I got confused, okay?
I got confused of this.
The end of the path.
All right, down I'll go.
By the will of chaos.
We're speed running.
Oh, she stopped talking to me.
That's fine.
120 seconds.
I swear to God.
Oh, my God.
It's gone.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm going with...
I'm not...
Guys, I cannot do this.
I think the next two rooms are boss rooms, guys.
I think...
Guys, the next two rooms, I'm pretty sure are boss rooms.
There's no way I am not defeating the boss room in 120
seconds It would be funny
No, we need the mana We need
I swear to God I swear I swear to God I swear to God I don't
believe I don't believe I know I don't I don't believe I
have no belief in us Recycling Oh yeah look at that It was a
boss room I fucking knew it I fucking knew it I fucking knew
it I was talking mostly wondering what is your deal yeah
what is your deal ruining our concert I am indeed an agent
of night I fucking knew it recycling was super chat they
could thank you restore to its rightful rule no matter I
can't believe it yet you were right an agent on the hunt
well your search is over agent lady because you won't find a
bigger talent in the sea or out just watch okay I thought
knew it I was like oh my god I'm like so out of oh my god
I'm not okay right now you know the way I'm saying right now
like it's not looking good okay like what's hitting me what
the fuck is hitting me me okay
I don't know what's hitting me but fuck it oh my god it's
the cast it's the cast I forgot about the fucking cast guys
I actually I forgot about it I picked it and I forgot about
it.
Literally, that was the only thing that was damaging me.
That's the worst part.
I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck is hitting me?
I don't understand.
What could it be?
Oh, I'm not okay anymore.
Oh, it's okay.
Deaths of Fines, guys.
Okay, there you go.
She's down.
Oh my god.
This is bad.
This is actually so bad.
I wish I had cast.
Because cast would actually be so good right now.
There we go.
We don't need moon water.
A bit too close.
Oh yeah, no, that was a bit too close.
But we don't even know.
I don't even have moon water, guys.
It says zero.
It said zero, guys.
I couldn't even use moon water if I wanted to.
Okay, how much HP do I have?
I might as well go.
Yeah, let's grab the HP.
What do I have?
Grab that for the next boss fight.
Long way down.
That was under two minutes.
minutes without cast.
I'm still not... I was not fucking risking it.
How much more do I have for...
Oh my god.
I gotta find the goddamn entrance.
I still forgot about that guy.
Fuck it.
Wait guys, how many more do I need?
How many rooms was the casting?
Oh my god, almost the cast.
I can't...
Oh wait, I'll grab this.
Oh my god, he wasn't even prior to this.
Four more rooms?
Okay, I just gotta remember.
God, not being able to do cast is so fucking...
Oh, it's so frustrating.
I'm so used to using it.
Damn it.
Oh my god, he does so much.
Are you fucking okay?
It's okay.
I'll heal It's okay It's been so long love why I felt a
little thrill of fright but then a little birdie told me
you'd gone far down in those steps Even to some success.
I'll be excited to hear all the joy.
Yeah, I did all that my brain is so fried now But I did I
did Heart throb attacking is power but you prime okay we
can't get that we cast inflict weak okay i can't cast yet
but two right i feel like two i use magic a lot
attack deals 50 oh wait no faster
yeah no faster more dps damage per second oh my god almost
Mine, mine, mine.
Okay, nice.
Got the money too.
Then we'll grab the ash.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I didn't even see the second option.
I'll never know.
I'll never know what was over there.
I'm so sad.
I just auto- I was like, that's one tree!
Yeah, nice.
Look, I thought I saw one tree, okay?
Okay, nice.
No, this build is actually crazy.
Like, it's just so much DPS in general.
Is anyone ever- okay, it's how I gain magic anymore?
As expected.
Okay, your cast inflicts your attack a chance to hit two
times.
No deal.
You deal more damage than you take damage.
You take no more for 15 seconds.
Regain this.
Oh, wait.
You cast.
I think it's chance to hit two times.
Yeah, we do Gamba.
Gamba's always good.
Nice.
all right go up
and nice
are you fucking oh my god how did he hit me oh my god it's
the thorns he didn't hit me oh oh I was like how did he do
it and it was just the thorns I just ran into the thorns
that's how it's always just the thorns oh my god please get
out away from me my chaos spoon just then oh my god that's
it i'm freed
press and hold or cast and build them with oh any money you
oh my god they're all fucking trash bro they're all all
right what to speed more damage more speed it's all trash
anyway I can't.
Oh my god.
I...
No.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It was okay.
Hello.
It's Echo, Echo, Echo.
Aww, I'm fucking with her now.
You're not speaking in the customary way of mountain nymphs.
Some sort of curse.
Sort of curse.
All right.
Oh, okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
You gave me the worst ones.
Gain no extra.
Gain another at...
Ah, fuck it.
Just give me a random boon.
I'll go with this.
Oh, wait.
No, that's good.
Cardio.
Wait, one.
Yeah.
Magic.
Let's go.
Okay.
All in on magic.
Aphrodite, moon, and boon.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, moon.
Alright, I should be able to cast now.
Yeah, there you go.
Thank god.
Like, thank fucking god.
Like, I actually just needed this.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Okay.
That's right!
I'll go so fast now!
So much DPS now!
Alright, moon.
Get here.
I almost there at the purple.
I'm not even reading that shit.
God, where do I go?
That fragility.
Get him out of here.
Oh my god, there's so many wolves.
cast cast there's so many oh accidentally healed that's not
what I was okay it's fine it's fine it's fine everything is
fine it's fine look at all that magic though I'm unstoppable
name of Hades alright give me a chance to dodge for each you
have I have four you need more damage while you have at
least okay your special steal more damage to nearby Oh, I
don't know.
I just want to dodge.
Fuck it.
One more.
Can't hit me.
Alright, dig.
Where the fuck are the others?
Alright, boon.
Alright, get rid of the snakes first.
Alright.
Can't do shit now.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of...
Okay, this is actually...
This is a really crazy build that accidentally did.
Your attacks can cause a...
Oh, I don't know.
One or two, chat.
One?
Yeah, one.
Where the fuck are you?
He's been waiting for so long.
This guy was waiting for me.
I was like, what the fuck?
A golden bow.
God, I need that.
Okay, nice.
Okay, the last one is down here.
Alright, we gotta go.
We gotta book it.
Boon shop money.
How much money do I have?
Okay, it's worth it.
300.
Oh hey, it's that.
Okay.
Beyond awaits the monstrous hound.
Okay, this is a city shot, but that's fine.
No longer watchful of the underworld's gates, but now grown
desperate to return to his grid master, wherever he resides.
Wait, this is fine.
Hear me on my authority.
Oh, all right.
Rushing your tax king power, but you prime 20.
Gain, and now for the rest of this night.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Girl, I'm not buying the ash.
I don't care.
This is the run where I either die or like everything will
be fine.
This is the run.
I either make it or break it.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh, God.
Fucking of course that hits me.
Okay, it's fine.
I have heals.
Oh, yeah, fucking course.
Oh, and then he goes high like a pussy.
Okay, it's five.
We're so fast.
Our attacks are so goddamn fast.
We're unstoppable.
I just gotta make sure he doesn't fucking hit me there.
Where is he going?
Okay.
Holy fuck, I do so much damage.
It's actually insane how much damage I'm doing to him.
Like, if I have the HEP thing for this, I think this would
have been, like, the craziest, the fastest fucking run ever.
Oh, fucking crazy.
Or, like, the fire thing.
I think if I had the fire blast from Hesia, I think that
would also be crazy.
I think the fire blast would actually go so far Where the
fuck did he go?
Jesus fire is fine Yeah No, I think it'd be like the fire
blast with my cast I think it'd be really strong with that
The hound of hell is ended for the while
Yay, be sued Now be at peace.
No, this literally build is so fucking fast.
This is it.
Okay, this is it.
Surely it won't take me 20 years to kill Kronos.
Surely, right?
Alright, let's grab the teeth.
In water.
It costs zero dollar center.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm willing.
I don't know about chaos.
You have to fuck it.
Let's go.
What will chaos give me this time?
The lowest reaches.
It worked.
All right.
What will chaos give me?
We bid you a warm welcome to the depths of Tatras.
That was awkward.
I forgot about the trap, guys.
All right.
I forgot about it again.
There's so many things on my screen, okay?
It's not my fault.
There's so many things on my screen.
I forgot about it, okay?
Guys, it's been nine hours.
Oh, yeah, I'm fine with not earning money.
Wait, I'd like that.
Wait, actually, fuck.
that yeah no who needs money all right hey dad such a
cacophony occurred after you last visited exactly when i
cannot say all of the titans wretched servants flew into a
panic their cries would not cease what transpired perhaps
they were concerned for their master all busy trying to
bring him back to life because I slew him finally I did it
and it won't be the last time I killed him once it's fine
yeah I could have had four death defiance which once took
half the blasted strength of Olympus all on you not on my
own at all I had their strength if not their support as
you've given me yours father we can stop him Yeah, we can do
it, Dad.
We can kill him.
That would be so easy.
He shall seek vengeance with a renewed zeal.
This entire plot of his is driven by the same imbrose.
Then kill him if you must.
At least his many deaths.
Nine more times.
Yeah.
Okay, here you go.
150.
Ah, one, three, one, or three.
Three, right?
But then the dash has been really helpful, too.
I'll do three, just so I don't have to deal with.
Yeah, I'll do three for that.
Yeah, fuck the eyeglasses.
No, you're right.
You're right.
Okay, take care of him, okay?
Okay, fuck you.
I'm like, servers, take care of him.
He's like, no!
Oh my god, I gotta make sure I don't fucking...
I wish I had the...
Oh my god.
I really want the...
The one where I could chuck my thing.
Because I think that would be...
That would make the build so strong.
If I could just chuck it.
Okay.
There you go.
Do I risk straying from the shortest route?
Yes!
Oh, great.
Oh, no.
Wait, maybe not.
Wait, wait a minute.
I don't...
Now I'm not too sure anymore.
Now...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
oh my god it's it's fine you don't understand there's so
many things on my screen it's very hard to see guys it's
very hard to see okay there you go who needs gold anyway in
the name of haiti's all right your cast inflict days you
deal more damage until you take damage your cast expands in
size until they expire Wait.
Oh, they're all so good!
Cast inflict days and deals a burst of damage before they
expire?
Or...
Uh...
Or three.
Well, my cast is my cue, right?
One, yeah.
Yeah, I do need it.
I do, I admit.
No, I definitely need it.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I wish I had the freeze for this, though.
It would have been so good.
If this had a freeze, this actually would have been so OP.
Yeah, destroy that.
Bam!
Dead.
three boons oh my god 200 okay yeah 200 200 damage man yeah
i'm gonna do 200.
oh i still i really wish i had the what what hit me oh my
god i don't know what's hitting me guys i don't know what's
hitting me i literally don't know
Okay, I had to use heals there.
I couldn't tell what was hitting me
That chaos curse of mine is finally gone.
Okay, I can finally earn money I didn't even know what was
hitting me there
Okay Jesus Christ oh my god, wait, I hate this.
I hate this I can't see anything.
Okay.
Like, I don't, I can't see shit!
Jesus Christ.
I hate you.
I need a heal.
Oh no, I don't have heals anymore.
This is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
Oh, fuck.
I need all those.
I need the one heal that I have.
I just gotta pray.
Okay, that's fine.
This is my father's realm.
Poppy flower seeds.
Was that all the room?
Okay, this is the last room.
I only have one heal left, too.
Oh, please tell me.
I wish I have freeze for my cast though.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah, that's the only bad thing about this is that it's so
overwhelming.
Yeah, it's so overwhelming when you don't have...
Oh my god, it really is.
It's really bad.
When there's no CCs for this.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright, nice.
time okay we need the money we need the money money time
hello okay i can stun these guys stun that's right i can't
do shit now okay there you go stun that's the only thing i
can't do i just gotta stun them in my little fucking corner
There you go.
Okay, now I don't know what to do.
Now I'm out of ideas.
I can't send them here.
It's so hard.
What do I do?
I ran out of ideas.
That was the only thing I knew how I was to do.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I got the money.
I don't know if I have to use my final okay Let's pray that
this is our boon Let's pray that seals What the fuck is this
Guys Is that another death defiance?
Oh my god is this a death defiance
Oh my god another death defiance Okay
500 and wait 500 Okay we can get these two Olympus, I accept
this message.
I was like, math.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Well, you have...
Oh, dice.
Oh, my God.
Damage recovered.
Your specials deal more damage.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
One?
Really?
But self-healing?
Is it really better?
What am I replacing over that?
Is it really better than three?
You have a million depth defiance.
Is this really better than my current one?
My current one is volcanic.
Okay, one is good.
Okay.
All right, we'll do one then.
Alright.
What is this?
He's suggesting an exchange.
Okay, yeah, we don't need that.
We're not doing that.
Oh, wait, electric overload.
Right?
Two?
I am not doing another exchange!
I'm not doing it.
Here we go.
I don't even know how many depth defiances I have.
I think I have three, right?
I've had...
I have three now.
Cowards.
Your eyes do not deceive.
I'm as hailed and hearty as can be.
I'm doing my nine to five right now in Hades.
I told you guys, I love roguelikes.
You now know it to be true.
I was never going to destroy you in a single clash.
You more than anybody ought to know results of any worth
take time.
I wish I had the chucking cast though.
That one was so strong.
the end fine for my part I occasionally need to stretch my
limbs all right here we go again here we go again I
gotta get rid of him first too Jesus Christ at least I can
okay
oh my god I didn't even realize that was a thing
We were fucking minions out first.
There we go.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Okay, I didn't see that.
It's so annoying, though.
If I had...
I wish I had the...
The cast.
I think it would be so strong.
Where is he?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Oh my god.
God, fuck you!
Oh my god, I hate your minions!
There you go.
There
you go.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Oh!
Seven, you possess some of your father's strength.
Or rather, mine.
clutch oh this one is hard though like see i can't do that i
think if i could i wish i could do that like the what was it
called the passing was so clutch during this moment right
here that's why i wish i had it oh
my god jesus christ are you fucking oh my god that's so
bullshit
oh my god okay okay that's fine
Okay.
Are you serious?
Take this!
Oh my god!
I can't believe that was the run!
I was like, bro, I'm just gonna go in there, get 12 rooms,
and then be over.
I- We're still 11 minutes to spare.
Oh my god.
Bro, I had three death defiances.
I was rich.
I still had two more.
I saw I was gonna just take it.
I knew I had a lot of oh my god.
I can't I was not trying to do another run Look at that Ares
The gutted grand hall of the former house of Hades eerily
lies still 12 minutes is quick in and out adventure The dark
princess pursues an object that may be the key to her
predicament I don't remember this princess chamber still
he's gone for now all right back to laura the chambers down
the hall laura again just as it was the chambers of the
missing underworld prince lie in a perpetual state the
moment she left it got so easy of time but otherwise
untouched for who would dare just as we surmise that was so
much damage that was crazy of the subconscious i descend
that's actually crazy that was So I don't even know how I
fucking got that much damage going in literally was
autopiling fixed.
I was like And I was like wait a minute.
That's a lot of damage I was like wait, wait
Hey, I'm back Just as I remember
everything just as you said particularly since you're here
again so soon Where were we?
I was trying to persuade you to take me at my word that I'm
your sister from a future time in which the Titan Kronos has
usurped the house of Hades I mean to stop him okay I don't
have much time I don't need exposition dump him I have a
wide end the designated security specialist around here so
perhaps I know the answer to that one some security
specialist Kronos caught the house entirely off guard but
you're my closest kin you've subverted the will of the fates
before and slain gods if not Titans I also lack the means of
reaching anybody else this way.
Yeah, you're the only one I can talk to, brother.
I feel that strong kinship between us already.
Next question.
Where even is this Kronos, and what would you have me do if
and when I locate him?
Let's kill him, chop him.
I don't know where Kronos is exactly in your time, though I
do have a lead.
His remains were scattered to the deepest pits of Tartarus,
which means he's probably recovering below where you reside.
As for what to do if you can locate him, we'll get to that
um i hate to break it to you melina we but this isn't all
that comprehensive a plan especially for something you've
been planning all your life do i just wait for you to work
through the details or yeah this is a shitty plan like did i
not come prepared your security specialist begin an
investigation though in absolute secrecy what the is it like
you do all the work like do i not have a plan you betrayed
this for your whole life I was like, okay, now, brother, now
that I got here, it's your turn to figure this out.
What's left of them, yes.
I can only reach you like this while we're in the same
location across time.
My plan is literally was like, go find him and then have him
deal with the rest.
Yeah, I never thought I'd get this far, guys.
Then don't wait up on my account.
I'll see what I can do and speak to you and next to you on
my dreams.
care sister we'll sort this out all right nice you make it
sound so effortless all right eight more to go guys eight
more to kill we're not doing anymore here i just wanted to
go up i didn't want to go down tell me me again hey when do
i wake up i wanted to go up to limpus sagreus i'm counting
on you all right back here i'll go where's lord morrow Yeah,
where is he?
Oh, five more.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Deft of Kronos.
Oh my God, there we go.
Finally did it.
My protection, I dispel.
For I am ready now for heaven as for hell.
We're not completing it all on today's stream, guys.
I just wanted to go up.
You brought the Titan low.
yeah back to back after that was your bygone brother more
cooperative I just wanted to see what's up he doesn't know
where to find Kronos though seems willing to investigate
perhaps he'll turn something up I still scarce believe it's
truly his past self I've spoken to imagine how he feels
continue to check up on him but not a word of this to
anybody else time flows ever forward And we are not meant to
travel opposite that stream All right, you did it.
Oh, hey new stuff.
Oh moon dust be well And then I can also get more psyche.
Yeah, fuck it.
Let's just get more psyche.
I think it's always just psyche How much do I have okay 845
all right What you said to me before about my mother?
Yeah, it's very cruel and yo mama me fair enough can't kill
each other here but we can use our words if we were fighting
for real I wouldn't have held back either I figured not all
right yep oh you want to talk okay give me a sec I need that
stuff plant poppy seed and wheat seed I have too much night
night shades anyway I heard your efforts to bring Cerberus
back to his senses was successful least temporarily goddess
he bounded off to Tartarus only to be cast out into the
fields again that's what I gathered yes I can't just bring
him back home yeah my father whom I happened upon bound in
chains Kronos is torturing them mocking them Kronos is using
them to get at you instilling you emotions that compel you
to throw caution to the wind remember wars are one and lost
in hearts and minds Did you not act on your emotions in your
mortal days?
Yeah, didn't your whole fucking crew died?
Oh, oh.
I guess he doesn't want to talk about it.
I mean, understandable.
Should be able to head to the surface now.
Oh my god, thank god, finally.
Thank fucking god.
I have enough.
150.
Oh, I can get psyche now.
Let's just grab some psyche real quick.
One, please.
How much do I need?
That's fine.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Any minor fine for a major fine?
Their location rewards at least chance to deal critical
damage with death.
Fuck it.
I have enough of that.
Just in case.
Should work.
Alright, grab this out of here.
I will be done.
First be a little cautious here.
What was that?
I don't think I have...
Um...
Aspects yet.
Above the way to Olympus.
Oh hey, it's a full moon.
Let's go.
Alright, let's go!
Finally!
Olympus time!
What does that look like?
Hello.
Wait, what the fuck?
What?
What are you doing on the surface, young lady?
How shall you survive?
Surely you know your line is bound beneath the earth.
Your strength is better spent against our foes down there.
I can take them.
I beat up Kronos.
I don't fucking know bits, I guess.
Yeah, fuck it.
This is not the guys.
Oh, my God.
What is this?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Where are these guys?
Rest again for now.
Oh.
What?
I...
Oh, my God!
The ill-fated princess feels her life force fade with every
breath of surface air.
Her soul recourse is to return whence she came.
Oh, no.
I can't breathe.
Okay, we gotta do fast.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh, my God.
This is so bad for me.
Mining, mining, mining, though.
Oh, my God.
I can't breathe.
I can't breathe oxygen.
O2.
O2 is bad.
Quick, get the prize.
Didn't you, Sunshine?
I thought your birthright meant you couldn't live up here.
Oh, yeah, no, no, no, no, it's true.
I mean, I'm going to be taking damage all the time.
What's this?
Oh my god, what the fuck do I do?
What is this?
Oh, wait, but there's hammer, though.
Oh, this is so bad for me.
No, I'm dead
Pick a door Any door So Apparently Apparently she can't
breathe oxygen Oh too bad Well the fates decided long ago
That those of your line could not survive there And would
always be forced back to the underworld
palpable I never intended to stay for long just long enough
to lend my relative support but it's yeah that lasted like
two minutes well I don't see them around right now do you
incidentally there was once an incantation that I happened
upon which was not intended for my eyes but I now choose to
think that it was Oh, thank God.
Alright.
It literally was like a fish out of water.
Oh my god, yeah, I couldn't breathe yet.
It's literally like they chucked the fish onto land and it
was like, survive.
You must remember something of life on the surface, right
Dora?
Anything at all?
I wonder what it must have been like.
I don't remember.
And I don't wonder.
This is the life right here.
My greetings.
Thank you for visiting me last night, Lord Moros.
So, hypothetically, if I were to complete a certain
incantation that somehow loosened the grip the three fates
have on my birthright.
I mean, they're technically in prison, so they shouldn't
care.
Please understand, Princess, that I am not at liberty to
give advice on matters such as that, not even
hypothetically.
I trust I've been sufficiently direct in putting it this
way.
in other words we shouldn't be talking about this at all and
i assume all risk for my actions related to any potentially
forbidden incantations that i've learned damn it's like
legally speaking i can't do all this but hypothetically
maybe you could do this yeah that's a loop yes yeah the
loophole so they don't know oh no i won't succeed all right
so what can i do on the surface to survive.
Oh, remove the...
Oh, wait, no, it's not this.
Uh...
What would save me?
Do I even have anything that would save me?
I don't have anything.
Unraveling a faithful bond.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, it's up here.
Sorry, I was down here looking at it.
Oh, there you go.
What the fuck are all these?
The thalamus and moss the fuck is the fuck is that okay i
guess i gotta figure out how to get a thalamus like a
plumbus sounds like a goddamn plumbus the surface i can't
imagine that played out particularly well at least you made
it back at all i know the moss from the surface it was
draining even at night something about being under the stars
i it's chaos gate okay A lesson learned and an experience
gained.
The fates themselves do not want you up there.
What shall you do?
I have an incantation to complete.
I don't need to stay forever on the surface.
I just need to hold on long enough to make it to Olympus.
We're going to call it here.
I'm tired.
I went to, I tried to go to Olympus.
I got in two minutes.
That's enough for me.
That's enough touching grass for me.
me she and that we the same we touch grass for two minutes
and then we fucking died that was fun that was really fun um
fuck that bitch eris that's the last thing i'll say about
that until she fucking appears again uh because i wouldn't
finish the game by now she actually that horror i'm sorry
i'm so mad about her i'm mad i had to get punished for just
being good at the game i said i want to put in my two cents
about that fucking bitch anyway guys i i had a great time
playing like i said i love roguelikes and you know haiti's
too haiti's too scratches that roguelike game uh roguelikes
for me uh at like roguelike itch oh my god my brain is so
frazzled right now i've been i've been playing for so long
uh all my homies hate eras um but thank you all for watching
guys uh maybe i don't know about i don't think we can
complete this game obviously by in the next playthrough but
we'll see how far we can get on it next week hey guys i'm
gonna head out okay i'm gonna start the stream for tomorrow
the no players online 30 minutes later uh i'll do it at 1 p
.m instead of 12 30 because i think i need a little bit more
gap in between the two streams anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated pause check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you suffer me head to bed
cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye i haven't had a lot of he's just really fun i'm
glad i waited until now to play to play the full game hey
guys bye everyone bye